hello everyone and welcome to simply
learns youtube channel today we'll be
taking you through the react and
typescript full codes
this course will cover every important
aspect of both react and typescript
in this video we'll go through the
difference between them and the
similarities between react and
typescript by the end of this tutorial
you guys will be able to implement both
react and typescript in different ways
so before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technology videos so if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and press that bell icon to
never miss any updates from simply
so without any further delay let's get
started
let's go through the agenda for this
full course tutorial
we'll start this video with what is
react and cover fundamental topics like
react components react props and stay
following that we'll use react to create
an app from scratch
then we'll go through the comparison
between javascript frameworks like react
angular and view
we'll then go through what is react
native and finally we'll create a
project using react
upon completing react we'll move on and
cover type script as well
we'll cover everything you need to know
and understand about typescript
we'll see what typescript is and will
then cover the difference between
typescript and javascript following that
we'll cover topics like typescript
generics and how typescript is used with
react and nodejs
at the end of this video we'll go
through typescript projects and some
commonly asked interview questions
i'm sure that you guys are excited to
dive deep into it so let's start this
video with what is react react is a
javascript library used to create fancy
user interfaces for mobile and desktop
applications
it is widely used and is preferred over
other frameworks for front-end
development
so if you wish to learn web development
then you're in the right place
this video covers all the necessary
topics to give you a good understanding
of react and some of its concepts
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
so here's what's in store for you
we'll begin with a quick introduction to
react and then move ahead with react
installation on windows
later we'll look at some of the
fundamental concepts like react
components
props and state
then we'll build an application from
scratch using react after that we look
at a comparison between javascript
frameworks like angular vue and react
we're also going to be covering topics
like react.js with node
react with redux and understand what
react native is
we look at another detailed project
using react it will help you understand
the library better
after that we'll understand topics like
react hooks react router and then we'll
conclude the session by looking at some
of the commonly asked react interview
questions
now without further delay let's begin
in today's video we'll be learning all
about react.js so let's jump in and see
what's in store for us so we'll be
covering topics on what is react why
react features of react react
prerequisites and its industry trends
let's go ahead and begin with what is
react react is a javascript library used
to build fast and interactive user
interfaces for both web and mobile
applications now one thing that makes
react extremely powerful is the fact
that it's open source any user can
access its source code modify it and
enhance it in a typical model view
controller architecture react defines
the view part of the application it is
also responsible for how the app looks
and feels fun fact react was built by
jordan walkey an engineer at facebook
now let's go ahead and see how react
works in real time consider a typical
web application say instagram the entire
ui of the web page is divided into
several components we have the search
component a profile description
component stories component and a
post-list component these components
make the code easier to debug and always
remain discrete components also make
development and maintenance of web
applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the act helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual dom and one
way data binding we'll learn about these
topics a little later in the video react
uses reusable components now this helps
decrease the development time react
involves unidirectional flow of data
react also has a small learning curve
compared to other frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to javascript using jsx
we can add html to the javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of javascript and html now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a javascript notation h1
tags indicate html again the semicolon
indicates javascript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom that is
exact copy of the real dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual dom with the virtual dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
dom as discussed earlier virtual dog
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding this means information
flows in only one direction one way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
facebook instagram pinterest skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses flux implements unidirectional flow
which makes it easier to understand what
actually is going on now let's see how
it works when we trigger an action the
dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal api of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state and props are the essential
concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a javascript class having some state
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
components more dynamic it is important
to define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of html tag attributes now consider the
following code snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that
moving on let's go through some of the
things that you should know before you
can actually start working on react you
should be familiar with programming
concepts like functions objects arrays
and classes one should also have a basic
knowledge of javascript and a
familiarity with html
don't worry if you feel like you're not
good at them once you start working on
them you'll get a good hang of it
finally let's go through the impact of
react on the it industry and get
insights into the salaries of react
developers statistics show that react
developers earn way more than other web
developers according to pay scale the
average salary for a react developer in
the united states is a whopping 91 000
us dollars the average salary for a
react developer in india is 7.25 lakhs
per annum over the recent years react
has gained immense popularity and is
being adopted by many companies
according to the data by google trends
react has had a better growth scale
compared to other frameworks like
angular and vue statistics show that
front-end developers have wholeheartedly
adopted this lightweight framework
foregoing other available options if you
are skilled and have a knack for
front-end development react can help you
gain fantastic career opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use react devotionally we have
facebook instagram netflix dropbox
whatsapp among others in today's video
we'll be learning all about react
installation on windows so without
further ado let's get started to set up
the react development environment we
need two things installed node and a
text editor of your choice so let's
begin by installing node.js we can head
to the official node.js website save
download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so i'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
i'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download vs code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it
first
react now open your command prompt now
you can type in the path for the folder
that you just created so say
cd
[Music]
users
first yeah now go ahead and type in the
command npm
install
hyphen g create
react
app okay so this command installs all
the necessary react.js modules now to
check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in
create react
app version so you can see the version
here now let's continue and develop your
react application type in the command
create
react app
and you can give a name to your
application so i say my app
now this should take a couple of minutes
okay once you've successfully created an
application
they say to begin by typing the
following commands so let's do that save
cd my app and npm start this should
typically start your application and
here we go
all right you can also open your
application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file
open folder go to your desktop or the
drive that you saved your folder in
first react
my app and i say select folder so as you
can see all your modules have been
imported you can click on app.js and
start editing in today's video we'll be
learning all about the most basic
infrastructure of react.js called
components without delay let's begin and
look at what's in store for us so we'll
be touching on topics like what are
components types of components nesting
components higher order in pure
components and a brief description about
component life cycle all right to begin
with what exactly are components
components are the building blocks of a
react application wherein each component
represents a part of the user interface
now to make it more understandable
consider the facebook home page the
entire ui can be broken down into
several elements say we have the
credentials component the sign up
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks alright reusability is one of
the salient features of react components
one component can be reused several
times across the application and this
improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels a component
can also receive properties from its
parent components also you'll get a
better understanding of all of these
when we start working hands-on so don't
worry so moving on let's look at the
different types of components first we
have the stateless functional components
and then we have the stateful class
components now functional components are
typical javascript functions that return
html now they can be contained in a dot
js or a dot jsx file coming to class
components these are regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
html they can also be contained in dot
jx or dot jsx file okay then let's go
ahead and build our first react
application using components alright so
i've opened my text editor that is vs
code to build my application also i
suggest you watch the react installation
on windows video to help you get started
the video briefly explains how to
install node and how to start building
your first react application in my case
i've opened a folder called react
component tutorial and here in my source
folder i have app.js now app.js is the
main component that gets rendered to the
dom let me show you that here in
index.js you pass app.js which is a
component that gets rendered to the
react dom so app.js consists of several
other components that can be nested so
as you can see app.js is a functional
component and before moving on let me
get rid of all the unnecessary code so
let me delete all of this
and return
an h1 tag that says hello welcome to
simply let me save it and if you look at
the browser you'll have hello welcome to
simply learn now let's go ahead and
display another message say h1
this
video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser it gives you an error
so jsx uses a conventional rule which
states that all html tags have to be
enclosed within a div tag so for example
i say div
and i enclose it so let me save and
check my browser again here you go so
multiple html tags have to be enclosed
within the div tag moving on let's
create a first functional component to
do that i'll first create a folder in my
source folder say components within that
i'll create a file say
functional component dot js all right so
the first thing we have to do is import
react so i say import react from
yeah the general syntax for a functional
component involves the keyword function
and say
functional
component
now you say return an h1 tag or i've
already used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general syntax for a class
component so i create another file say
class component dot js i again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class react.component
so going ahead i say class class
component extends react dot component
now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so i say render
within braces i say return a paragraph
tag saying this is
the class component all right so moving
on let's see how these components can be
nested into the main component that is
app.js components can be nested into the
main component using import and export
keywords so as the name suggests export
feature is used to export a particular
file or a module and import is used to
import a particular file or module into
the current existing module so we have
two different types of exports you have
default export and just export or named
export so a default export is used to
export just one object be it a function
a class a variable from the file and
there can only be one default export per
file and when you're importing it you
can specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our editor and
then functional component and here i say
export default and the name of the
function component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js i say import
name of the functional component that is
functional com from and i pass the path
this components slash functional
component also let me get rid of these
unnecessary
files here now let's define functional
component in our app.js component so
here i say functional comp let's compile
it and check our browser here it says
this is a functional component moving on
to my class component it's the same
syntax here as well i say export default
name of my component and in my app.js i
imported
import class comp from
the path and again i'll have to define
it in my return method i save so let me
compile it and check my browser it says
this is the class component one unique
feature of default export is that i can
rename the file while i'm importing it
so for example i can rename it as say fc
and while i'm defining it i'll have to
make sure i use the same naming
conventions so i say fc again and when i
check it it says this is the functional
component there is literally no
difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so i'll
just copy paste this
let me give it another name say class
com1 and the message that i want to
display is hey i'm another class all
right so when i'm exporting it i don't
want default so let me take it off and
say export here all right
in my app.js while importing it i want
to import both the classes so i'll
include them within curly braces here i
say class com comma class comp 1 and
then again i define it here class comp
one let's compile it and run it and here
we go here you can see hey i'm another
class so we've successfully exported
both the classes from the class
component and imported it back in our
app.js component one advantage of using
named export is the fact that i can
choose to import the classes that i want
to now say for example i do not want to
import class component here so let me
take it off and here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
hey am another class the second class
got imported while the first class i was
defined earlier is not imported here all
right so next up we have higher order
and pure competence now i won't get into
the nitty-gritties of it because they're
advanced topics but to give you a brief
insight higher order components are
basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click
dot js all right so here we define a
class i use the snippet rce here we go
we get the entire format using the small
snippet rce and here i'm going to make
use of a button now see i use the tag
button and i'll say
clicked
one time every time the user clicks on
the button the value gets incremented so
for this i'm going to use a variable say
count and i'm going to use the concept
of states so let's go ahead and define
our variable count and initialize it to
zero so for that i'm going to use
another snippet called r const and here
this dot state equals my variable count
initializing it to 0. so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
i say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button the
count value has to get incremented right
so we make use of an event called on
click equals
this dot
update click
now update click is going to be another
method that we have to define now so
every time the button gets clicked this
method is called so let's go ahead and
define the function so it is update
click equals is going to be an arrow
function and i say
this dot set state is nothing but count
this dot
state dot account plus one okay and here
we say count times all right so once
this is done let's import our component
in app.js so here again
i say import click from components click
and let's define it here so let's check
our browser every time we click on the
button the value gets incremented all
right so let's go ahead and create
another component say counter.js wherein
every time the user hovers the mouse on
the button the count value increases so
let's go ahead and do that i say
counter dot js i'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag i
define a button and say incremented
to for now i say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event say button
on
mouse
enter
i'm going to call the method this dot
increment count okay so once you're done
with that let's go ahead and define the
increment count method i'm going to copy
the same code that i've mentioned in my
click.js so i say copy this all right so
one change is that i change the name of
the method and
call it increment count again let's
define the count in our render method so
i say const count equals
this dot state and here i change x to
com now let's go ahead and import it in
our app.js so i say import counter
from
components and counter and let's define
it here all right let's save it and
let's run the code okay so as you can
see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time i
move my cursor on the button it
increments mind you i'm not clicking i'm
just hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our hoc
let's call it
higher order dot js okay so i say import
react
from react after that i say const
updated component equals
original component that's going to be an
arrow function again and within curly
braces i define my class that is class
say new component extends
react
dot component inside let's define a
render method
that returns the original component with
a modification that is i want to type
the user i want to append the user
before the actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return new component and
let's export this say export
default updated component
now we import higherorder.js in our
counter.js and click.js and pass these
components as parameters so let's do
that let's go to our counter.js and here
i say import
updated component
from
dot slash higher order component and
here while exporting i say updated comp
and pass this as my parameter let's do
the same to click.js here i import
data.com from higher order component and
here i pass this as a parameter now here
in a higher order component we've
defined a property name and initialized
it to the user so we'll have to include
this in our other components that's
counter and click so let's do that and
here right before incremented to i say
this dot props dot name let me save it
let me do the same thing here and say
this dot props dot name so if you go
back to our browser here you can see it
says the user clicked zero times and the
user incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react a
pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you'll learn about
this method a little later in the video
now this method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom but a pure
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a read ender is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component now using
this example i'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a
purecomponent.js file i say pureform.js
so here i'm going to use a snippet rpce
that is going to create a pure component
class let me get rid of this export and
here in my div tag i'll display the text
say i'm
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create a regular component
let me call it
regularcomponent.js and here i'm going
to use the snippet rce and the message
that i want to display is
i'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pure component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here i'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here i
display the message i am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we are going to make use of a
constructor so let's use the snippet our
const and here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead i'm going to make use of the
method and say component
did mount and here i say set interval
the first argument is going to be an
arrow function and the second will be
the time interval and i'm going to be
setting it to 3 seconds now within the
arrow function i'll make use of the set
state function to set the state of my
property however i do not change the
name i keep it simply on itself moving
on let's import pure component and the
regular component into a parent
component and then pass name as a
property so to do that first import pure
comp
from pure component and then i say
import regular comp from
regularcom.js and here let's say regular
comp name
equals this dot state dot
name and i say pure component name
equals this
dot state dot me now let's include the
property name in both our regular and
pure components so to do that let's just
say this dot
drop dot name and here i again say this
dot prop dot name and finally let's
import parent component into our app.js
component so here i say import parent
com from okay and here let me define
parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have i'm the parent and regular
component simply to set the state and
we're going to set the state for search
results to whatever is passed by the
system so the search results are going
to be returned as a callback and that's
what we store as an updated state now
coming to the add track method so let's
scroll up and we'll say add track and
this will take the track to be added
let's declare a temporary variable
called tracks equal to this dot the
current state of all the tracks that are
there in the playlist now if track start
find i'm going to call the find method
so if we are able to find which means
that the track is already there in the
playlist then we would not want to add
it if it's not there in the playlist
that's when we would want to go and add
it the triple equal to is an equality
operator that will check for both a
watch value match and a match on the
data type as well okay so if the track
is uh already saved to nothing if the
track is not safe just track the track
id because that is the track that will
uh have to be added if it's not if it's
already there then just return if it's
not there then we've got to go to this
variable called tracks we'll use the
javascript method called push and we
will push the current track into this
tracks array and then update the state
so we want to set the state of the
playlist tracks
and this is how uh your state management
that we discussed in detail is actually
being practically implemented here okay
so the track has been added now let's
talk about the remove track so that's
the remove track function and that's the
track that we want to remove so let's
let tracks equal to this dot state dot
playlist tracks those the set of current
tracks that we have and
let track search another temporary
variable equal to this dot the current
state of the search results then let's
take the tracks array equal to track
start filter so filter is of javascript
function that will again allow you to
remove a certain value create a
temporary variable called current track
use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id is
not equal to the track dot id which
means this particular track is not there
in the list okay so you need to remove
that and again i have a method called as
unshift which will actually get rid of
the track in the array and then we've
got to so we'll search whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is then we simply want to remove it
if not we do nothing so we set the state
we need to update the state of the
playlist because the track has been
removed so the playlist tracks will have
to be updated with this tracks array
okay then we go for remove track search
that's the next method that also will
take a track as a parameter okay here we
are going to say let tracks which is
another temporary variable we'll give it
this current state of
search results and then we're going to
say tracks equal to tracks dot filter
current track current track dot id not
be equal to the track dot id and then
this is where we would want to say this
dot
set state
and we'll pick up search results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated uh set of tracks
after making the change let's remove
this and correct it okay so that's fine
so the remove track uh
is now the remove track in the remove
track search is now in place let's add
the do these functions which actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say this dot add track okay
so it adds the track and then it removes
the track from the search criteria so
the search component which is managing
searching of the tracks it will go and
remove it from there after adding the
new track so that's a combined
operation we want to execute then i've
got update
playlist name which will take the name
of the track to update and this dot set
state the playlist
name is what we need to update with the
name that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists
so
here let me create a constant variable
constants are variables whose values
will not frequently change we'll take
all the track uris dot state dot
playlist tracks
will be dot map create a temporary
variable called track track dot url so
we actually want to go and uh now save
this on uh
spotify so that's the reason we'll
access
spotify's safe playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name comma track uris
and if that is successful we then go and
do a callback so that's the callback
anonymous function where we're going to
say this dot
set date and the playlist
name that we want to create on spotify
will be called new playlist so that's
the custom name that i want to provide
and the playlist tracks
define that this closes here
okay so that's for the update on
spotify
now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
javascript and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your html view uh and
synchronize and bind the data together
so it helps uh from a maintainability
perspective so even though everything is
in the same file it's well classified
and differentiated into different code
blocks so we'll add the anchor tag and
we'd say href is http localhost so
that's the default server port on which
this application will run okay and we
want to give it a custom url name of
musical file so the h1 terminates will
then say div class name equal to app
within that this is how we're going to
inject a search bar that's going to be
the search bar component injected here
and on search so that's the custom event
we will call a method called search so
on search we just call we bind to a
method called this dot search then we'll
open up another div here we'll have
class name equal to app dash playlist
and if you remember that's exactly the
css
class name that we refer to in the css
file we have another component called
search results
that we are going to inject here
and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to this dot
state dot search results so that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be displayed with the data
bound and if somebody says add if if i
click on the add button for search
results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist by calling binding to
the 2ds function and it will remove it
from the search results text box then we
have another component called playlist
and here the playlist tracks
will be bound to this dot state dot
playlist tracks okay so on the top if
you look here we started with defining
all the function declarations in the
constructor then we provided the
function definitions okay that's how and
this that we passed refers to the
context of the current
component itself so whatever you put
into the app component or into the
respective component those values will
be then passed out here to these
individual functions okay so that's with
the playlist couple of things we'll have
to do is
if somebody changes the name of the
track so on name change is going to be
another custom event where we'll have to
call this dot update playlist name and
we also have remove functionality so to
remove a track we would say equal to
this dot remove track on save equal to
this dot
save playlist okay so that's done and we
close this so we seem to be pretty much
on track the export
app will make this all of these
functions accessible across other
components it's very similar to the
public access specifiers etc that you
provide
in other programming languages so that's
done we've created our app component now
let's create another folder under
components and we've got to define all
our various components here this folder
is going to be
for the search bar so we'll name it
search bar we'll add two files within it
the search bar dot css okay and another
file that we'll need here is
search bar
dot js
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file so we'll
start with first styling search bar we
will say that the display should be flex
flex
direction should be column we want all
the items to be aligned at the center so
that's align item center then we'll add
up padding so padding top
is going to be
6.94 rpm and
margin
bottom is going to be
6.33 rem all right now let's add up for
the search bar so that's search bar
we'll add
for the input element we want the width
to be 287 pixels the padding to be 0.88
0 the border should be 1 pixel solid
white the border radius
will give a slight rounded edge to give
a web 3.0 look and feel so we'll set up
the border radius then we've got uh
margin bottom so we've got a potent
margin that we want to add up then we
have color so let's add up the color
c3f so that's the color black then let's
add text alignment of
center and let's add up a font size of
one rem okay so that's how we've set
this up let's add the search bar input
is going to be
so if someone focuses so focus is the
got focus so if someone clicks inside so
the end user goes and clicks inside the
text box so we change the outline to
none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
uh on input and if the input is
focused so that's the event that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search button so on the
search button the cursor will set it to
pointer so that's the cursor pointer the
width we set it to 8.11
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and zero the border radius
we'll set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly uh well defined search button
with a nice little border let's also add
background color hash
954 that gives me a color then i've got
my text alignment let's set that to
center then we've got
a font family let's set up the font
family to the same standard font a t
and it's a part of the sans serif family
then we'll set up the font size
to zero 0.833
rem correct this
and finally
we will need
transition so all of these are basic
css properties so that will add a slight
uh transitional effect with a delay of
that many milliseconds
so transition background color we've
provided what else let me scroll up uh
let's also provide a border here so we
remove in fact let's remove the border
we we would not want a border on the
button that would look odd so i'll get
rid of the border and color we'll
specify
as per our standard color that we've
been using okay so that's the color
we've specified and then i've got font
weight of 500. finally we'll take uh the
search button and on the search button
we will register for the over event so
if someone takes their mouse over the
button that's the over the event in that
case uh if we hover around the button we
would want the background
color to change so it will appear to
have a slight little glow there
a mouse pointer moves over the button
okay so that's the opacity and
the rgb combination so that completes uh
the css file for the search bar and we
obviously now
need to go and
get the code in for
our search bar component and that's
exactly what we are going to do next so
let's start with setting up the code for
the search bar first thing let's go and
import react from
react
next thing we would want to do is import
the search bar dot
css file then we define our class
called search bar which extends
react dot component we define our
constructor and we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state we'll just need one variable
here which is
the term to search for in the search bar
and then let's say this dot
will define a function called handle
term change which is going to be equal
to this dot handle handle term change
dot
find so that's going to be the first
function then a function that will do
the searching for us
which is this dot search so that's the
search function and we'll have it bind
to this
then we've got this dot
handle enter so the moment we enter into
that search text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is handle term
change
we'll pass it a system defined keyword
of event this dot
set state
and for the term
we will use the event keyword we will
get
the value that is there inside that text
box the moment the search term the user
is entered changes so the search
criteria changes we trap the updated
value then in the search function we
will update
the local property props dot on
search
okay so we'll access the on search and
pass it the updated term and then we got
the handle enter on which uh we're also
going to pass the system define event
keyword so if there's any data flowing
along with the event we are interested
in it in this case the data is the key
code that the user is pressing and if it
is 13 that indicates uh that's the ascii
key code for the enter button so if the
enter is hit then the user is completed
entering the search criteria and we need
to start searching and that's where
we write our render method that's going
to render the html view and we return
the complete view here so that's the
view now that we want to return let's
say diff class name equal to search bar
then on the input text box we will use
placeholder equal to enter song album
or artist that you want to search for on
change
on the on change event the moment the
term changes we connect that to handle
term change we already have an function
that manages that and the moment
keys are pressed and released so on key
up is where we would want to connect to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
place bracket that i'll have to put up
here so in the render function uh we're
going to return a value i shouldn't
forget to export the search bar okay so
that's uh what i want to export so we've
exported that okay so at the end of this
what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written our div tag
here is where we'll go and close
the div tag we've added an input and
here is where i'm going to add a button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment the end user
clicks on the button we're going to
connect it to this dot
search and we close
the button back within the button tag
search so that
completes the
the render function so in the render
function again let's run through all of
what we've written we started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor passing props to the super
class constructor we created
state we set it to a value of
term and null so the state currently we
defined as term then we said handle term
changes search and handle enter should
be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render render we said is going to return
to us
the html that we've specified okay we
dumped all the html that we want this
component to return to us
so on change and on key up are both two
functions that
or two events that we connected to where
we called handle term change and handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event and
connected it to this dot search so all
the three functions uh that we uh had
actually written
uh so two things we've completed now uh
in the app class
okay if you look at the app class we've
actually defined a set of functions here
that deal with the playlist and adding
applications etc adding tracks delete
removing tracks
then we've created
the search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also we have specified a set
of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care to structure every
component separately so the search
component is doing something completely
different which is managing the search
bar we have the core the root app
component in which we have imported all
of the other set of javascript classes
uh that we are creating and that's how
the entire application is now structured
so and that's the core
concept when you're working with react
where you would actually have every
separate
block of
code or every separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether so we've completed the search
bar component as well so two components
done and two components good to go so
we've got to start up on the next set of
components that we will need to build
and the next component is the track
component that will manage individual
tracks so a new folder a new file called
track.css
and
track.js
so that's going to manage
the tracks for us
so let's start with dot track we would
say display is flex
align items
center border bottom one pixel solid
rgba
256
256
256 0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use all of
these classes
when we write up the html view we'll add
a padding here of 0.5 we'll set up a
font size
of
1.05 set up a transition color of
0.25 s
border of 0 pixel and
a background color of rgba
000 color hash
so that's the color that we continue to
use then we bring in track another class
track action and if we hover over this
class we want
the gb values
change to 265 265
265 5 is the last parameter so that's
the hover
then we have track information so track
information is the next class that we're
dealing with we'll add the flex
parameter first display flex
and
then flex
direction
is going to be column let's have justify
content set up as
center and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's a track information
let's have another track information and
the h3 tags
nested inside that
for all the h3 tags nested inside that
we'll need a margin bottom of 0.22
rdm finally let's have track information
and paragraph tag we'll have the font
size
of 0.83
rem and a font weight of 300
and a color as well that we'll add so
let's add up a color here rgba 2 6 256
256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's uh that's in
terms of the css
and let's move to
the track and we'll move into the
javascript file so let's move into
so let me take what we added in the
search bar i'll go to the track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor this will change to
add track so add track change this to
add track this is
remove track change this to remove track
get rid of this and that's going to be
the add track function and here we're
going to say uh
this dot props
so we'll modify this this dot
props
dot on add this dot props dot track and
then we have the remove track so that's
going to be the remove track function
this function is not required so this
dot props dot on remove and this is the
track that we would want to go and
remove we'll add up another function
called
render action so this is going to be a
function uh that we are defining called
render action and in this we'll just
check if this dot props dot is
remove
if this dot props
dot is
removable so in that case
we would want to return so this is a
view action method that we are adding
which is going to go and add this button
with a class called as track action that
we've already written the css for and
this button will actually get added
via this render action function and this
dot
remove track is
what it's going to map to
let's close this
this is going to point to this specific
function so that's uh the closing button
tag okay so the closing button tag is
what
we've added there and the binding is
what we have done to this dot
remove track and
we will terminate this here
so now the render action uh let's also
have the return here and we just add up
the button and this
is going to add track so you can look at
how the component is completely dynamic
uh in nature so we have two buttons that
are going to be added this button with
the hyphen is going to remove the track
this button with a plus sign is going to
add the track and you can actually see
how simply it was done in a render
action function so the render action
function actually helped
with
checking that if
on the value of the props
and if the user
depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
the class name here is now going to be
track the class name for
uh the enclosing div inside it so let me
get rid of this
the class name for the enclosing div
here is going to be track dash
information within it we'll add h3 we'll
bind to this dot props dot track dot
name so the name of the track is going
to get bound here then in the paragraph
we will find to this dot props
dot track dot artist
and
with some gap this dot props dot track
dot algo so that's what
we've data bound to
and then let me add an iframe an iframe
allows us to
very easily inject some content into the
page within a small embedded window the
source parameter of the frame is going
to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash
embed slash track and close this so
that's the spotify stream that we are
going to connect to and this dot props
dot track dot id so that's the track id
the width is going to be 300 the height
parameter this the height parameter is
going to be 80 of the iframe and
the frame
border is going to be zero and the allow
transparency so that's the opacity we'll
say true let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here and we can also have the
title set to preview so that's uh with
the iframe okay at the bottom is where
we would want to so this could be an
empty element and we can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part and then here i'm just going
to say this dot
render action so we call the render
action method uh which will actually
give us plus minus button to add and
remove a
new element okay and that's
what we can actually go and add up there
so let's check now whether
all that we've done is good to go fine
so everything looks good
in terms of the track component now and
we have all of the functions in place
it's now time to jump into the
next component that we would require
after the track component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list component
that will comprise of a list of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this track list
and that's going to have
track list
css
and it's going to have
track list dot js
so that's the track list
component now which
we're going to go ahead and use
and the css we don't need much
so let's just say track list
and we just provide a width of 100
okay that's all we need uh in the css so
let me add this in the css file save
this
and come to the js file now which is
going to have uh the track list code
that we will need to add up so here
again i'm going to say import react
from react we'd also want to import
track list dot css
and
we
also want to go and get track because
this component is going to be made up of
a collection of tracks individual tracks
so we want to get this from track slash
track and we'll define class track list
which is going to go and extend
react dot
component
we just need the render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself it
simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks
so this class name is going to be track
list
and we'll bind to this dot props dot
tracks dot
map create a temporary variable
and this will go and return
the track component
which is going to point to individual
track data the key is going to be track
dot id so the key is going to be track
dot id
and on add on adding a new track we want
to bind to this dot properties dot and
we already have on add defined so that's
what we'll connect to we add up my
base bracket here okay and
then we would also need
is removal
equal to
this dot props dot is removal and the on
remove
will do this dot prop start on remove so
that's for the track removal and
so we've got our track list
oh yes we'll have to go and
also close the tip tag correctly and
also we need to go and export so we'll
have to go and export
the track
list
so we've got one more component done
which is track list and let's move on to
the next component now so we've got app
which is root we've got the search bar
that takes care of entering the search
criteria we've got individual tracks
that are searched and returned and we've
got a track list that manages a set of
track records so the track is more
relevant to the playlist and then we've
got the search results also to manage
once we search for some
set of tracks so we'll add a new folder
which manages search results
and this is going to have
search results dot css
and it's going to have
search results dot js
okay so we need a search results dot css
and js and here in the css file we'll
keep it simple for the search
results so we'll say search results
we'll set up the width of 50 percent we
set up the height of 950
pixels we'll say
overflow y is
scroll we'll say padding is 0.88
rem background color will be rgba
95
23 23 0.7 and we will use the box model
so we'll provide a shadow dropping
shadow of 0 4 pixels
2 pixels ash
and then
let's add
a scroll bar so
webkit
and m0z are the constants specific to
mozilla and
chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants and then we'll also add a
media query that if it goes with a max
with one zero two zero pixels
in that case dot search results
with is 90 percent
with a margin bottom of two are even
okay so
we're going to add hyphen so it's hyphen
webkit scroll path zero pixel width
and we've set
transparent background so that's that's
about it with
the css i need to get to the uh js file
now let's move to the search results
js file and
that's where we will now have to go and
add up
the component code for search results
and let me take
pick this up from track list add it up
here this will be
search results and
we need the results will return to us a
list of tracks so we'll have to get a
track list this would be track list
and
i'm just going to return class name will
also be search results so that's the
component and this is going to export
out search results so it's accessible
across
other components then we've got h2 with
results
let's go and create
track list with a set of tracks and we
will bind it to this dot props
dot search results
and on the on add we are going to bind
to this dot props dot on add so we
already have that so that uh basically
completes
search results and
that leaves us with the last component
which is going to manage the playlist
for us so we'll add up a new books we'll
add up a new folder in components
and that's going to be playlist
and within that we will have a playlist
dot css
and
a playlist dot js
so that's our
playlist component now that
we're going to work with and the
playlist component is
uh we'll first set up uh
the css that we will need uh to add up
to the playlist and uh i'm just going to
pick that up from my code snippet so
that's my playlist and let me get all of
that css here so that's uh just the css
for the playlist nothing to do with
react again pure css
let me get
into the js file and that's where we
will need to go and add all of our
component code so again let me go to the
track.js
the track list rather let me get this
and add it
out here we'll make some small changes
this is going to be playlist
i need to import the track list
because the playlist is going to contain
a list of tracks
this is going to be
playlist and
let me
here this will be playlist and we'll
leave this
for later okay let me also get
the constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here and just one
function that we will need here which is
handle name change you know if i need to
change the name of the playlist so
handle name change and that's exactly
the function that we will need to write
code for so that's the event
and this dot props
dot on name change that's when we'll say
event dot target dot value so we get the
updated playlist name coming to the
render we now need the input
input is going to be on change equal to
this dot
handle name change
the default
value we have already provided with a
hard coded value which is new playlist
so that's the default value if
not provided then we'll just pick up the
default value then we've got
track list so track list is
what i will add the tracks i'm going to
bind to this dot props dot playlist
tracks
so we are going to bind this to playlist
tracks
and here we will say
is
removal equal to true and on remove
equal to we'll bind that to this dot
props
dot on remove
finally we'll need a button we will use
class name equal to playlist
dash
save that's what we've added in the css
click equal to this dot props
dot on save and here we're going to say
save to spotify so that's with the
playlist and yes we need to go and
export playlist and not track list
now we'll need to uh do a quick lookup
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in uh and create
an id it takes us to our dashboard uh
that's where we can create a sample
application the name of the application
will be musical file okay and
we'll say that we are building uh
some kind of desktop app for example for
which we want to uh connect this to and
we'll also need to provide
so we'll say next
refresh the dashboard so it's uh
asking me for a login so let me login
once more so moment i login that's going
to be description and i'll say maybe
this is why i need it i'll say no not
commercial integration agree with the
terms and conditions and we will say
submit
and that's the application that has got
created and now i can say edit settings
and
the redirect url here is what is
important
so it should accept connections from
http localhost 3000 that's the port on
which we will host our application
okay and we'll say save okay so that's
uh now there's a client id that is
generated here for my app which is
unique so i'll just copy that up let me
come up to my application under the
source folder i'm going to add a new
folder called util and under that a new
file called spotify.js
so we will start with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util folder the
first line of code is going to define a
client id variable that equates to the
client id that we will generate on
spotify so this is going to be the
spotify generated client id which is a
unique id associated for the developer
to connect to the spotify api and we
will look at
the source of that as we go through the
demo the next variable that we'll create
is the redirect url or let's call it
redirect uri and that will equate to
localhost colon 3000 which is the port
and we'll create another variable called
the access token let's also create
another constant variable called spotify
and this will work like a function
expression so we'll equate it to a
function called get access token and we
will say if access token is true then
return the access token now let's
declare a constant variable called
access token match
which will be equal to window dot
location dot
href dot match
and we will say this is equal to access
token which will be equal to and we will
give a rejects expression to do a
pattern match ampersand so that we can
actually get into the url and extract
the token information from that and
hence uh the pattern match is crucial
here another constant variable called
expires in match
equal to window dot location dot href
dot match here we will read the expiry
information using another edgex
expression from the url ampersand
asterisk so that's the second constant
variable we've created now we will say
if access token match and
expires in match in that case
the access token should be equal to
access token match of one then we create
a variable called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from the expires in match
that's done then we will say
window.settimeout
and we're going to say access token
equal to comma expires in multiplied by
thousand then we will say window dot
history dot push state and we will say
access token we pass the second
parameter as null the last parameter as
slash and close this and we will return
access token else
we will say const access
url equal to https
accounts.spotify.com
slash
authorize
client underscore id equal to dollar
client id ampersand response type equal
to token ampersand scope equal to
playlist dash
modify so we are actually building the
url that will now get generated so we'll
say modify dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect uri so we
have constructed the url now that will
go out and get generated in the browser
and here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access url then we'll
add the search criteria function which
accepts a term as a parameter to search
on here we will say constant access
token equal to spotify dot get access
token so we get a reference to the same
access token return we call the fetch
function and we're going to pass
https
api dot
spotify.com slash
v1 slash
search question mark that's the query
string that we will add type equal to
track and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization where we will say that
the bearer is dollar access token dot
then response
return response dot json dot then so the
return of this function once it
completes
we will then call the next function so
json response
and then we will say
return response dot json after that
another then block so we'll now say json
response
and if
not
json response
dot tracks
in that case we will return
an empty array else
we will return json response dot tracks
dot items dot and we will pass
we'll create track as a variable with a
lambda expression and we'll create a
temporary json object with id and that's
where we want to associate track dot id
that was returned as the search result
the name is going to be associated with
track dot name the artist is going to be
associated with track dot artists of
zero dot name the album is going to be
track dot album dot name and the uri we
will equate track dot url so that
completes uh this block will open the
next and we this will be the save
playlist which will take the name and
the track uris and here we will check if
not
name or not track uris dot len in that
case we simply return out of the code
and then we declare a constant variable
called access token which will be equal
to spotify dot get access token so we
get a reference to the access token we
then declare headers authorization
bearer is going to be dollar access
token and we'll create a user id and now
we will return the fetch result where we
will pass https
api dot spotify.com
slash v1 slash me so that's the url
comma headers
will be the header information then we
call the then function declare response
as a variable use the lambda expression
and access response dot json we use the
then block to declare json response
here we say user id equal to json
response dot id and then we return fetch
https
api dot spotify dot com slash v1 slash
users slash dollar of user id slash
playlist so this is how we have
constructed uh the urls manually here we
will say assign headers to the headers
variable we'll assign method as post so
the data is sent as part of the body and
not as part of the url and as the body
we will say
json.stringify to convert this parameter
name and then we will generate a
response variable to
response.json and then we'll create json
response with the lambda operation we'll
create a constant playlist id which is
equal to json response dot id we will
return fetch
https
api.spotify.com
v1 users
dollar user id slash playlist slash
dollar again we are constructing the url
so playlist id will be replaced here
then we will say tracks
and close this comma and here again we
will say headers would equate to the
headers
variable be constant headers and this
goes here okay everything fixed now so
here we're going to say headers should
equate to headers and
the method is going to be post and
the body is going to be json dot
stringify uris track uris and we close
this we close this block we close this
block and we close this block so that
completes our code of course one more
thing we have to do which is export this
class out so export default spotify and
that completes the code for
the spotify.js
which is part of our utils class so
let's move on now to the next step so
here is uh the client id that will have
to exactly match so i'll copy this
client id and provide it here so that's
the client id uh that we actually need
and we could also store it out here
so that's the
client id and that's the redirect url
that we've also defined there and we
just create an access token if here the
access token is true we return access
token so the access token is something
that we are going to do a match from uh
the moment we try and connect with this
particular url and you can look here
that this is the access url that we are
trying to connect with okay with the
client id and post fixed with the
redirect url right and then i've got a
simple search function which returns an
observable so we try to fetch data using
the search term that we provided okay we
try to fetch data using the search term
provided if we are successful we get a
response of the data and accordingly
we'll iterate over the json response and
get a list of tracks out of it and do a
mapping of this json object to the track
id name artist information album name
etc and here
just like a data access layer very
similar to a data access layer we've got
a save function which will save this
data to spotify as well so i've got a
save playlist and i've got search so
these are the two functions which
will go and connect to the spotify
service
by using this client id and it will
allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning a stream of json data and will
then allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we
actually need to start up the
application so i'll go to the terminal
and rather let me go to view and
bring out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens powershell from
which you can actually fire your
commands so i'm going to say node
package manager npm start to actually
start up this application so that's
going to do a full compile and uh
so we will fire this up give access so i
need to grant access
to that port 3000 let's give it time to
run and that's the app now that
you can actually see here so this is uh
the search bar that we actually had okay
then we had the results we had the
playlist
now the results is going to consist of
a set of tracks which are maintained by
the track list and then you can take
individual tracks with the plus and
minus button and add them into the
playlist okay so that's how
it's typically going to work okay so as
you can view here i'm just going to
search for an artist
and we'll click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says
that i need to agree to the terms and
conditions
and i've just agreed to that
so the very fact that it actually uh
gave us
a confirmation link
the moment we tried to connect and
execute our application
that's proof enough that it actually
went and connected to the
service there and tried to return a
value to us so this is what we did we
just added an artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons getting added on
the fly so that was the render action
these are
buttons that got added onto this list of
tracks dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist okay as in when i click here so
i've added a couple of tracks
if i go back to my dashboard of my music
or file application and that i've
created here in the developers portal of
spotify on
developers.spotify.com it's blank so now
i'm going to click on save to spotify
okay and that clears the playlist
so let me come here
and
now when i come out here we saw that it
actually got uh successfully connected
out here now i'll have to log in to so
this was the development app that we
actually created on the developers
portal of spotify now we will go to
spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and it says do you want to launch the
web player and all that so let me click
on that so it just launches and can you
see here this is the new playlist that
just got added right and there were four
songs that i'd actually added to the
playlist and you can see here those four
songs have got added out here okay so i
can go here and
i can delete this playlist and say i
want to delete it okay so there's no
playlist now i'll go back here
i'll add two tracks and i'll say save to
spotify so that's how you actually saw
that the new playlist uh you can see the
new playlist has come back here okay and
that's the playlist uh the playlist has
got generated again and that's the new
playlist that
got created and we deleted it but it
still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity
that we successfully created with this
react app and the core concept of the
react app was breaking it down into
components which is the search component
then we created the track component we
created the track list to maintain a
list of tracks
then we created the search results which
will generate a list of results which
further contains a track list and this
is the embedded iframe which gave us the
response which is scrollable here and
you can see that the iframes we created
allowed us to scroll this uh with this
embedded web page inside the iframe
container so with that uh i hope we've
been successful with explaining the
concept of component based design and
architecture with react and how
important it is to create individual
components and the benefit of that being
that you can isolate change request to a
certain component you can promote
reusability wherever you want the same
feature to be implemented on the page
you can just inject that same component
and the same implementation and the same
features can be reused so it promotes
reusability it promotes flexibility to
change it isolates your change request
to single components preventing the
massive effort of recompiling and
re-testing the entire application as a
whole in this session we'll be comparing
the three cutting edge ui development
technologies that is react.js angular
and vue we learn about the key
differences that make them so distinct
all of these technology stacks have been
replacing pure server-side technologies
and we've slowly progressed from
server-side applications to more
distributed applications where a part of
the job is done on the client side and
apart on the server side and now we've
transitioned to something known as
single page applications or sba and all
of these technologies that you see on
your screen right now are based purely
on javascript as a result they're
lightweight and aren't dependent on any
third-party runtime tools so let's
compare the three technologies and learn
about the factors that make them stand
out so let's see what's in it for you we
learn about their features use cases and
where they're applied their performance
how they handle data the languages they
use and the testing mechanisms we learn
about the dedicated user community that
backs these technologies and finally
we'll see the growth curve first we'll
look into the saline features now react
is a front-end javascript library while
angular and view are javascript
frameworks now although the terms
library and frameworks are used
interchangeably they're significantly
different now library is a set of
classes or functions and the user is in
complete control to call them frameworks
on the other hand are like models they
have limited choices and come with a
blueprint of their own and as a result
the user doesn't have much control so
javascript being an interpreted language
where code is executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment and would definitely
encounter a delay now these are avoided
and as a result these tools are fast
moving on react is used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single page applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack mainly because it's
purely based on css html javascript and
jquery single page applications as the
name suggests are built using single
page now the entire page is broken down
into several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component handles the
login the other one would display icons
and images and so on all these bits or
components are then put together to form
a single page application and moving on
react was developed and maintained by
facebook while angular was built by
google and view was developed by evan
unx google employee now react represents
the view part of the mvc framework and
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
in itself and view on the other hand is
focused on view and the model layer of
the mvc framework now what exactly is
the mvc framework now mvc framework is
an object-oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while vue deals with the representation
and the ui logic of the application and
the controller drives the functionality
of the two any changes can be easily
factored and isolated and as a result
testing becomes a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective in
terms of react we have top websites like
facebook instagram netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by nike hbo forbes sony and
vue is commonly used by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an html view and render it into
the browser this view to the user is
basically just html tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balanced tree
structure this b3 algorithm is extremely
fast so when the user makes any changes
to the ui the changes are reflected
immediately this is facilitated by the
b3 algorithm so as a result the
performance is improved so how does
react make use of this tool it uses a
virtual dom dom is an api developed by
w3c it stands for document object model
and defines how the document is accessed
and manipulated this dom parser converts
the html code into an inverse balanced
tree structure so react uses the virtual
dom while angular uses the real dom and
vue uses the virtual dom again now the
virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages and only changes the parts
that need to be updated angular on the
other hand updates the entire tree
structure regardless of any changes made
or not and view again only updates the
ones that have changed since there is no
time spent on making unnecessary changes
to the entire tree react is extremely
fast on the other hand real dorm
updation is time consuming risky and
error pro vue also ensures faster and
bug free performance
now let's talk about data binding the
core reason why we would use single page
applications now consider a scenario
where you log into an ecommerce website
as say user1 then you should be able to
see the items in your shopping cart
while user 2 would be seeing different
items in their shopping carts and so on
so identifying the user and retrieving
data corresponding to that specific user
is facilitated using the help of data
binding data binding is a process that
allows an internet user to manipulate
webpage elements using a web browser now
it is used in interactive components
such as calculators tutorials games etc
now react supports one way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa angular on the other hand uses a
two-way data binding while vue also uses
a similar two-way data binding in react
every time the model state updates the
view changes accordingly however the
reverse is not true in case of angular
any changes made to the view are
immediately reflected in the model part
of the architecture view follows the
same principle now this hugely
influences the performance due to
one-way data binding react is modular
and fast improving the performance
angular's two-way data binding adversely
affects the performance and view on the
other hand performs according to the
input type moving on to scripting
languages react combines ui templates
and javascript logic resulting in a new
language called jsx so react only
requires the knowledge of javascript
angular uses templates again in html you
can also inject javascript code into
html using a clever implementation in
angular called directives so you can
create a class and then inject it into
html angular also does something better
you can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax now vue again uses html based
template it uses html5 throughout for
the ui and the combination of javascript
for business logic all view templates
are valid html and can be passed by html
parsers let's move on to testing now
jest is a framework or an api that is
developed by facebook and is used to run
tests on react applications to ensure
that they are bug free now it is
embedded typically in every react
library and requires zero configuration
now angular on the other hand uses the
jasmine framework now this framework
allows various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases this also
ensures that the application is error
free the view cli or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
moca now view typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast now let's
talk about community support since all
these tools are open source they have a
large developer community there are a
few popular github repositories for
react such as react.js 101 react.js.org
and so on you can raise queries solve a
few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react here
are a few repositories for angular view
also has a few popular repositories you
can commit download third party plugins
and also explore these stacks even
deeper all of them surely have a very
happening community at the time of
writing there were about 1 million
repositories 5 million comments and 1
million issues with respect to react
here are the figures for angular and
here are the figures for vue according
to npm stat over the past two years
there have been approximately 360
million react.js downloads there have
been around 38 million downloads for
angular and around 63 million downloads
for view now let's look at the future
scope learning a new technology always
comes with questions like what's in it
for me what's its growth potential how
far will it take me in my career and so
on so let's go ahead and see the growth
rate of react angular and vue according
to google trends over the past 12 months
react has been on a way faster upward
trajectory than angular and vue which
have considerably lost their momentum
now this indicates that react is growing
faster than the other two with respect
to popularity industry adoption and
community support welcome to this
session on how to connect react.js with
node.js and in this session uh we are
actually going to look at
how do we connect react.js with node.js
so a very warm welcome to this session
on react.js connectivity with node.js
and in this session we are going to
focus on how do we connect our react.js
application with the node.js platform so
we are going to dive into creating a
hands-on demo which will have two parts
to it we would have the client
application that we will first create as
a react application we will then create
an express gs application with node.js
and we will then try to connect both of
those applications together so
express.js is a rapid application
development framework that allows us to
create a web application very quickly on
the node.js platform and we'll use it to
create a custom api and then connect
that endpoint to the react.js client
application so let's dive into our demo
and
let's start with creating our client and
node express applications and see how to
set them up and then get them connected
to each other let's start with our
hands-on demo and we will first go to
the node.js website nodejs.org we can
download the lts version which is the
stable version of node.js moment i click
on this it will prompt me for a download
it will download the msi file and then
all i need to do is double click on it
keep clicking on the next button and
install that would install node.js for
us next we'll open our editor you can
use any editor of your choice so i'm
going to use
an editor called visual studio code and
let's open up the terminal here and i
also have the command prompt open where
i've navigated to a folder that i've
created called react.js demos now we'll
invoke the npm package manager
which is invoked by the command npx so
npx will not only install packages but
also execute them once they are
installed so once they are downloaded it
will execute the package and
we will use npx to go and create a react
application called client so while we
give it time for the installation to
complete we can then open it
within our editor so we'll give it time
so that the installation completes
so the installation is completed and so
we have seen here that the installation
is now completed and let's
go and open up this project so i will
say file and open folder and
let me pick up that folder and we will
open this application called client so
that's my client app let's fire up
the terminal so
okay so that has launched the terminal
for us
and here
all we need to do to fire up this
application and get it running is npm
start which will compile and start up
this application that is created let's
close this we'll go to the browser and
now let's say localhost 3000 so that
gives us
a startup page the sample
default startup page for the first
client application and this is going to
work as a client we'll now go and try to
create
the back end
application which is going to be another
application that we will set up and to
create that
let's say npx
express
generator api okay so this will uh
create an express application on node.js
called api and let's give it some time
for installation okay so that's done
clear this screen we'll come out here
we'll open another instance of the
editor we'll say open folder and that's
the api application we'll say select
folder and the api application is opened
let's go to the terminal now in the
terminal we will attempt to install all
of the packages that are required that
would be logged in the package.json file
so the package.json file here would be
listed
so you can see we have a list of
packages that it uses and npm install
will go and install all of these
packages that were pre-listed here so
let me ensure it's executed correctly
and we'll fire that once more that's
done so npm install has installed all of
the packages required and let me
terminate this run by pressing a control
c so this terminates
the client application that was
executing and now we will say npm start
so that this application executes and
let's refresh
so that's the standard express
application now that has got installed
now let's go to the api application
we'll go into the bin folder and here
we'll have a file called www we will
change the default port number from 3000
to 9000 let me stop this application
from executing we've just updated the
port number now let's go to the routes
and we'll create a new file in the
routes folder called test api dot js
here we will say variable express
equal to require express
and here we'll say variable router equal
to express dot
router and here we will say
router dot get we'll open this
so that's the default route root route
is going to be slash for which we'll add
a callback function which will take the
request
and the response parameter and next
pointer in case there is another
function to call post that and here we
will just send a simple message saying
api is working okay a simple message
sent out for the root default route and
we'll have to export this so we'll say
module dot exports equal to router all
right so that's uh done let's go to the
app.js file and here let us import that
so here is where we will import this
by saying app.use we want to use the
test api file and that is
test api router and this is exactly the
same variable name that we will declare
here which will be equal to require and
we are going to say routes
test api all right so let's try
launching this now we would say npm
start after adding this code let's go
out here and 3000 test api is going to
be the url to hit it's not 3000 but 9000
now because we just updated the port so
9000 test api and there we have a
message which says that the api is
working properly so this is tested now
let's go to the client application in
the client application let's go to the
app.js file okay this is the file that
we would have to revamp a bit so let's
uh revamp this here we will declare a
class app which extends so that creates
a new module so it extends
react.component
and here we have constructor we will
accept the props here i would pass props
to the superclass constructor and
set the state to api response
currently it just has an empty value
next we'll add up a new function called
call api which will generate a call to
that
api url which was http localhost 9000
was the port and test api was the url
once this is called we will then call
the then function declare response
generate a call to response dot text
and then we will again say this dot set
state api response is going to be equal
to the response that comes in from that
url which is nothing but a string which
says api is working another function
called component will mount so the
moment the component is initialized on
the screen and loaded we will generate a
call to this function we created called
call api then comes
the render function in the render
function we would go and return a diff
class name as app this would be app
header the standard logo after which
in the paragraph we wouldn't need the
link here right after the header we'll
add a paragraph where we will print this
dot state and the variable we created
called api response and we will data
bind to that so that largely completes
uh the return so we simply create this
application that's the react application
that will talk to this api that is and
this
url that is hosted on node communicate
with it get a simple string as a
response print that string inside this
react application so once that's done
we have the component wheel mount which
is a life cycle method here it's a life
cycle event that gets triggered the
moment the component loads and that's
when
we have actually gone and executed the
call api custom function let's go to the
api application we'll terminate the
execution here there's one more step
that we'll have to perform which is
cross origin
resource sharing which means that to
allow the react application to
communicate from another hosted domain
to this particular domain server we will
actually have to enable cross origin
scripting and sharing otherwise it will
block the request coming from another
application so for that we'll have to
install globally cross origin module and
dash dash save indicates that it's going
to do a global install for all
applications
that are on this particular system so
we've installed this
and we'll clear the screen let's go to
the app.js
and right here is where we would want it
to go and use cards so we will say
app.use course so that it uses this
particular api and here is where we will
declare the course variable and go and
import the new library package that we
just installed which is quartz so looks
good and now let's
fire up this application with an npm
start let's also fire up client with an
npm start and now when i go and
try looking for localhost 3000 which is
the react application the react
application should go and talk to the
api that is hosted on node.js which
returns to me that string message so if
i go and ping that api separately which
is localhost
9000 test api you can see this is a
standard message so here i've directly
ping the api that's hosted in node.js
now we are consuming it through the
react.js application and if you scroll
down you can see the message returned
from node.js into react saying the api
is working properly so the practical
impact of this is to actually host
restful services etc on node as a server
and you can go and consume the data that
is returned there could be in string
text or json format directly into the
react.js acting as a client application
today we're going to cover react with
redux
so with our session today we're going to
go through it's going to cover why you'd
want to use redux when you're building a
react solution
what redux is what are the core
principles of redux and what are those
pillars that drive what you're doing
redux and then finally what are the pros
and cons of redux and after we've gone
through the powerpoint presentation here
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to go through and actually do a
demo of actually using
redux so you can actually see how this
would all look so why would you use
redux well the reason why you want to
use redux is that redux actually
understands and helps manage the state
of an object
and redux was introduced to help address
some problems that you're having with
react so the stage for an object stores
values and properties that belong to
components that could potentially change
over time so
the state could be modified by actions
in your network uh they could be
changes to the re-render of the
component in the browser and the object
could also then potentially store
multiple properties
and then with redux it actually takes in
and actually will create a
you know take a a large application that
you could create with app with a react
and breaks it down to several components
instead of having this massive number of
states you have to manage and so every
time that you you know an application
will then switch from a current with a
react you'd actually be then changing
the state and this is a a really big
problem because when you're like doing
that switching back and forth there is
the potential for applications to be
re-rendered which reduces the efficiency
of your application and so this is why
redux was introduced
so you know what is redux so redux is a
way to be able to have a predictable
state container for your javascript
applications they allow you to run your
applications in multiple different
environments so whether it's a client
solution a service solution or a native
app solution and then more importantly
um or one of the key
elements that i like about redux is that
it's really easy to test and so with
redux you're able to match the state of
your tool uh you can actually use it to
work with any javascript framework or
library
and you can actually then store the um
the application and the components in a
state store which makes it easy to be
able to manage the state of your
application so in simple words redux
stores all the state objects in a single
store and organizes it it provides
information about the current state of
the application any changes in the state
of the application can be described to
the store by the user and then it
notifies any modifications made to the
state of that application so let's jump
into the key principles of redux and
there's three key areas i want to focus
on so the first one is that redux
provides a single source of truth um and
that source of truth is uh being able to
store the state of your whole
application in an object tree in a
single store and this makes it easier
for you to debug and inspect
components of your application
uh also enables you to be able to
persist your app state for development
and improve faster development cycles
the second principle is a state is read
only and that's why you're able to
describe more effectively what's
happening because it is read-only and
this ensures that no events like network
callbacks
would uh
create and any issues with the code and
the re-rendering of your application
and that object actions are become then
just plain objects and then finally
changes are made with pure functions so
what do we mean by this so we can
actually
take actions and transform the state
tree with pure reducers and we'll go
into a demo later on to show you this
but a reducer is essentially a function
that accepts an accumulation value and
then it takes back and returns that as a
new accumulation and this allows you to
have a single source of truth value the
user can return the new state objects
instead of mutating to previous state
uh the user can
start with a single reducing as the app
grows it can then split off into smaller
reduces
and then finally the reducers just
become functions so let's talk about the
pillars of redux
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reducers
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree state
um and there are four key
states there's getstate which returns
the current c to the store and when we
actually run the demo later on you'll be
able to see that we'll be able to open
up our terminal window and be able to
get the state store from our terminal
window
the second state is dispatch and this is
a an action it's the only way to update
the application state and here we have a
action on a button change to actually
change the state of the application
and then the final two are subscribe
unsubscribe and these are our ways in
which you can actually change the
listener to the state
so an action is a plain object that
represents an intention to change the
state so with actions you have payloads
of information that send data back and
forth to your application store
so you can send any kind of data
that can go back and forth and that
actions must also have been a type field
that indicates the type of action that
has been performed and finally with
reducers reducers are um specify how the
application state changes in response to
actions sent to the store and so actions
only describe what's happened but don't
describe the application state change
they are reducer is a function that
accepts the current state and an action
and then returns a new state with the
action performed and then finally you
can use combined reducers utility which
can then combine reduces in an app into
a single a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using redux because nothing is perfect
so a pro for working with redux is that
redux provides a single source of truth
which is the store so there's no
confusion over where you're getting your
values
this then leads to having a predictable
and strict outcome redux is more
stringent about how the code is
organized this makes it easier to
onboard developers because there is a
very structured way of writing redux
code this makes it also then
easier for the initial render which
allows you to make your solution really
optimized as an experience and then
finally developers can track everything
that's going on inside the app in real
time the cons
so
one of the big cons is there's no
encapsulation so you're using redux to
test out the code and the writing of
your code
but the component cells can access data
and they there's potential for security
issues
you do have to use boilerplate code so
this kind of takes us back to the
structured code format it is um strict
in its setup and it is memory intensive
so with that let's go in and look at a
demo of using redux to
reformat a react application
so in this demo we're going to use react
to show how redux can work first thing
we want to do is go ahead and download
node.js we're going to go to nodejs.org
to get the latest download the downloads
are available in windows mac os and
linux you can also download and
recompile the source code if you want
i encourage you to go with the latest
lts version it's the latest stable
version now there are other versions you
can use but that's one you would want to
use i already have it installed so i
just want to show you how that looks so
i'm just going to go in and put
node dash version it's going to give me
the version number so that shows that
it's installed and we'll also use npm
which is node package manager because
we'll be using that validate that it's
installed by doing node mpm
version so okay so looking good and
we're going to go ahead and create a
folder um on our desktop
normally you wouldn't put
a project folder on your desktop but you
know this is just for an experiment so
we're going to call this one
redux react it's going to be taking a
react project and we're going to show
what it looks like as a standard project
and then what it will look like
as a project that's being
taken through redux
so let's just move our cursor to the
correct folder
and so we're going to go to cd
redux react
and there we are we're in at the correct
folder using our command prompt
you use terminal on mac os
so let's just type in mpx and that's for
our redux
and we're going to do create dash react
dash app so we're going to create a
default react app and then we'll also
install redux dash app
and these are the two
components that we need to be able to uh
build out our solution one is react and
it's react.js
and the second is redux and we hit
return
and this is going to go ahead and
download the latest versions of both of
these applications and install them into
the folder that we just created on our
desktop
just give that a moment
and so it's installing the different
packages react react dom react scripts
and there we are have everything
installed great
and these are just different commands
you can use
and it's recommending that we select npm
start
to get everything up and running so we
use visual studio code to do most of our
work here vs code
is open source solution for scripting
and it's available on all leading
platforms uh it is from microsoft but it
is open source
and
there's just a ton of stuff here but
we're going to go ahead and open up the
folder we just created on our desktop
and so here is redux react app
and we're going to select that folder
and on the left hand side you'll see all
the files from that folder which is
gonna get rid of the welcome screen we
don't need that anymore uh you'll see
there's some commands we use we do uh
control plus uh i'm not sure what that's
called again anyway it gets us to the
terminal window um
not an exclamation point
so you'll see that in our project folder
we have all of the files we need for our
solution we have both the node modules
and then the public files the product
files is just the application itself so
over here on the index.html you see the
index file there and we're going to
actually show what this looks like
inside
as it's broadcast from a web browser in
a moment now uh we're going to create a
very simple application here um and the
application is going to look exactly the
same in both um
just standard react and redux react it's
the optimization that's going to be
improved so we just did npm dash and
start it's going to take us to local
host call on 3000 give it a moment and
then we should get our
floating
uh logo showing that the application's
up and running up there we are
we can go ahead and head and edit app.js
to
create our application
okay so let's go in and we're going to
go into app.js
and we are going to create an
application called
new comp
dot js and we actually have some code
that we've already created that you can
download as part of this application
um so but we're just going to type in
here import react
and then component
from
[Music]
react
so i'm going to pull in our react
library and we also import
connect
from
react
redux
and that's the
package that we're working in
let's
terminate the batch shop yes
and then rerun
npm
install
dash dash save
react
dash redux
and there we go takes a moment just to
install that
so our goal here is to show
how you can optimize your solution with
redux for the uh using the store and
reduces in redux
again the solution is going to look
exactly the same what's going to change
is the performance of the solution
and this is what redux gives you all
right so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to go in and type in class
new comp
extends component
and then we're just going to select our
constructor
props
and then we want to add in the
super props
and then this
state
equals
we have a message here
subscribe
to simply learn
very simple little app don't forget to
save your work as you go along and we're
just going to apply some styles
let's just make the
apply some font style
like italics
then we're gonna
make the color
purple
and let's have a button that we're going
to press a
button change
equals
this set state
i'm sorry get state
and we'll have a message that comes up
basically saying thank you for
subscribing
there we go we have our button we'll
change the state here in a moment
and very simple
little application
and we want to rent that
on the screen
we just have some basic
html for where we're going to place
everything we use div tag
for our app
again we're going to keep this really
simple
and we're going to call we'll reference
this styles for
this h3 tag
and so our message is going to be
subscribe to simply learn
this will be created dynamically we use
our style
i'm going to add in a button
one click action
subscribe
and nope change too many s's
save that
all right let's see now let's run
that script
you're going to have js
and we're going to actually import that
into
our app.js script
rid of this
and then
and we'll extend
the news corp js
component into here
player in
font style here
and
render this correctly
and i'll pull in the text
and styles
again it's very simple little
application
now playing from use call
so we'll actually have
a welcome screen a welcome line and then
pulling the two lines of code
all right let's
run that
npm start
and here we go
refreshes our page
so what we've just created is a basic
standard state object
and oop
let's see now oh yeah this is good now
we actually can show you that uh we
didn't actually write all our code
correctly so let's go back and fix that
because newport news
newscomp.js and we have to make sure
that we
uh have a correct export feature here so
that the image that
everything can be exported effectively
import we also need to have an export
all right let's run that again
okay should take care of our
problem hey there we are so welcome and
then we have the standard set object of
subscribe to simplyline hit subscribe
and we change the text to thank you for
subscribing
okay so let's kind of go in and modify
this now so it goes from being a
standard state object to one that uses
store and reduces
so we're going to go ahead and terminate
our batch job
and since you reset everything
and what we're going to do now is
install redux
this is what's going to help us
it takes a moment to install redux
all right so we have redux installed
that's good
and now we want to
start
our package
and it looks the same but now we're
going to make some changes
so let's go
to our index file
index.js
here's our react dom
now we're going to add
in contour
so this is going to be our react this is
going to be our redux store so we're
going to create a new store
and it's going to be a reducer
and
we're going to
pull in
strict mode
okay juicer's not too fine let's go
ahead and define that
so
we're going to come over
to our new comp
js file
and what we want to do here is we're
going
to
take out the one class file that we just
created
and
just kind of stripping it down here
now let's go in
and
let's map our state
to
props
equals state
and we're going to do return
message
is state dot message
and then
[Music]
construct map dispatcher props
and this is going to be our dispatch
and we're going to pin
return
and we have our button
change
and for dispatch
we'll type in what the message is
we can have message change
let's turn from the button okay
so we'll pass the value over
all right
and now we actually
connect
as part of our export and in our
connection
i'm going to do map state props
and map dispatch props
all right now we're going to go in and
it's going to be for our new comp
now we want to switch over
and we're going to just change some of
our linking variables here
so serve to button change we're going to
do props dot button change
otherwise we won't be able to find in
our code
this is some pathing
and
you go ahead and create a new folder and
this one is going to be our store
and again this is going to be our redux
store
i'm going to call the store
reducer.js
and
const
initial state equals
this is what the default state will be
for when the page loads which will be
subscribed to simply that
and then
the reducer
we're going to place to where the
reducer is
and con's new state
and it's going to be
an if action
dot type
i'm going to change the message
it's unused comp
so that's the
action there we
pull that
so it's identical
and then new stage dot message
equals
thank you for subscribing so
we have the default and now we have the
new message
again this might seem like extra work
but actually makes your
whole application much more efficient
and export default
reducer
all right so make sure we saved all our
files which we have
and
now let's go ahead
so we have let's just inspect everything
it's all looking good
all right
now terminal window we're going to do
npm start let's see what happens
and our web browser should load up
oh we have an error
that's good so now we're learning stuff
this is again this is all part of your
standard coding is just hunting down
errors in your code so let's go to
index.js
and
let's say
we're going to pull in here
so we have reduce and this should
actually be
spelled correctly there we go
okay all right everything is now
as it should be
let's go back
recompile
let's
rerun a
file
and do we want to move our file let's
just go ahead and move the store
i'm going to update all the links to the
store
and we're going to be providing making
sure our provider store
[Music]
is referenced correctly
okay let's re-run our application
and
there we are
so let's go back through
our application is running much faster
now
we're able to manage our changes and our
elements for our applications different
objects
we're able to change the messages after
you click
and it's able to then create the new
message again this is a very simple
application but you can see how for more
complex solutions how this become useful
and you can start using the different
components you create
for your whole solution
and that's our demo
hi guys welcome to this video on react
native
if you wish to build mobile applications
and are confused as to which tool to use
then you're in the right place
this video on react native will explain
what react native is and guide you
through it
but wait before beginning if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already then
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
so here's what you'll be learning in
this session
first we'll understand what exactly
react native is
then we look at why react native is
being so widely used off lately
moving ahead we look at the differences
between react native applications and
platform specific applications
after understanding why react native is
used we'll understand some of the
prerequisites for building applications
using react native
then we'll understand react native
fundamentals like view state props and
style
and lastly we'll end the session by
looking at some of the industry trends
of react native
so let's begin
what exactly is react native
now react native is a framework that
combines the best parts of native
development with react to build user
interfaces
these applications that are developed
using react native are downloadable on
google play store and apple store plus
because most of the code you write can
be shared between platforms react native
offers a wide collection of ui kits and
makes it easy to simultaneously develop
for both android and ios devices
but you must be wondering why is react
native used
so let's look at some of the reasons why
react native is used
first up is cross platform
cross platform means that the
applications can easily be run on
microsoft windows linux and mac os
so you can build your code base once and
then run it on any platform as opposed
to software built natively for a
specific platform next up is performance
now the react native apps are compiled
into natively written code which enables
it to not only work on both the
operating systems but also functions the
same way on both the platforms with no
lags at all
moving ahead there's quicker development
now react native offers excellent
developer experience
it provides strong developer and
debugging tools with meaningful error
messages so working with this tool
becomes very easy
a large developer community now there
are several github repositories on react
native and groups on facebook
stack overflow is an excellent website
with several developers interacting
about issues on a regular basis
next up is wider audience
now since react native applications run
on both ios and android devices there's
a huge user base
and lastly react native has a great
career scope
considering the pace at which the
framework took over the market and its
simple approach to resolving development
problems the future of react native
looks more promising than ever
so these were some of the reasons why
react native is being widely adopted
so now let's go ahead and look at some
of the differences between react native
applications and platform-specific
applications
as discussed earlier react applications
work on multiple platforms while in the
case of platform-specific applications
as the name suggests these applications
are built for the specific platform only
developers have a stronger web
development background while in the case
of platform-specific apps they have a
very strong platform's language
background
in this case when you consider ios
developers have a very strong hold of
swift which is a programming language
used to develop ios applications and
talking about android developers have a
very strong hold on java
when it comes to react native it has a
faster build time and is less suitable
for complex applications
comparatively platform specific
applications have a slower build time
and are suitable for complex
applications
react native is best for small
development teams with limited resources
while in the case of platform-specific
applications it is best used by
experienced developers who have adequate
experience in building mobile apps
so now that you know what exactly is the
difference between react native and
platform specific applications
let's look at some of the prerequisites
for building apps using react native
first up you should have a strong
holding programming concepts like
functions objects arrays and to lesser
extent classes
now understanding javascript and all the
javascript libraries and frameworks is
crucial
and lastly you need to be familiar with
html and css concepts so as long as you
have a strong hold of these then react
native development becomes very easy
so now that you know what react native
is you've understood why it's being used
some of the prerequisites for react
native let's look at the basic concepts
like view state props and styling in
react native
let's begin with view
now view is the most fundamental
component of building a ui
it is a container that supports layout
with flexbox style some touch handling
and accessibility controls
now view maps directly to the native
view
equivalent on whatever platform react
native is running on so here you can see
there's a simple code snippet and the
output for it so as you can see there's
a hello world message in a render method
and the same is being rendered and the
view component here is being imported
from react native
now view as mentioned earlier acts as a
container with support for flexbox
layout and other styles
so flexbox is designed to provide a
consistent layout on different screen
sizes
moving on to state now there are two
types of data that control a component
one is props and the other one is state
now props are generally set by the
parent and are fixed throughout the
lifetime of a component
but for data that is going to change we
make use of state
so here you can see you have made use of
the this dot stay dot my state in my
render method you can also use the set
state method when you want to change it
moving on let's look at props
most components can be customized when
they are created with different
parameters these created parameters are
called props short for properties now
props are passed from one container to
another as a way of passing data between
them
so here using the name as a prop
lets us customize the message in the
component so we can reuse our component
for each of our tv shows here
so this is how you can use props in our
component
lastly talking about style react native
uses the conventional javascript
styling for components so the style
names and values are similar to how css
works
now to style we either use inline style
or style sheet
so you can see here we've provided
inline styling with a background color
a color and a font size and accordingly
the output is displayed
moving ahead to our last and final
section
let's look at the industry trends today
talking about salaries the average
salary of a react native developer in
india is around 6 lakh indian rupees per
annum
and the salary of a react native
developer in the us is around 96 000 us
dollars per annum now as you can see
react native has a higher growth
trajectory compared to other frameworks
as a result is being readily deployed by
many companies
applications like facebook instagram
netflix
pinterest uber uber eats among others
are developed using react native welcome
to this session on react native versus
flutter in this session we would look at
identifying some of the differences
between the react native and flutter
frameworks let's start with
understanding the core areas of
comparison as part of this session we
will be looking at key aspects to
identify differences between both the
frameworks predominantly on the language
front the ui aspect the performance the
documentation the popularity the
community support that is available for
both these frameworks along with the
industry trends
in terms of the industry adoption for
both these platforms the core objective
of the session would be that at the end
you should be able to decide and make an
informed decision as to which framework
is the best among those available let's
start from a language perspective now if
you look at react react is basically
completely written and built in
javascript using the react.js api on the
other hand if you look at flutter it is
basically written in a very new language
called as start and we do not have uh
too many developers that are skilled on
dart however uh every browser and every
platform being shipped with uh an
in-built javascript execution
environment that makes javascript
platform the language of choice
for developers so every browser today or
every browser manufacturer would have
inbuilt support for executing javascript
programs similarly most popular
platforms mobility platforms like
android and ios have default support for
executing javascript programs and that's
the reason when you compare this with
flutter flutter uses start which is
predominantly a newer language and we
really do not have too many developers
who are skilled on this so that really
is the selling point
and the usp of react native because when
you work with react native uh you really
do not have to relearn a lot you don't
have a sharp learning curve most of the
javascript developers who are working
with means tag already working with html
css and dhtml can easily align to this
that as we have discussed
is pretty new in the industry and would
not have that much of penetration in the
developer community from a ui
perspective
when you talk about react native it's
based pretty much on native components
for the android and the ios platform and
flutter on the other hand uses a very
proprietary
set of widgets
and it has its own page structure that
needs to be set up so
it's a closed ecosystem as compared to
an open ecosystem in react native which
allows you to go and implement third
party widgets and ui frameworks as well
now this is really what uh allows you to
pick and choose with react native
because uh you can go and decide whether
you want to use kendo ui or a set of
delivery controls or any other
third-party ui framework can be
implemented but for flutter you have a
pretty closed ecosystem and that's the
reason the ui components that are
available out of the box and built into
the platform are all that you can use
from a performance perspective when you
talk about react native it basically
is built and uses javascript out of the
box and that's the reason when you want
to write any code in javascript that
connects and tries to access
native services on that specific
platform it uses a bridge to do that but
when you're using flutter on the other
hand flutter does not need any kind of
bridge so there's no concept of you
write flutter code and then it uses a
bridge to go and connect to the native
set of components to interact with and
this is what really impacts the speed
and the performance aspect of developing
and executing applications between both
these frameworks because if you look at
react the speed of development is a
little bit slower when you compare that
with flutter and that's because it has
an intermediate bridge that it has to
communicate with and every layer of
additional communication and computation
that you put in between two tiers in a
application that you built obviously
would have a performance impact from a
documentation perspective if we were to
compare flutter typically has a very
well defined documentation repository
and it allows developers to go through
it in a very simple manner so it's all
structured it's all organized unlike
what you see on react native because in
react native it actually since react
native is an open ecosystem and allows
you to implement third-party widgets and
you can do a lot of configuration and
plug and play and that's the reason uh
the documentation also is not very
strong well organized and impactful and
that's the reason uh most developers
would find it a little challenging to go
through the react native documentation
when you compare that to the
documentation available in terms of
flutter popularity is always a key when
working with platforms and that should
be a crucial decision maker because when
it comes to open source technologies and
you're stuck somewhere you obviously go
to the commit to the community to go and
find out how best you can solution the
problem now flutter being relatively a
new entrant into the market it does not
have a lot of developer penetration and
that's the reason the popularity in the
community is not very strong react
natively there for a while now it's been
around for some time and that's the
reason uh it's pretty popular among
developers also since uh it uses
javascript it's a natural transition and
a progression path for those who are
working with html5 css and building web
applications or have been building
hybrid mobile apps find it very easy to
migrate to this because flutter requires
you to learn a new programming language
which is start and that is one more
reason why the popularity of this is
much much better on the react native
front as compared to flutter again if
you look at google trends
you could actually look at both of the
lines here the red line indicating
flutter it started on a very positive
note and then there was a plateau and
then suddenly a spike react native has
been much more steady in terms of its
growth and ultimately if you look at it
now both of them seem to be trending at
par with each other so the community
support as we were speaking about if you
look at stack overflow which is one of
the most popular websites to go for any
kind of
developer
trends and movements and for a q a that
most developers would have you can
actually look at the number of questions
here and uh also uh react native is part
of uh github as it's open source it was
released in 2015 and it's because of the
huge community support that it becomes
easier to implement this you have a lot
of confidence as a developer when you
start building on this stack because if
you're stuck somewhere you will have a
lot of help available on the way on the
other hand if you compare that with
flutter you can look at the question
count here on stack overflow and this
being a new entrant in the market
it has a smaller footprint on the
community aspect but of course that
keeps increasing every day again from a
react native perspective and you talk
about stability in terms of stable
releases
there again you would see that react
native does a much better job as
compared to flutter so the industry
tents are something which all of us have
to be aware of specifically if
we would need to make a decision in
terms of our careers the technology that
we are learning what is the growth
aspect what is the industry adoption and
how we could really move ahead on our
career graphs in terms of the
opportunities market the job market etc
so again getting back to stack overflow
which is the benchmark for understanding
technology trends in ide sphere and
software development if you look at a
recent survey conducted in 2019 uh 62.5
percent of developers uh seem to have
shown interest in react native as
compared to a marginal rise of 65.4
percent where flutter seems to be doing
much better and of course that could be
due to the uh time frames that uh both
these technologies
have been around react has been around
for quite a while and hence the job
prospects are much better a lot of
organizations implementing this clutter
has been a new entrant and hence uh
slightly fewer opportunities as the
penetration still needs to happen in the
opportunities job market and
from a developer skills perspective so
these are some of the big names that are
using react native in their
implementations right from facebook to
pinterest to wix skype tesla insta
bloomberg
you can actually look at
the implementation across industry which
is absolutely crucial when you're
learning something new because when you
want to join a large logo obviously if
there are a lot of logos using this that
enhances the credibility of your
learning puts a justification to why you
would want to learn this technology
flutter on the other hand associated
with big names like google sonos alibaba
the largest retailer out there from a
conclusion perspective if we were to
conclude on what we've discussed from a
language perspective uh obviously we
said react is much more popular since it
is a natural progression for developers
to work on javascript and move to this
as compared to dart which is relatively
a new language from a ui perspective the
open source plug-and-play capability of
configuring and adopting seamlessly to
newer platforms of widgets and
third-party ui platforms are much better
as compared to flutter which is a closed
ecosystem and depends on inbuilt widgets
to implement the performance aspect we
discussed because of the bridge from the
code that you write to the native
component access exists in react and is
isolated and not any longer required in
flutter and hence the performance is
impacted because of the additional layer
in between the documentation much much
better in flutter because it's a closed
ecosystem and they can control what you
can use react native being open-ended it
really has a lot of third-party
integration you can do and hence the
documentation is not really well
organized the popularity perspective
react native much more popular among
html5 css three mer mean stack
developers since it's all javascript
flutter needs you to learn new skills
and you need to spend additional time
for that from a community support react
native has been there for a longer time
as compared to flutter and hence has a
stronger community support as compared
to flutter and that translates into
better job prospects in the industry for
react native as compared to flutter so
if you were to give it a score react
scores much better with a total score of
5 leaving flatter with the total score
of two so i hope we were able to
understand the differences between the
react native and flutter and this will
help you make better decisions with
planning your career and deciding which
technology you should latch on to
so our demo is going to be about
creating a calculator using react and
node.js and so we have here just a basic
calculator nothing crazy um but the
whole thing is going to be created with
react and so we'll be using javascript
to be installing react and installing
the various components such as node.js
and the different npm solutions that we
need so as you can see when the
calculator works just fine and now let's
go ahead and
let's go and install the different tools
that we need so the first one is going
to be node.js
and we do google search on node.js we
always start with google searches
because it's the easiest way to find
things and so we go to the default
node.js site and you can go to downloads
and there are windows mac os and also
linux installers you can also download
the original source code and compile it
yourself if you want and you'll also
need a text editor i'm going to be using
visual studio code it's just my favorite
text editor it's free works across all
platforms
uh it comes with a ton of extensions so
you can get up and running really
quickly with it
so we're just going to go ahead and
install the windows version i already
have installed so you have to download
it again you also want to make sure that
you have the latest version of node.js
installed now with that node package
manager so we're just going to open up
our terminal window and validate which
version that we have running
and we can do that fairly easily we can
just put in node
version and it'll tell us which version
and which means that's installed and
same thing with npm
node package manager we'll do npm
version and that will give us back the
version number again you have to have
them installed for them to be able to
do that and we're going to also now
create a react app so we're gonna do
install and then it's gonna be create
dash react dash app that's the command
to create a new react app
and we're gonna install it right off our
desktop
so let's go in and we'll put
mpx
create dash react dash app
and then the app is going to be called
calculator which will install a folder
on our desktop with all the appropriate
react code
and this will be just a template
application but it'll have everything
there that we need to get started with
hit return and that will take a few
minutes just to install everything
and here we go
and so as we go through some of the
components that we're going to be
creating today we're going to be
creating an app component and they'll be
the main component that has all the
information that will then be disabled
on the screen then we have a layout
component and that will be the actual
look and feel of the calculator and the
output component which will be the
results from the calculator and then the
output row and this will be all the
different tools that we will need and
here we have
our new folder right there
on our desktop but we're actually going
now into visual studio and if you've
seen any of the other
node.js videos that we've created you
know that i like to work with the
node.js in visual studio code
because i can run terminal window right
there so i'm going to open up the folder
that we just created that's called
calculator and we open up the whole
folder
not a file but the whole folder and
here's our folder on the left hand side
we have all the different files there's
our json package that has the
instructions for what the calculator
looks like
including which version of react and the
dom
and here's our default
element
as you can see because we're using react
it's going to
embed the code into a html page and so
we have a div with the id of root that's
going to reference um some
class files that we create and so the
app.js file
has the application code that we're
going to be modifying in a little bit
and you'll see that it actually then
references up to our
index.js file
and if in index.js file it has the id
element root which ties back to
the id element of root in our html file
so we're constantly referencing and
cross-referencing our application
and this is where we're gonna be doing
most of our work
right so we're gonna go ahead and open
up the terminal window
and the first thing we want to do is
start
npm
and
it's now going to have everything
running on let's have localhost and
everything running on port 3001
we'll give that a moment and this will
actually then bring up just the standard
default react boilerplate app
it's just taking a moment to load
i should probably get a faster computer
okay there we are
just not patient so here we have our
basic boilerplate react js application
nothing to create crazy here
so let's actually go in and start
working in some of our code so uh
see now yep everything's running where
we expect it to run
all right so let's go into fjs
and
we can actually go ahead and if you want
to type control plus c and actually stop
the app or you can
in the terminal window you can actually
stop it
now you can also go up into the terminal
command to stop it as well
and if we do stop the app then we'll get
an error message there we go the site
can't be reached
and you'd expect this
we go back in and
we're going to just restart
our application
everything should now be working just
fine
we're going to refresh the page
and we'll see
our default react app
coming up on port
3001 there we are
looking good looking good
okay
so we're going to delete out what we
have there because we want to put in our
own content
and we're going to call this one class
app and we're going to go in and we're
going to be modifying that class here in
just a moment
we'll put in default layout
i'm going to create a new folder
this folder is going to be called
components this is going to be for our
calculator
and put a new file in there
i'm going to call this one layout.js
and this is where we're going to start
breaking down the structure of our
layout
and we're going to
say import
layout
and then we want to do the path to our
layout
components
layout you know so we have the dot
because we have to go up one folder
that's the command for that so dot op1
folder components folder layout
notice we don't have to type layout.js
it automatically knows to add the js
extension
constantly making sure that we're saving
let's go over to layout.js
and this is our layout
and we do this using css
then we're going to import
react
from
react
and then select import
and then we're going to link to layout
css it's going to be a css file that
we're going to create
so we're going to have to type that into
layout.css
and notice we had to write out
explicitly that it's a css file
and so
here we have
and then we're going to put in
[Music]
the constructions for the layout
what our props look like
and then we'll export default layout so
it can
show up correctly
okay so we'll go to our web page now
yep that's good we're expecting to see
that so we need to
change some of our path in here just
quite quickly
so
let's see now
[Music]
we're going to move a file so it can be
accessed appropriately
we run this
you know what i think we didn't we have
to update
uh yep i know we have to go back to
layout and
we have to start adding in
some values here
so that
the application knows to lay content out
so we just put in
a
hello world
there we are okay so that shows us
everything is pulling through correctly
so we want to get rid of hello because
we're going to replace that with our own
application
i'm going to change this
div so that actually starts
pulling in the application
and
put in the class name for calculator
and this will be a css reference
okay
so you
need to have some image files
and what we're doing here is we're
essentially building up the
different elements that will need to be
presented on the screen
and then we'll have a css file that
we'll use to create these elements
and as you can imagine i've i've already
got this written so i'm cheating a
little bit because i know what i'm
putting here
but
as bottom line is that
the calculator really is
a bunch of form elements
um such as buttons
on the screen but we use css to reformat
them so it looks more like a traditional
calculator
that's one of the the things that you
get comfortable working with when you're
doing web applications is how to take
technologies that you're used to using
and then modifying them so that they
look different and so in this instance
we're used to using button elements
within an application so
why not use the the same button elements
which consistently work from browser to
browser
and then just simply
update the look and feel of them with
some css so that
they they look good
and here we are just doing a very simple
on click command this is some basic
javascript
that will render inside of the browser
itself
okay so now we see boom there's a button
all right so and again you want to be
constantly testing and verifying that
the code you're writing is working
correctly
and we're going to do
another button
and this is going to be the delete
button
so we've got we're going to start
building out our different buttons here
mm-hmm
so let's delete
now we have an unclick event for that
okay we're just doing some formatting
here
okay so we just used
going through our code here
make sure everything looks good
and one of the things we can now do
because we've got a base line
that looks correct we can just copy that
and then we want the percentage sign and
then the forward bracket so this
so it gives us our two buttons so we
have a
it's got a new row here
i'm just gonna copy everything over just
make it a little bit easier ourselves
and then we're just gonna pin the
numbers
seven eight
nine
and then
plus symbol
sorry the multiply symbol
and we'll be able to move these into
multiple rows here in just a moment
and we just want to keep
going through making all the changes
here so we actually fill out all the
different elements
so as you can see most of this
isn't really complex it's
just the
uh you use the word fiddly yeah i guess
again the the fiddly parts of
putting this content together
so we refresh our screen start seeing
all the different elements
okay let me get it
we have to come back and make some
updates
to
our css class names
and then we do our final three buttons
across the bottom
so now
[Music]
okay so let's now add some styles to the
content that we've created
we do then our layout.css file
and so we already have some styles that
we created so we're just going to go
ahead
and for the for the sake of brevity
we're just gonna pull those over
um
we can
if you want to um and have us do a more
detailed video on how to
create the csc css files and
um you know we'll certainly do that but
i think most you probably know how to do
this already
all right so here's our css file and so
we have our calculator keys our buttons
and the different types of button here
so we can just copy these all over and
so these these will have the background
color the watercolor et cetera et cetera
and so we're going to do that
here we have our
buttons
for our app
easy way you know how
okay so we take out the css then we just
have basic buttons
we have the css link back in
we have
nice laid out application
so we've got a couple of areas that are
still missing we've got the results
screen and the
default logo
so
let's go ahead and add that information
in
and we'll create a new folder called
assets from the assets we'll put
another folder called font
and that'll be where our fonts will be
then we'll create another folder we'll
call this one images
and we'll put our images in there
so we have our logo image just simply
learn logo
and then for layout we can then
just reference that in our image
reference
so i'm going to import the logo
i'm going to import that from
our assets folder
and under assets we go to amg which we
have our image
and then we'll do the path for the
logo.png
so remove this
and then we'll do source
and we'll do the source is
from
our logo variable which is the has the
import of the image
i'll put the width
and we have to know it's 150 pixels and
the
there we go 750 pixels wide
and the style that we'll reference from
css
will be
block
so just some inline styling here
generally normally do this i normally
have all my styling in my css
folder
but uh in this instance because we're
just putting up a solution i want you to
be able to see that you can actually do
this in line so there we are however
that logo
okay so now we need to have the
results screen make sure that looks
correct
okay
and so we're going to create a new
folder and this is going to be got our
output
js file and this is going to control the
output of that blue screen
and put our react objects
and we'll export that
and we'll put a new file called
outputrow.js
so we'll put our instructions
this is going to be our component the
users will put their
results into
and
now put row
put yeah instructions here so we're
going to like export
default
output row
all right so we're going to start
putting together the code that allows us
to construct our solution
i'm going to update the output row.js
file
and
we're going to
add in our return value
so i'll put a div
and this will be
input type
so essentially we have a text field um
that will be read only at the top of our
calculator and here we see our text
field here
and
that will allow us to be able to
put in our values
and we use the class screen that allows
us to give our formatting
and we're going to put
a file it's going to be output row.css
we're going to add in our specific css
for
this output row
[Music]
and as you can see we're just using
all of our standard html5
skill sets here
and
let's go over to our
style it
will pull in our
props dot text size
and then the default
value
and so this is going to align with uh
go over to our css file and we'll update
that
output.js
make sure the results get returned
correctly
as we're tapping on the buttons
and so this will
pull in our output row
and the value will be
[Music]
we bring out text size for output flow
here
and we're just going to put some
sample css styling here
nothing too crazy
now we have two
rows
save that
our two rows will appear in a moment
let's go into our layout
let's add in our rows
so this is our output i'm going to
pull in those values
and there we have our two values
and so we can apply some css styling to
this
so the top row will be
the calculation broken out as we've
written it and the bottom row will be
the results
and it's going to our css file here
we're going to copy over some css
and you have
some
font styling
we have our screen class name
there's our screen here
again this is
nothing no rocket science here and we've
done any css
um editing you'll be familiar with what
we've done here
and you see they're referring to a font
asset we actually have the font in there
to
pull that font over and
it's just a ttf font true type font
now you can use and any of the
internet fonts as well google has a
massive library
of fonts
and there we are
i'm going to change the size of our
font so that the second row the text is
a little bit bigger
a little bit smaller and we don't have
anything wired up yet we'll do that in a
moment i'll be easy part of this
assignment
all right so let's go over and
now layout
okay so net
input
set input
and use state
that way we can default the initial
state
and for the results
the you state
the initially state will be just blank
there we are
this is what you'd expect to see
so the results
um
are blank and this is just when you run
the app for the very first time
okay so going through
and now we want to put in our actions so
we can have an event
when we click on any of the buttons
we want to take the value of the button
and
so this
you're going to be
any of these actions here
and
we're just going to put together a
script to do the calculations
so as you can see so far
we've put most of this application
most of the hard work has been setting
up the base react application putting
together the
different files and folder structure
making sure we have the correct assets
such as
images
fonts
css files
laying out our core structure in html
form elements
and now um the part that we're doing at
the end here
is putting together the script
that will actually
write they'll actually do our calculator
uh events and and honestly and this is
going to be um
i've got this running here it's just
javascript so there are lots of
javascript calculators on the internet
so you can actually take any of those
and use those as a base
for what we're doing here
and there we have it if there's an error
we'll do math error a result
we don't expect to see that
and we'll just keep putting together our
code here
[Music]
so our different results
so depending on
which commands you use so for instance
it's the equal sign
and
you have the results
so we're using the value to actually
then trigger
what we would actually be
seeing in which screen
okay it's looking good
so we'll capture our value and this is
all concatenate together
and
[Music]
if there are any error messages
so if the value is
c from the button so if you set c
so we want to set the input to zero
which is to reset
the screen
and
if the value
equals and this will be delete
what we want to do is we want to
manipulate the string on the screen
which means we're going to
[Music]
eliminate
the last character entered
and this is
manipulation here
and this is all reducing the length of
the string
by one character at a time
again this is your standard
javascript control
so hit delete
and that gets rid of a character another
character
hit it again i'll get rid of the third
character
and
put if the string is
zero let me put
that as the value
all right
this allows us to test out our
application
all looking good so far
okay
i want to make sure that we're then
calculating our values correctly
and here we have
the
display and the input
it's all coming from here our output
class
and then we'll put in our results
okay it looks like we're letting lining
everything up just always want to go
back and double check that you have all
your commands all your variables lining
up correctly
eliminate those
now we'll make sure we have the answer
and the user
entered there
and we have the answer in the user and
we'll change the font size
you say that
we'll go over and this is now this is
our local application
and we test it we can start putting
together our construct
and we'll see that our calculator is
working so clear gets rid of both values
everything's looking pretty good
and here we have our first application
and this is the sample application
this is the application we just wrote
here is the original application that we
were testing against
and as you can see
everything lined up correctly
and so you've seen how in just 45
minutes you can actually
write out your own
react js application with node.js
and so we terminate the application
so this is the one we just built
it's going to fail so that
allows us to validate that we actually
created we will restart the services
say yes
i'm running on another port because we
already have an app running on
another port says to run on 3001
refreshing the web page
and voila there we are there's our
application up and running
everything looks really good
working fine
it works absolutely identically
now if you want to you could actually
then take this application and
um make it a native application as well
right now we're just using it as a web
application
we're just updating some of the css
making it a little bit tighter
everything's looking exactly the same
there we go that's your app
all up and running hello everybody and
welcome you all
so
we're gonna talk about something very
interesting topic of the day
and that is called hooks in react
see friends actually what happens when
we work on react-based development
so in react 16.8
we have introduced a new feature called
react hooks
these hooks have
really changed the way how the react
development really happens
because prior to these react hooks
we were writing so much of code because
of that it actually increased the
complexity to our program
but ever since the react hooks came into
this picture the development time has
slows down
okay and we have actually increased the
productivity of our development
now how the react hook really changes
the way this we're gonna see it now in
those slides
now what are the react hooks see the
react hook is a special feature that
lets you
hook intro
now what is this
see they say fuse important thing they
say normally hook allows you to reuse a
stateful logic without changing your
component hierarchy
your application can actually divide it
into the smaller pieces which later on
can be used together
okay
so hooks let you use most of the react
features without using classes see
actually what happens
in react we have a two type of ways how
you write your components number one is
called class based component and second
which is called functional component
now
class based components are little more
heavy lifting because it comes
pre-loaded with state management as well
as the life cycle
[Music]
but not always you need these two
so you need to keep your components
light weighted so if you want to keep
your components light weighted so you
need to basically approach towards the
state
less or functional components so by
adding those hooks features so you can
have this normal functional components
on the top of that you will be having
some add-on feature that's the beauty of
react hooks
now the rules of react hooks
so there are few rules of the react
hooks which you need to understand
and what those are
number one they say
only call hooks
at the top level
don't look hooks inside loops conditions
or nested function so there are certain
conditions
they say
only hooks only call hooks from the
react function component don't call
hooks from the regular javascript
function instead
you can call hook from the react
function component or call hooks from
the custom box so there are multiple
options are available which you can
expose or use in your regular
react based applications okay
so after that we will see the demo how
the three different type of hooks are
used straight hooks eventbooks and
create customized hook and we will see
some demo on the top of that
hello everybody so once again we are
going to start working with another type
of foxy
in our previous examples we have seen
how you can have the state related hook
now my next event will be all about how
you can have
the
even based hooks we're talking about
something called use effects so how the
use effects really works let's take a
look now so here
in a similar example if i just give the
name call uh
[Music]
okay let's try to make it here only so
what i'm trying to do now is in my
current application
i'm already having this count and set
count to me but
i can also provide some default values
that anyways has been provided so rather
than hard coding it i can provide it
from somewhere else so how we can so
let's use one property called props here
and here rather than providing this i'm
saying
props dot
count so my question is like what do you
mean by count here
see count is nothing but a property
which initial value i don't know so
which you can set it from outside
so what you can do is here
before you export it you can say give
the name call
hook stand dot
default props
default
props
okay equal to i'm starting with the
curly braces and after this curly braces
here saying
count
okay that value is what
zero
what initial value we're giving count
initial value equal to what a zero now
and uh post this
this value whichever we are giving it so
what we also do in the same line is uh
here we would like to also perform the
another actions for setting the state
initial value is called count
and
this way i can say set count count plus
one okay that is anyways fine
so increment let me copy this
so here let me say npms please start
so i must see some values have been
presented okay you can see still
initial value was 0
that's why if you see initial value was
zero so now because of getting the
initial value called props dot count and
now i can say increment
and i want to talk about decrement so
decrement and here we say reset
so
here
we can say minus one and this value
rather than say count plus one
okay
you can say
props dot count means whatever the
initial value would be that value will
be initialized here
so now the code will work just the way
it is now you can say increment
decrement reset
so it's working fine
so in our react hope of an option which
is available called
life cycle hooks
life cycle books are very very important
that means you're trying to say
whenever you would like to call anything
related to your life cycle like when
your component starts you would like to
learn something when the component
you know update you want to launch
something so these kind of activities
you can certainly make it
so are you going to be making it now
let's take a look now so initially what
i'm doing is
i'm just
creating a new function called
use
because it is a predefined
okay available from
okay react 16.
so here onwards you can see it is coming
from the same property
from react and under this use effect
what i will do is i will just say
log and i'm saying
called
every time
now if i just launch my application and
see the inspect
you can see it is saying called every
time even if i say increment it is
getting called even decremented is
getting called and reset it will get
called
because this is a life cycle method
and the life cycle method means it will
get called
normally in a react we have a call
component did mount and component did
update so it is a copy of both
okay
however you can
stick this particular use effect to the
specific need only like if you do not
want this to be get called
on updates only when the component
launches so what you can do here in its
comma parameter you can make it as a
square bracket
this square bracket will contain those
values which you would like to watch for
those changes
so if you do not keep it anything by
default it will be what blank so now if
i just go ahead and start it is saying
called every time and now you can say
it is not getting called at all because
now it is knowing that hey it is a blank
value so i'm not seeing any value so it
needs to be get called only when it is
launching not every time
however you also can offer the condition
where you want to call this use effect
only when the changes happens not
every time when it is loading
so what you can do you can just call
this
again
and paste it again this use effect and
say called
on
update and here you can provide the
value which you would like to listen so
actually if i see
the state is getting changed for this
count so i can say
count and now once it is ready
i can start my application
and you can say here
increment now you can see it is getting
called
okay but it is not getting called on
loading every time
so you are specifically telling like
this use effect should get called only
when
state changes to the count and this you
are not listening to anything so you are
making it as apply
i hope you clear about what use effect
is all about
okay everyone so the previous example we
have seen like how
this books with regards to your
current application works like as i'm
saying we're talking about like in
this
state hook where we have seen use effect
we have also seen another feature that
is called use state and now we're going
to be talking about our next okay
everyone so now
we're continuing to our next feature
here and that is known as caller use
context
see when we talk about react use context
we always have a very special feature
coming up with us where the reusability
comes as a priority
okay so if you really want to use a
reusability
okay you always think about the option
called use context now first of all i
would like to show you the problem and
then we discuss about the solution so
now here
i'm gonna say
use
context.js and in this use context.js
what i've been doing i'll be creating
some few functions here i'm saying
function
okay
so in this main app i can create
const
i can say
user
set user equal to
use
state and initialize the value which
call what
admin that is the initial value we are
saying like in main app uses that user
uses state admin
and now after this
i am using return
and in this return
with my dev tag i would like to offer
the message
okay so we are giving the name called
h2 and within this h2 we are
using this a value called
welcome and with this dollar sign
we can give the value like a user
whichever the initial value will be that
will be represented here
so that's what my first component
likewise if i want to share the data
to the other components
how i basically try to use that's an
important thing i would like to consider
right now
so this is my first component
like i also want to create another
component which is accepting the data
and utilizing its own way
okay so like this
i can copy
and say
user 2
for this function i'm creating this user
tool
in this user tool
i will not be defining any state as of
now because it is there already defined
okay so in this it will be expecting
here it will be expecting
user is in parameter
okay so return
you can defined it anything i can say
paragraph
and this i can say
[Music]
user to
component
okay and i'm saying
component 2 and now i would like to pass
this value further to the another
component now
so what i'm trying to say now here
if i say user 2
let me copy this the whole bunch
and paste it below here and i'm saying
user3
which is also taking this data
and here i'm defining this value called
user3
okay space user
equal to
user
like this
we are providing it
okay
so that's where
i'm trying to use this
functionality
so we are having this function user 2
okay so after this
we are taking function three and adding
the data right over there
okay so this dev tag
whichever you're taking it
so we have a called main app we can say
user2 and followed by user 3 so the data
we can keep on passing from one
component to another component
so we have got this component with me
user 2 and same time we have called user
3 now
ok and this user 2 whichever is
available to me okay when you're saying
hello user
this user too i can provide this data
right over here
okay so in my main application i can say
uh
user
two
okay
and with this we can provide the value
called
user equal to
once again user
like this so you can see here
we are passing the data
down the line to all my components
whichever we are utilizing it
okay
so that's fine
so
after this what will be doing because we
are passing the data just like that but
the only thing is what if this main app
wants to pass the data directly to the
user 3 it cannot pass
okay it can pass the data to the user 3
only from its immediate child which is
the user tool
and that's what the problem i would like
to sort it out but here
let me say
export
default
the name is called main app
okay let's make initial capital that is
always good
okay export default main app
and let's add this main app right inside
your
app.js
okay now let's see
see the value is coming up welcome admin
welcome admin will remind me
so that's pretty fine
components are basically rendered but
there is no reusability if you see like
it is a plain old technique
you pass the data to the child and you
cannot pass the chat to the grandchild
these are the certain challenges
okay so let's try to sort it out this
issue
okay everybody so it's time to basically
talk about the solution we have already
seen our problem
there's no reusability there's no
sharing of the data
and the sharing of the data is happening
from parent to child
only when you are a direct parent
otherwise not
so how are you going to be fixing this
issue
so fix this what i'll be doing is we
just want to say
const
wrap context equal to
create
context
okay so we're going to say equal to what
a create context
so as usual the states are there
return
now in this return what i will be doing
it i will be using this
context so anyways i'm having this dev
tag
so i'll be using this option i can
use a context
or the context which we have created
that is called app content so we are
saying what
app context here okay dot
you see there's an option available
called provider this is the one which
should be helping you to share the data
to the all the components value equal to
user
okay in this app context
i would like to cut it
okay and paste it after here
okay and here
user to equal to whatever it is the
value is there so you are passing it to
user two
okay and later on you can pass to any
components those who want to really use
it
okay so whosoever wants to access your
context it can be easily available
okay so you really don't need to pass
this data again and again so if you are
in second component
okay so your anyways wrap this second
component right over here
so here in your second component
you really don't need this any data like
this
and you really don't need this
like that so you can easily pass this
into the user three also
okay so it's very simple and
straightforward
so
let me try to remove this value from
here also
and you can get the data the way you
always want
okay
so
you're saying value equal to what
user here
so after that you're saying
user equal to what user whichever value
you are basically passing it okay and
say use context.provider
okay and the second component
when you say user2
you just say
you really don't need this in fact i
would say
you can even remove it
okay and the same you can remove it from
here also
okay and when i see my component swag
see
still working like the weight is
expected
okay so that becomes the idea of what
your
use context
okay which is designed for sharing the
data between and among the components
okay everyone so now it's time to
basically discuss about our another very
important topic that is called user f
okay use ref is basically what the use
ref you can say it is the kind of hook
which allows you to persist value
between the renders
again i'm telling you user x allows
actually to process the value between
renders
normally you can store
or you can use to store a mutable values
which are changeable
okay that does not cause
a rerender when updated
okay
that means
you can persist that value in a storage
okay as a mutable value which does not
cause
a re-render when the updates actually
happens so normally it can be used to
access your dom element directly
clear so how it can be let's take a look
with using one simple example
so you all can understand how we can
utilize this
okay so i'm going to create another one
here
name call
use ref.js
inside this user.js so let's get started
with this implementations the one which
we're looking at it now so called userf
so once again i'm creating
a function
app
and inside this i would like to say
const
input
vl comma
set
input val
equal to
user state
okay
we want to use it now we want to use one
more const
pref value
okay equal to now we would like to say
use
ref you can see it is coming once again
from the where from the react here in
this user we can pass initial value
blank we do not have initial value so
that we are sending it as a what is a
blank
now post that
we want to create
first important thing is we would like
to use the use effect first use
effect you have already seen the use
effect earlier because it is holding the
life cycle related
conditions so now here we are saying
prep value
okay dot
current
equal to
input file
okay and after that which value you are
seeing
we get updated so we are passing
input value for sure
okay
post that once it is ready okay i'll be
saying return
okay inside this return
i'm having
dev tag
and here in this dip type we can say
input type
equal to
text
okay value
equal to which value would like to take
it so we are giving
input val
okay and we are also saying on change
equal to
taking this e is an event object here
and
we're calling
set
input val
with
e dot
target dot
value
okay
so we are holding the values
just like this
okay and after this once it is ready i
just want to use the
h3 tag
to show what is the current value so we
can say
updated value
okay here
i'm having this input value with me
and now i'll be using one more
h2 we are saying
last value of
we are saying
priv
value
okay dot
current
so that's where you are basically using
so
this will be offering you what
the kind of value you are actually
expecting into your program
okay so use ref hooks can be used to
keep track of the previous state values
this is what we're doing it now
okay so this is because we are able to
persist use reference value between the
render so now let me try to say
export
default
and
i'm just giving the name
of app and this app i'm using it here in
my app.js
app
let me terminate it and
launch it again
[Music]
let's see
local 3000 again
so it is taking some more time but i'm
sure
we'll be able to see the outcome
soon into our system so now you can see
these values are coming up so now when i
pass the value call
one it is containing the one when i say
two you can see it is holding the
previous value and i said three it
containing the previous value when i say
for it holding the previous value
that's where exactly the beauty of this
user of which you are expecting it from
all of you so everyone we have already
seen like our previous example like how
we can use
the use ref in our previous project now
it's time to talk about
our another interesting feature in hooks
continuation to this and
that we're talking about call working
with a use reducer
so what is the use reducer see use
reducer
is again a hook
which is as state
okay it allows for custom state logic
unlike the normal state how we maintain
using new state allows to also having
some custom logic also see if you are
finding yourself where we have multiple
portions of the state
that actually depends on the complex
logic use reducer would be very very
beneficial for you because it contains a
centralized logic
okay and can help the users to develop
some more fantastic applications so
let's see how we can really do this and
how we can utilize that so in hooks demo
i'm going to create a new file here i'm
going to give the name call
note app.js
and in this node app.js i would like to
have some initialize state i won't like
to make it available to the user
so
let's try to use one
very simple logic call
const
note reducer
not
reduces equal to here
i would like to take the parameter like
in state
and
action it is just like a normal
functionality we are writing it down
and inside this we would like to use a
switch
here we use a switch and we will judge
what type of action client is trying to
invoke action this is what kind of
condition client so client is ready to
invoke i'm using action
dot
type
okay
and here we use the first option like in
case
first
condition i'm taking it is called
populate nodes
okay
populate underscore
which all the existing nodes are
available populated
okay and here
after this
we would like to say return
[Applause]
dot
nodes
okay or else in a default case
or in a default case we are saying
return
the default state whichever is available
to me
so that's how the condition is now
going back
i would like to also check what are the
type of
states are available which i would like
to show it back to the client so we are
using this option like it
cost
let's create a states first we are
saying const
nodes
comma
dispatch
equal to use
reducer and inside this rule is user
first parameter we are passing is called
node reducer whichever we have taken as
an action here and comma the initial
state which i am making it is a blank
i do not have any states of making it as
a blank again i am using this option
again const
title
set title equal to
use
state with initial value blank so that's
how we are passing it now
okay now the next thing is like i would
like to
check
in my code
how to basically display the list of
nodes back to my application
okay that's what the whole logic i want
to write
okay so let's check in case if i want to
return
the bulk of nodes how do i do this
so here
let's try to create the
notes app so
this i would to make it
that was the reducer for us
now here we gonna create cost
and i'm closing it here
okay so we are having these two
properties with me
and
we can have a number of actions also
but let's talk about return
in this return
we want to display the list of nodes
which are available to me
in case if i'm having it i will display
it so
i'm having the div tag
inside this tab tag i can say
h2
notes
after this notes
notes
dot
map in case if i'm having a array of
notes map is a predefined function
for me so here we are using what
note
okay so
so inside this we would like to provide
the
object where the details will be
available to me
okay so
i can use
the div tag
where i can have the property with me so
i can use
the div
okay so i can use
key
equal to
you can just use
the default sheet which is available for
nodes
equal to what notes
and provide
the other details too like if you want
to iterate it so you can just provide
data accordingly
okay so
that's what the whole idea is
and here
under this we would like to provide
note
okay
and
here if in case if i want to have some
data that can be displayed
okay so
now say
export
default
note app
and this note up i'll be making it as a
child of app.js
okay
you can see i have got initial data
displaying here so in case if i have few
more records
suppose if i set data
okay so you can basically make
this data also available here so you can
see our god
list of records are available
okay so
that's make your development even more
easier
and that's the beauty of how the nodes
can be used for the further development
okay so i hope you're clear about
what in case if i want to use
uh you know this reducer so how we can
further utilize it to initialize
the data with this but later on if i
want to add some actions
i can also add it
okay but this is what the initial state
which we are using it
in case if i want to display the data in
my code
hello everyone so in the previous
sections we have seen like
how we will be utilizing
our
you know use reducer applications now
i'm going to tell you about another
react very popular tool that is known as
called use memo which is once again a
very very popular
tool so what is the user memo it is
again another hook
so
use memo hook return some memorized
value what it was the previous value was
so we can
say think of
uh
memorization as a caching value so that
it does not need to be recalculated it
already contain the value within that
so use memo only runs when
of its dependency update
okay so use memo
okay
is one of the very very popular tool but
it can be
you know little expensive resource
insensitive function okay so it is
used memory can be used to keep
expensive and resource oriented function
to avoid needlessly running so we will
see how this
use memo can work
so let's check this out and see
see
what my intention is in my application
is like
use memo is basically perform
some
actually memorized your complex
calculations so that it doesn't need to
run unnecessary every time
okay so it does a kind of caching
behavior for you to make your life even
more simple so let's see how it works so
accordingly you will also get the
implementations
okay so
you need to understand the use memo hook
except the second parameter
okay to declare dependencies so the
expensive function would only run when
this dependency has been changed
otherwise not
okay so let's see how we will be using
those so now here
i'm creating a new file and give the
name call
[Music]
okay so inside your memo app.js what you
do is just take a look let me try to
close rest of those
yeah so here you see
okay so we are saying
set count
equal to
user state initialize value with what
i would say 0
for a time being i'm trying to use now
okay
and
after that if i want to perform some
calculations i can do that but let me
try to perform
this job only okay count and set count
according to my
rule
okay now
what i'm planning to do now is in a
similar line
i want to offer one more feature here
called const
cost to do
equal to use state
i'm making it as a what type area type
okay and i'm saying
const
calculation equal to
expensive calculation
and here we are passing what
counters and parameter here
okay now let's perform some functions
i'm saying const
increment equal to
set count
c
plus one
okay and we are using
we're calling this set to do's here
okay and use
all the previous states whichever are
available and
new data this will get added so three
functions you are basically calling
after that i am saying
return
in this return i am having what
div tag
within this div tag i can use
another tip tag here and here we're
using
my after this h2 we would like to use
todos dot
map
slash what index
and here we saying return
paragraph
sorry key
equal to
add task
okay and
here
sorry
equal to what index here
and
here to rules
[Music]
okay
how do you make it
okay so this is how we have it now
after this we would like to create a one
button
inside this button i can say
add to do
and here
we will say one click and in on click
we'll be calling
at task
so this is what it is happening now
okay everybody
so here after this
div tag is getting closed
hr is getting closed
again we are opening up another tip tag
here
and here we are seeing
count
and here using
in this button we would like to
click on plus
increment what we're calling it here
increment here
[Music]
and call something called
calculation
just like a normal message
and here
put what
calculation
okay so once it is done
so your dip tag is also close
both the tip tag is kind of getting
close
okay and they are also getting close and
now
we would like to perform one function
whichever i would like to use it for my
standard calculation
okay so let's see what we are trying to
do
so here i am saying
power running calculation equal to
okay and we are using this
lock button insert this lock button i'm
saying
calculating here and post this
this thing is called
for let
i equal to zero
i is
less than
[Music]
okay and we're using what
i
plus plus
and say
num
equal to 1
okay
and after this
i can say
return
now
and after that i'll be rendering this
function
by saying
export default memory
that's it
okay
so this would be my application here
okay so now
here in this example
the expensive function which is called
long running function
okay
whatever i'm talking about
the long running function
okay will only run when the count is
changed
and not when the totals are added
that's a whole picture about this code
here
okay so you can just see here
we're using this statement
and
here
we're gonna give the name of this long
running calculations
to here
okay so i'm calling it there
now this memo app i'll be using it in my
app.js
okay so that is what we have it now so
i'm clearly saying like here
so
in this application
hook accept second parameter to declare
dependency the exp so the long running
functions will only run when the
dependency have changed otherwise not
that's a whole picture
so it is adding it saying calculating it
and then it is getting changed
okay
so that's what the whole picture of what
we have done so i'm sure like you all
are clear
about how
this memo is really performing some job
the one which is actually expected
and once again we're going to start with
another feature of books as we have got
many hooks seen in our development
okay and uh
now on this top of this i'll be working
on our new concept that is what's called
use imperative handler it is again a new
concept as we have already seen multiple
different type of
hooks into our development now we'll be
talking about use imperative handler
now what is the use of
this particular hook look when we talk
about use imperative handler if i just
get you this
so if i say
use
now when we talk about use imperative
handler
okay so this use imperative handler and
the user is what we've already done
allows to pass a reference object
but the later which is called
use reference
which you've already seen
this use reference
doesn't allow to customize the instance
that are
also passed with the ref object so use
imperative handler hooks is a different
from user friends
because it allows again
it allows
handling and customizing the return
value
it allows handling
and customizing the return value
and it also allows to replace the native
instance of the ref object
now how it works let's try to understand
in our development
so
here we're going to start working with a
very simple approach
into our code okay
so we're going to create a new one that
is called
[Music]
imperativedemo.js and after this we are
writing
function
converter
okay here we are passing two parameters
here one is called
props and second is called what
two parameters we are passing it
now here we are saying
const
use ref
okay
now
after this we're using use
you can see we have a call use
imperative handler comes from
this one so we are using this use
impellative handler and here we are
passing what refers in parameter
okay and
okay now in this case we are using one
type of functionality called blur
okay and here
with this blur
and we are using
log
and writing
custom blur is called
after this once it is ready i would like
to say return
in this return
we are saying button
okay
and
with this button
i want to use rift
okay equal to
btn and
props we both are passing in here
in this using
click
okay
that's it and
once it is done then
we would like to use this
okay into my application
wherever i can actually access this
in my application to system
so once it is ready i would like to
make it
available so by using i'm saying export
default and i'm using something called
forward reference
you can see it is again a part of what
the react application we are using is
called forward reference
and here we are passing what
button so that is what my code is
now here i will be making it as a child
off but
[Music]
in my app.js so we already have this
earlier
memo app so here in my application
i'm just using const
btn equal to
use reference
i'll be using what use reference
so react
okay so we're using this option called
use reference here and we are passing
null here and after this
this value whichever we are having it we
just said
cut and passing it here
and this under this written keyword i'm
using
button
and pin this button in our
options i can provide the events
so inside this button we would like to
one second
yeah
so inside this button using
on click
equal to
we're saying btn
okay dot
current dot
okay so we haven't imported
anything so let me import a button from
here
okay so we say
import
button
which class you have created here
imperative demo
okay
so
so once it is there so
[Music]
so we're providing what
dot current dot
blur
so closing this here and along with this
we are saying ref
equal to
bda
that's it
so this is where exactly the
options are so you understand in this
button component that has a user defined
instance
attached to the reference object so
button component is the child component
of the app component
are we clear so when we click the button
here the button is clicked
okay it called
user defined blur function which is
attached to the pass reference object
okay so that's the whole idea now
so i haven't written anything another
button
that certainly i can add it
so under here
okay
so now
okay so
here
the things are working the way we were
expecting
okay so you see like what we did here is
now we are now
using this approach
okay you see like we are using this
approach with using this
use comparative reference so we have a
call function button
we are passing two parameter props and
ref so we're getting this use reference
object
and use imperative we are passing this
ref
and this object here so we are using
this blur
as an
kind of custom objects where
console.log custom
properties getting called a reference
button equal to
button and you're saying dot dot props
click here button and export default
forward reference button here
and followed by app.js we are just using
this
normal app component
const but in equal to use reference null
return we are returning this button
on click
you see here equal to btn
okay it's just a reference what you're
using dot
current dot blur
and uh after that it's getting close
using ref equal to what btn whichever
you're referring it and that's it so the
job is done
so friends now after this the previous
example we have seen called imperative
now it's time to basically discuss about
another very interesting example that is
called use layout effect there is
another hook which is available to you
so this use layout effect actually works
similar
okay
to use use effect but rather working
asynchronously like what a use effect
does because use effect works
asynchronously
it fires synchronously after all
loading is done
again i'm repeating
the use layout effect works similar to
use effect but rather than
but rather working asynchronously like
how the use effect works okay what it
does is it basically it fires
synchronously after all norm
is done loading so this is pretty useful
for normally a synchronously
re-rendering the dom
okay so it is very useful for
synchronously re-rendering the dom and
also to read the layout
from the dock
but to prevent
blocking the page loading we should
always use use effect otherwise it will
block
so the use
layout effect okay works in the same
phase as component mount and component
did update methods we should only use
use effect layout effect if use effect
is not outputting the expected result
so let's take a look with a simple
example of the one which we are looking
forward for
okay so here in my code what we're doing
is
we're gonna give the new file name
called use
dot js
okay so let me add
constant
layout
okay
and here we're using cost
equal to
use state
and give any value whichever you would
like to give it okay let's say
welcome
and after that
you come down and say
use layout effect
okay and say if
value
equal to
welcome
i'm saying
set value
welcome to react hooks
okay so that's an expectations and after
that we are using what
the log and inside this lens is saying
use layout is working
okay with value so
using what the value here
okay
and
whenever the value changes
and listening to what the value here
and after this when we talk about return
so you have to return the values to
okay so we say
return
insert this tip we will say
value
that's it
and after this
in here
okay
so once it is ready you will see here
in your program
here we need to check
[Music]
so
value okay
all right so here i need to use
to make it okay so now
i go to the inspect
go to the console
let's refresh
and now you can see it is loading
synchronously
okay
so your application is now loading the
way it is expected
used out is working well it is working
so that's where the idea of this
particular example so
in this example we have built a name
changer application that changes the
name of the state when the use layout
effect is called
okay and it's working fine
okay everyone so now if it is ready then
we'll be talking about our next feature
here
that is called working with
use debug value
this is once again another hook
of the react-based development
so when we talk about use double value
so what use debug value actually does
and
what we
really do with the use debug value this
we would like to understand
okay see what happens not too many
developers nowadays know about
use debug value book okay though
although it provides a much better
debugging experience when it comes to
the debugging custom books so use debug
value is a simple in-build hook that
provides more information about the
logical of a custom mode within a react
dev tool so react dev tool is a tool
which you can
get it uh downloaded for your chrome
extension
okay
and
it allows you to display the additional
information
okay
next to your hooks with optional
formatting
okay so that's what the
redux
react
views debug values basically be useful
for
now how you basically use this so you
can just consider in this way uh if i
just go back and create a new file
and give the name called the usable
value
dodges
okay
so inside this youtuber.js
here we would like to use function
and in function we can use this option i
can use
friend status
use frame status so here
we can say
trend
id
and here we can use construct
is
online
set
online equal to
user state
we are providing the value called
okay and now here we use this option i
can use
debug value and here i told you is
online
question mark
here we say
online
okay and here
we say what
okay and after this we are talking about
this option
okay
so that's where exactly you perform
this condition for after that what you
can do you can just use this option i
can export
default
trendline online status
so this is where you can
basically perform this online debugging
sorry the debugging for all the
react hooks whichever you're looking for
so this is very popular and utilized and
useful option for the regular users
hello everybody and welcome you all
so today we have a very interesting
session coming up for this react which
is called react router so let's get
started with react router and see what
it offers so friends the first important
thing about what is the routing
as we know it very well the routing is
synonyms of
navigation
any application whether you talk about
multi-page application or single page
application it always requires a routing
through this routing you will be making
your applications
uh you know to be navigate from one part
to another part like you have called
login page registration page and you
have got a lot of links available and
when you click on those links
application will take you towards those
necessary pages but here in react these
are component centric architecture
so here you will be having a components
loaded
okay
so as we know in a traditional web
development routing plays a very very
crucial role so that you can navigate
through
okay
now
react router so what is the react router
so we know this react router is a client
and server side routing library provided
by the rehack it is a javascript
libraries which is normally known for
creating the attractive user interfaces
now here the traditional react router is
available on the web
okay and the server
so
with using traditional node.js
based application which is you know it
is designed for developing a server side
java based javascript based applications
and on react networks once again for
mobile phase environment for react
applications
now react router components so browser
router so typical we say the browser
router is this is one of the component
because react router comes with lot many
api so here's one of the api which is
called browser router so browser router
is something from where okay it uses the
traditional html5 history api which is
one of the main component
so
it keeps your
url in sync with what you are navigating
through
okay so next we have a call routes
so routes are basically chosen based on
what best matches you are providing it
so that when you click on those links so
appropriate root will get loaded for you
so called components
so now we have a call link so the
traditional link components are used to
basically create a hyperlinks like ahref
how we used in html pages
so
to different
uh from the traditional react replica
application so it is mainly designed
focus on navigation throughout the
applications
and now we have a call switch so
traditionally switch what it does it
renders the first routes and matches the
location rather than rendering all the
matching route like whichever has come
it is like a typical switch case
whichever comes it make it available and
come out
that's how it provides
okay so installation wise you need to
have
first
you have to create the react based
application by using
npx create reactor so
create react app is a tool provided by
the
official facebook and the router hyphen
tutorial is the name of the project
okay so you'll be using this command to
create a new project for you and post
that
you have to install
this particular dependency called react
hyphen router hyphen dom so this
dependency you need to install
post
first
i would say
the message is executed so once the
first command is ready then you will be
going inside this npm
install and then you say react router
down so this is how the steps are and
now we'll talk about demo so let's get
started with the demo part
okay everybody so it's time to
get into some hands-on
so i already have a project ready with
me which we have created with using
create react app so my project name is
react hyphen app
and i would like to create a new
uh
router based example here so the
dependency regarding react hyphen router
hyphen dom is already
installed so if you see this
package.json react router dom is already
there in place
so we would like to start now
developing those router based examples
so to make it happen what we will do is
here in my src
we will create a new folder name called
components
okay and inside these components
we will create some file name call
login
dot
js
likewise we would like to create a
register
user
details.js
one more
name call
portfolio
so we have got these pages already with
me
okay
out of which i want the first components
to be get launched here that is known as
call a landing page so here i will also
create
landing page.js
so let's go back and create a new
components here which will be helping us
to
move
here and there
so first thing in my landing page my
component.js i have a call app.js which
is a
base component for me
so as i can see this is how you go back
and create a new functional component so
i just copy the same
and here in login.json paste it
and give the name to
login
login and here we can say welcome to
login i just
this is my small component like copied
and i paste it in the portfolio
so you can portfolio welcome to
folio
register
register
login
user retails
okay so we have got these components
with us
i will start with
landing page first so
i would like to create a class-based
component here
so
import
to react
from
react
now 4d for class
landing page
exchange
component
now
render
return so the landing page is a
component which through which i'll start
working on
so
[Music]
i can say
welcome to landing so here i want this
components to be available outside
so what i will do is
this landing page in my index.js
i'll make it as a first component to be
launched
landing page so when i start my
application i should see here
okay welcome to lending is coming up
perfect
so this has become my first component
which i
want to launch and furthermore we would
like to add few more components here
okay so in our previous program we have
seen
how to create a multiple components and
how we can make one of the component as
a
learning component now it's our next
program where we will be enabling the
routing into our code
so level
landing page we would like to create
some more
dependency we are saying import
from
react hyphen router hyphen down so we
will be choosing those dependencies one
by one but from there
we want to start working with
cons routes
equal to
first thing
as i discussed with you that is we would
like to start with the browser router
okay
so
from this point onwards we would like to
start with
switch
as you can see they are taking from the
react router down
after the switch we will say
route
okay so here
with this route we would like to see the
navigation path we say path
equal to if it is
login
then which component i want to launch so
we can say
component
i'll say c small
component equal to
okay
it's not loading so we can say import
and since i want to launch the component
which is a type of login so we can say
import
from login
so if you see here
we work for login so we will be using
this login only
okay
so this is my login component likewise i
will say
from
register so here
i would like to say
login
and
in a similar way
we also want to have the another
registration
we copy the same
use this
okay
well
these are the quick two components we
have created one is called login and
second score register
after that what you will be doing this
routes you will be adding it and this is
div tag so i'm removing this landing
page
and here
i will give the name call
routes
that's it
so all this route has been given
now it's time for us to
see
what it differs
so landing page
or sorry we have a register we have a
register also
so
say route is not defined so what we can
do
we can also import it out from this page
now let's go back
okay nothing is shown so now we have to
manually type by saying
login you can see i've got this message
go welcome to login
now let's see register
and there we go register
so two components are loaded correctly
now we would like to import two more
import
portfolio
for
portfolio
okay
and last
we have a call a user details
import
name call
user details here
so we got user details let me copy these
two
so
register
portfolio
so this is how
our components are so now
we can see all the registers
successfully
then in our previous program we have
seen we were typing those urls manually
into our browser
but in real time this won't be a
solution
in a real time you would like to make
this example
by clicking on a hyperlink you would
like to make it possible so i will be
doing this
so to make it possible what you will be
doing is
like here itself you create a new
component called
header
okay
so this is how we're going to create the
new component called header
okay
so within this
you're going to add
the new
i call header within this you will be
using
nav link which is once again the tool
provided by
react to which you can create a
hyperlinks
so this is the nav link for you
so within the snap link you will provide
the option like in two
equal to
login
and
along with this
you will also provide
the name so here i say
login let me copy the same
login
register
register
we also have called
last we have called
portfolio
so this is my component which is
available to me and this i would like to
use
within my application so here
after this browser router
we would like to add the component
called
header here
that's it that's the only thing we need
to do now this header component is now
the part of
routes and let's see how it makes a
difference now you can see
very clearly it is having those links
with me and now when i click on those
links
you can see how these are easily
accessible to all of us
okay so these are the links which are
available to us through which we can
make our components
simple and easy to access
one more thing we can do it here
and what's that
this component whichever we are talking
about okay
this component we can attach
to one of my
base component when my components start
it should work automatically so i can do
one thing let my login component to be
the base component for me
so in order to make this possible i need
to write one more tool here called
exact equal to
true
and here also we have to use the same
so here
we would like to add one more property
here
okay and we will say exact equal to true
okay what i would like to use
exact equal to true
that's it any job is done now let's
check
and now you can see the by default login
page appeared
because the login is in root location
and that's all
your url works
okay everybody so in a previous examples
we have seen how the links are working
but these links are all internal links
but what in case if i want to go to the
external link so let's try to understand
that point so here let me try to open up
i'm opening up simply learn link and i'm
clicking on this
the url is right now https
simplylearn.com
that's a link which is available so let
me try to copy this link
and
[Music]
here
if you want to go to that location so
what do we need to do now
so to make it possible
here i can just make this another nav
link
copy the same
and i give the name call
simpler
and
and here i'll just copy the same
okay
so now it is asking me for the component
because i do not have any component here
right now
so here what i will be doing instead
i am making it as a blank
okay and here
i want to give window
dot location
dot
href
equal to
the website which is available
okay so that will be the link which i am
providing it now and
after this link what has been provided
i'm saying
return
that's it
okay so that'll be the link
so i'm saving this and going back to
this
location now
so you can see we have all simply that
the moment i click it here
so
it will somehow try to take me towards
where
this external website the one which
we're actually looking forward for
okay so this is the way
through which you can basically make
the application accessible outside so if
i just go back to my browser and
[Music]
refresh this and click on simply learn
and you can see now it took me to an
external location called simplyland.com
likewise if i just go back and open
the
simple learn
as a youtube channel
also just say
okay simply do
youtube so if any of the
i would say
the link
which is available right you can see
right now we have got
multiple websites so if i just click on
anything suppose
this is a link for me
and
i try to create one more link here
just like we have a call simply learn so
let's create one more and i say
simply learn
youtube simply on youtube so here
i copy the same
okay so here
in my browser whatever the link is
provided i'll just copy this link
and
paste this link right over there
okay so this is what a link which is
available to me
now i go back to my code
i can say simply run youtube i click it
and you can see it took me to where to
the right
so this is the way you see
how the links are basically created
and they are simply available to us
in a very simplified manner
okay and that's where
the hyperlinks are basically working
with us
welcome to the session on react.js
interview questions through this session
we will explore the most commonly posed
interview questions that you would face
if you walk up to a developer interview
on react.js let's start with going
through and exploring the general set of
react.js interview questions that would
be commonly asked in an interview the
first question would be what are the
features of react.js now right through
this session we would follow a common
methodology where we would explore the
question and then look at the best way
in which you could have answered that
question if posed to you during a
react.js interview so starting with the
first question what are the features of
react so react has many extensions for
complete application architecture
support jsx is used with react to
describe what the user interface should
typically look like react is broken into
small components so you look at the
complete application you want to build
break it down into individual components
and a component is typically a piece of
user interface like a function that
would return a stream of html characters
speedy performance is one of the core
features of react as only the updated
components need to be re-rendered on the
screen and not the entire page the
one-way data binding feature on the
other hand keeps everything modular and
fast the virtual dom is also a
lightweight representation of the real
dom which is again a feature which helps
speed up performance and avoids a full
page refresh and a full dom tree shake
which really speeds up performance so
what is jsx how do you answer this so
jsx is typically the extension used for
react and it's nothing but an extension
to the javascript programming language
because all that you can use inside your
browser for execution typically has to
be javascript because in html5 you
cannot have any third-party plugins
installed in the browser and that's the
reason the browser would only ship by
default with a javascript runtime engine
so by using jsx you can write html
structures in the same file that would
contain your javascript code as well
making the updates to the code very
simple so it's simple to update and make
modifications to your code because the
code and the data and the business logic
is all composed in a single file so
because the code and the business logic
is in a single file it makes
updating and incorporating change
requests
to the code very simple and easy so it's
basically used with react to describe
what your user interface should look
like and it's what you typically would
term as the html template or the view
coming to the next question can jsx be
directly read by the web browser so web
browsers cannot read jsx directly now
why is that well the reason is simple
it's because they are only built to read
regular javascript objects and jsx is
not a regular javascript objects it's a
react component so for a web browser to
read a jsx file the file needs to be
transformed into a regular javascript
object and for this there is a
javascript api called babel which is
internally used by react so what do you
understand by the virtual dom that we've
been speaking about in react so react
gives a very lightweight representation
of the real dom the actual dom structure
of the page so dom is document object
model it is uh an api created by w3c and
it creates an in-memory representation
of the html elements as an inverted tree
structure a balanced tree structure
which is the fastest search algorithm
when you want to search for html
elements and do a dynamic update on them
but again updating the basic dom tree
structure of the page causes a full page
refresh and if you only want to update a
specific component you wouldn't need the
entire page to be refreshed and that is
where react comes in it uses a virtual
dom which is a layer on top of the
actual dom which ensures that only a
certain part of the page is refreshed
and that speeds up performance so when
the state of an object changes virtual
dom changes only that object in the real
dom instead of updating all the objects
and this is what makes things really
fast so why use react instead of other
frameworks like angular first of all
it's very easy to create dynamic web
pages dhtml where you can update the
view of the template at runtime the
components are reusable so you reuse
rather than reinvent the performance is
great since you're working with the
virtual dom you don't need a full page
refresh the unidirectional data flow
makes data move one way there's no
two-way data binding by default and
that's the reason the page does not have
to do a lot of heavy lifting of
remembering whether the view is changing
whether the the base javascript entity
class is changing and that saves a lot
of uh processing time again to debug
react is much more simpler and that's
what makes it more popular in terms of
its simplicity and speed as compared to
other frameworks like angular what is
the difference between es5 and es6
standard so these are scripting
standards okay that are defined by the
european computer manufacturers
association or ecma and all of the
scripting languages are a subset of the
standard and are derived from these
standards to ensure that the code will
execute on all browsers and the code
that we are writing is standards based
so these are the few instances where es6
syntax has changed from es5 if you look
at the es5 syntax on the top we are
creating a simple react class component
and the render function just returns a
stream of html content in ex6 there's a
new keyword that comes in which is
extends so you are extending from the
base react component and creating a
custom component and then returning a
stream of characters also the function
keyword no longer needs to be used so
the exports versus export also changes
so you use exports to export out class
from a module so that it can be accessed
from another module in es6 you simply
say export and the component require
versus import so you would require a
third-party component or an api into
your javascript file to use it in es6
it's replaced with the import statement
very similar to the syntax that we use
in core java so how do you go and create
a react app first you install node.js as
a base platform which you can download
from the node.js website next any text
editor of your choice could be atom
visual studio code or sublime text third
you create a react app using a command
prompt terminal depending on the os you
are using the command to give is create
hyphen react space my first app okay so
the command that you would give to
create a new react app is create hyphen
react hyphen app space and the name of
the application you would want to create
in this case it is my hyphen first
hyphen app and that could be a custom
name of your choice so what is an event
in react well on the web when you talk
about dynamic html it's all about
interacting with the user so the user
performs some interaction event with the
web page which could be a click of a
button a mouse move and these events in
action can be triggered by a user or any
system or could be pressing a key or a
mouse click etc and in response to that
event you would execute a block of code
which is called an event handler so here
we have class simple which is a custom
class that extends the base react
component the name of the function work
which triggers a simple alert message
box and a render function which returns
html when you click on the button we
would want to bind that to the event
handler this dot work and that's how you
connect a click event to an event
handler function what are synthetic
events in react well a synthetic event
is an object which acts as a cross
browser wrapper around the browser's
native event it combines the behavior of
different browser's native events into
one api which makes sure that the events
are consistent across different browsers
and this brings in the standard space
development to ensure in this digital
age the code that we are creating for
different browsers have consistency in
terms of its execution so here we see a
function action link we see a function
handle click which takes e as an event
parameter e dot prevent default ensures
that there is no error that the browser
is raising in case the event function
call is not directly compatible with
that specific browser so prevent default
is used to suppress any browser specific
errors or crashes and a simple
console.lock which will lock into the
developer tools window which says you
just clicked a link and then we've got
the return where we are returning the
view to or the html template where on
click we connect to this event handler
called handle click so handle click is
basically a wrapper and the entire
action link is a wrapper object which is
a synthetic event we don't directly go
and bind to the on click and then
associate a function with it we actually
associate a synthetic object with it
which binds the base default event that
could be specific to a browser so some
browsers would probably understand an on
click sun another browser would
understand a click and to ensure that
its consistency of syntax and from a
development perspective the code that we
write will run on all browsers we need
to take care of using the synthetic
events which isolate the developer out
from the complexity of writing code
specific to different browsers so you
just write generic code which will work
on different browsers so how do lists
work in react so the lists display data
in an ordered format the traversal of
lists is done using the map function so
here we see there is a function called
list of names which takes a variable
props as a parameter props dot names
will allow us to get a reference to all
of the array of names that are passed
constant list names is another variable
created equal to name start map and
we are using the arrow operator which is
now an ecmascript standard and
again we are using the opening tag of
the li html element the key is equal to
the name attribute so the brace bracket
will bind that to the name attribute
then we just print the name itself and
we close the ally tag so that's the
name start names.map function and
finally we return in an unordered list
the list names themselves so the map
function will run through an iterate
over the list of names list them in the
li tag the li tag will get injected into
the unordered list and will finally get
returned out as a stream of html
elements in the next code snippet below
we create a constant variable names we
are associating it with a set of five
names and uh we simply say render list
of names names equal to names the moment
we do that
we are using list of names as a custom
html element which is not system defined
it starts looking for the function list
of names passes the names added to it
iterates over it using the map function
which is an inbuilt react function
brings out all of the lists it's very
similar to a ford loop that you would
write for iteration in other programming
languages and then finally what you get
returned in the getelementbyid app is
nothing but a list of simple names
wrapped in a li element that are printed
on the view so why is there a need of
using keys in lists so keys are very
important in the code snippet that we
saw due to the following reasons the
first reason the key is a unique
identifier if you would want to search
for a name in the list it is used to
identify which items have changed
updated or deleted from the list so if
you want to perform cred operations on
the data you would want to search for
which element do you want to update or
delete or change it also helps to
determine which components need to be
re-rendered instead of re-rendering all
the components every time and it
increases performance as only the
changed components have to be
re-rendered and not all the components
on the page what are forms in react so
using forms users can interact with the
application and enter required
information whenever needed so forms can
contain certain elements such as text
fields buttons checkboxes radio buttons
etc and forms are also used for many
different tasks such as user
authentication searching filtering etc
how do you create a form pretty simple
again create a custom component called
name from that will extend reactor
component we create a state variable
this dot state is equal to value we
handle the change by writing a handle
change event and we handle the submit by
writing a handle submit event in the
change event we just change the state by
saying set state of the value to event
or target dot value event being a system
defined keyword passed as a parameter
and in the submit we simply alert that a
certain name was entered and we trap the
value that was entered into the form
prevent default to suppress the browser
from raising any errors on the render
function we return a form on the submit
we connect to the handle submit event
and we bind the data submitted from the
form to the handle submit event and we
pass the this pointer which is a
reference to the current context of the
view itself we open a label specify the
name we then specified input box as text
the value is set to this dot state dot
value and on change we simply connect to
the handle change event and bind to it
and pass the context of the text box
itself so the moment we change the value
in the text box as we are typing the
handle change event will receive the
updated value and set the state and when
we click on the submit button the handle
submit event handler executes and we
alert out the current value printed in
the text box and that's it so how do you
write comments in react when you're a
developer if you want to comment out
some code or if you want to set comments
to enhance the maintainability of the
code a single line comment is as simple
as given in most other programming
languages backslash as strict to open
astrix to close multi-line commands
follow the same syntax and can span
multiple lights to add comments to
functions in terms of what the function
can do and what are the types that it
can return what is the arrow function
and how is it used so an arrow function
is a shorter way of writing a function
in react if you look at the snippet on
the top my input on change equal to we
are connecting to this dot handle change
dot bind and that's the longer version
of how you can connect it to an event
handler the shorter version is on change
equal to e
dot
arrow
operator
change so you don't need to call the
bind explicitly you can replace that
with the arrow operator and reduce the
amount of code that you typically write
how is react different from react native
so react and react native are completely
different react was released in 2013
it's a web-based platform it is html
compliant it generates html views it
uses css for styling and it's based on
javascript html and css react native on
the other hand is targeted to mobility
devices it's meant to create installable
apps on android and ios released in 2015
not based on html and css and it
basically requires the react.js api to
create these installable apps for these
mobility ecosystems how is react
different from angular another popular
framework by google so angular created
by google completely based on the model
view controller pattern works on the
real dom layer and requires a full tree
shake at the tom layer to update views
and components supports bi-directional
data mining the rendering is purely done
on the client side the performance
comparatively slow react.js on the other
hand created by facebook it's the view
layer of the model view controller
pattern it works at the virtual dom
layer and it sends faster it's
unidirectional data binding and not
two-way and the rendering is typically
what is done at the server side and what
you get is a response on the client as a
stream of html characters as an output
let's talk about and discuss some
questions around react components so
what are components in react so these
are the building blocks you can think of
them as lego blocks so you break your
problem down into small parts each part
identifying a certain solution of the
problem which is what we define as a
component so they are building blocks of
a react application and a single app
usually consists of multiple components
so it splits the ui into independent
reusable pieces that can be processed
separately a component is essentially a
piece of the user interface or the html
view what is the use of render method in
react so it is compulsory for each
component to have a render method if not
there wouldn't be any html for the
component to render on your view so the
render function returns the html which
is to be displayed within a component
like you see on the screen there is a
class app that extends the react
component and it returns a simple h1
element called hello simply learn and of
course do remember to export the app out
so that it can be accessed from other
components as well if you need to render
more than one element all the elements
must be inside a single parent tag like
a div or a form what is state in react
the state of a component is an object
that holds some data within it the data
would influence the output of the
component now how do you implement state
in react so state holds the data that a
component renders on the web application
for example here we've created
in the constructor this dot state equal
to and this temporary anonymous object
has two attributes car and pi when we
return we simply return this dot state
dot car and this dot state dot by now
this is how you would create stateful
components and access the state
properties within the view how do you
update the state of a component by using
the built-in set state method you can go
ahead and update the state of the
component so here we have a simple
render function that returns the state
itself state dot message and on the on
click connects to a button press
function the moment you click on the
button the button press function sets
the state to another message so the
initial message in the constructor is
welcome to simply learn the moment you
click on the button the set state
triggers and changes it to best place to
learn so the data on the view would be
updated what are props in react well
props is just a short form for
properties and that is what allows us to
pass arguments or data to a component
props are passed to components in the
way similar to that of attributes that
are passed to an html element so how do
you pass props between two components so
let's say we have an app.js component on
the top and a main.js component at the
bottom at the top we are trying to
return
car
this.props.car
the pike so two car and bike attributes
associated with this props of the app
component in the main component when you
look at the render function we are
associating car prop equal to a value of
1 1600cc and bikeprop equal to value of
150cc
and to access it if you look at the
import statement we are importing app
from
app.jsx and this is how you can cross
access properties from one component
within the other so what are the
difference between state and props well
state holds information about the
components they are mutable they can be
changed they cannot be accessed by child
components and they cannot have state
props allow to pass data from one
component to the other as an argument
they are immutable they are read only
and props can be accessed by the child
component and they can have props as
well what is a higher order component in
react so these act as a container for
other components which helps in keeping
components simple and induces the
reusability factor they are generally
used when a common logic has to be used
by multiple components that's when you
group together a set of components
within a higher order component in react
how can you embed two or more components
into one this code snippet demonstrates
the app component which returns a hollow
text and it has a custom tag called
simple the simple tag is defined in the
component below and it returns text
called simply learn and in the render of
the react dom
we simply go and render the app
component so hello simply learn would be
the final output and that's how you can
embed one component into the other using
this methodology what are the
differences between class and functional
components so stateful components would
extend react component in this case and
if you could look at the render it
simply renders this dot props dot title
the constant stateless component would
be equal to props the div tag returns
this dot props dot title so you can look
at the style very different in terms of
class and functional components one
using the arrow operator one using the
traditional class and render method so
the class component can hold or manage
state complex as compared to stateless
components can work all of the life
cycle methods of the component and it
can be reused the functional component
cannot hold a managed state they are
simple and easy to understand it does
not work with any lifecycle method and
it cannot be reused let's explain the
lifecycle methods of components we've
got initial state which is executed
before the creation of the component
component did mount which is executed
when the component gets rendered and
placed on the dom should component
update which is invoked when a component
decides any changes to the dom and
returns true or false value based on
certain conditions component did update
it is invoked immediately after the
rendering takes place component will
unmount which is invoked immediately
before a component is destroyed and
unmounted permanently let's move to the
react redux set of questions so what is
redux it's an open source javascript
library used to manage application state
and react uses redux for building the
user interface what are components of
redux the first is the store which holds
the state of the application store
contains state which defines the user
interface which triggers a set of
actions which are then sent to the
reducer so store holds the state action
is the source information for the store
and reducer specifies how the
application state changes in response to
actions sent to the store what is flux
well flux is the application
architecture that facebook uses for
building web applications and it works
in this way the action is triggered
which is sent to the dispatcher the
dispatcher sends it to the store the
store sends it to the view and the view
sends it back to the action and that's
exactly how the steps would continue in
sequence so when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified once
the dispatcher has dealt with an action
the stores listening to it will get
triggered the view gets updated when the
state of the store changes user action
at the view is sent to the dispatcher to
then be processed how is redux different
from flux redux is an open source
javascript library used to manage
application state the store state is
immutable it can only have a single
store and it uses the concept of reducer
flux on the other hand is an
architecture and not a framework or
library the store state is mutable it
can have multiple stores and it uses the
concept of dispatcher let's look at some
react router questions what is a react
router a rear router is a package which
is used to create routing in a react
application react router is used for
developing single page web applications
it allows multiple views in a single
application by defining multiple routes
in that react application how is react
routing different from conventional
routing react routing has a single html
page it uses or the end user rather
would navigate multiple views within the
same file called a single page app the
page does not refresh since it's a
single page file and there is improved
performance since you are not navigating
across multiple pages conventional
routing each view is a separate html
file the user would navigate multiple
files for each view the page would
refresh every time the user navigates
which would hence result in slower
performance how do you implement react
routing you can implement react routing
using a very simple method considering
the above components let's say you've
got a component called app about and
contact so here you can specify the
route path if the route part is just
slash the route default route it takes
you to the app component if the route is
slash about in the url given by the end
user you automatically navigate and
activate and load the about component
and if the url is slash contact it would
take you to the contact component let's
talk about react styling questions how
do you style react components either you
use inline styling by using simple css
by simply saying color blue and that's
going to be the output of the h1 element
or i could use a javascript object by
specifying a constant simple style
object and specifying a keypair value of
color background color margin font
family and apply that object as the
style parameter which would result in
this styled output how do you style
react components using a css style sheet
so here's an external style sheet so
we've written all the styling rules in a
separate css file app.css we've imported
that at the top of the app.js react
class and lo and behold you have the
output simplified as generated on your
page let's explain the use of css
modules in react so a css module file is
created.module.css is the extension the
css inside a module file is available
only for the component that is importing
it so there are no naming conflicts so
dot button is the css styling inside
button.module.css
and that is what we've imported from in
the app.js file so when you view the
button style start button is the styling
picked up from the
button.module.css file in this tutorial
we will cover everything you need to
know about typescript
typescript is an object oriented and
strongly typed programming language
which is superset of javascript
typescript code is converted to
javascript which can be executed
anywhere javascript is supported
let's look at today's agenda
we'll first understand what is
typescript
followed by which we'll look at the
typescript tutorial then we will see the
difference between javascript versus
typescript
followed by which we will understand
some of the concepts in typescript
generics
then we will see how to interface
typescript with react with nodejs and
with express tutorial then we will look
at some of the advanced typescript
concepts followed by which we will
create a real-time chat application
project using typescript javascript and
node.js
and at last we will look at typescript
interview questions which will help you
crack any typescript interview at ease
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simplylearn so
without any further ado let's get
started
what is typescript
typescript is object oriented and
strongly type programming language which
is superset of javascript
typescript code is converted to
javascript which can be executed
anywhere javascript is supported in a
browser or node.js and any other
application ebscript was designed by
anders hegelsberg at microsoft the
limitations of javascript for the
development of large-scale application
at the microsoft and among its external
customers led to the creation of
typescript due to the difficulty of
working with the complicated javascript
code there was demand for custom tooling
to make developing javascript components
easier
typescript is javascript with some
additional features
to support a strong interaction with
your editor typescript adds additional
syntax to javascript typescript is a
scripting language that understands
javascript and uses type inference to
provide powerful capabilities without
the need for additional code
why typescript compilation javascript is
an interpreted language there is no need
to compile it as a result it must be run
to ensure that it is genuine if there is
an error that implies you write all the
code to find out an output
as a result you will have to spend hours
looking for the faults in the code so
error checking is provided via the
typescript transpiler if typescript
detects any syntax mistakes it will
compile the code and generate
compilation errors this aids in the
detection of mistakes prior to the
execution of the script
typescript provides an optional type
system for javascript code when a client
doesn't have a value for a parameter he
can pass a null optional arguments are
features of typescript we can declare
some arguments in the function optional
by utilizing optional parameter features
so that the client is not necessary to
supply a value to optional parameters
strong static typing javascript does not
have a powerful static typing system
does the tls typescript comes with an
optional static typing and type
inference system the tls that is a
typescript language service can deduce
the type of variable defined with no
type based on its value
supports object oriented programming
such as classes interfaces inheritance
and other object oriented programming
principles are supported by typescript
typescript supports type definitions
existing javascript libraries can use
typescript type definitions external
javascript libraries are defined in
typescript definition files
as a result these libraries can be
included in typescript code
now let us look at the difference
between typescript versus javascript
typescript is an object oriented
programming language
whereas javascript is a scripting
language
and typescript supports static typing
whereas javascript does not support
static typing
errors can be found and corrected during
compile time
in javascript errors can be found only
during the runtime as it is an
interpreted language
there is a concept for es3 es4 es5 and
es6 in typescript whereas no support for
compiling additional es3 es4 es5 or as6
features in javascript
functions can have optional parameters
in typescript whereas this feature is
not possible in javascript
converted into javascript code to be
understandable for browsers in
typescript in javascript this can
directly be used in browsers
in typescript proper build setup is
required for static type definitions
no build setup is required in javascript
now let us look at the features of
typescript
typescript supports other javascript
libraries typescript is a new microsoft
language that is highly typed super set
of javascript with support for object
oriented programming and other current
features like decorators
because browsers and nodes comprehend
javascript typescript compiles to
javascript
typescript is portable typescript is
cross browser cross device and cross
platform it can run in any environment
that supports javascript typescript
unlike its computators does not require
dedicated virtual machine or a specific
runtime environment to run typescript is
superset of javascript
it's a strong syntactical superset of
javascript with the addition of optional
static typing
typescript is a large-scale application
development language that transcompiles
to javascript
typescript is static and typescript is
object oriented language
when a client doesn't have a value for a
parameter he can personal optional
arguments are a feature of typescript
when it comes to object oriented
programming with javascript javascript
shines because of the class keyword it
makes object-oriented programming look
quite similar to programming in other
object-oriented languages like c-sharp
or java
applications of typescript
typescript can be used to develop
javascript applications for both
client-side and server-side execution
typescript can be deployed instead of
javascript language since it adds more
features and gives error directly with
the code
typescript is used for building
large-scale application for enterprises
advantages of typescript
highlights error at the compilation time
during the time of development
in typescript it runs on any browser or
javascript engine
typescript has a namespace concept by
defining a module
typescript support strongly typed or
static typing
disadvantages of typescript
typescript takes a long time to compile
the code
typescript does not support abstract
classes
typescript has extra compilation step
for converting typescript into
javascript typescript has an overly
complicated typing system
setting up development environment
firstly we need to go to node.js
official website and install node.js
after installing
go to command prompt and type the
function node space hyphen v to check if
the node is installed properly
to install typescript run the command
in pm note package manager install
globally typescript in the command
prompt and this will install typescript
so let's jump to the browser and see the
installation of load.js and typescript
then we will go to visual studio and see
the different components like loops
variables data types with examples
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more so to install
node.js come to the website nodejs.org
here come to the downloads and from here
you can install node.js
node is an open source server side
execution platform for javascript code
node is commonly used for real-time
applications like chat news feeds and
web push notifications because it allows
for a persistent connection from browser
to the server
node.js is a javascript runtime based on
v8 javascript engine from chrome
node.js is an asynchronous event-driven
javascript runtime for building scalable
network applications
to install for windows click on windows
if you have mac os click on mac os to
install
so i'll click on windows here we go
node.js is getting installed
since i have already installed in my
device i'll cancel it
so once the installation is complete and
you have installed the node.js
next go to command prompt
in the command prompt run the command
node
hyphen v to check if whether the node.js
is installed properly
and here it shows the version of node.js
installed in our device
so here we can see that node is
installed properly next we need to
install typescript
to install typescript we need to run the
command npm node package manager install
hyphen g globally typescript
if you run this command the typescript
will be installed
the typescript will be installed
worldwide with this command this implies
that each project you create on your
computer can use typescript dependencies
without having to reinstall the
typescript package
so after running this the typescript
will be installed since i have already
installed will clear this
so after installing typescript to check
if whether the typescript is installed
properly
to check if the compiler is installed
just type dsc typescript compiler
space
hyphen version
and here you can see the typescript
compiler of version 4.5.4 is installed
now that we know how to install node.js
and
type script now we will go to visual
studio and
see the
examples
so let's see the different types of
variables available in typescript
for variable declaration typescript
follows the same rules as javascript
variables can be declared with the
commands like
variable
or we have
let
and we have constant
const
so these are the three types of variable
declarations available in typescript
we'll see them one by one
variables can be declared in typescript
using the var keyword just like in
javascript the scoping rules are
identical to those in javascript
for example we can declare a variable
of parameter h
and it is of the type number
which is equal to
say 45 something like this
and similarly we have
let
so let is a ecmascript 6 introduce two
new types of variable declarations in
javascript using the keyword let and
const to solve the issues with variable
declarations
these additional sorts of variable
declarations are also supported by
typescript which is a superset of
javascript
for example we have let say employee
name
is equal to john
similarly we have constant
constant variables are declared in the
same way as variable and let variables
are constant transforms a variable into
a constant whose value cannot be changed
the same scoping constraints apply to
constant variable as they do to the let
variables
for example we have constant
num
is equal to
100
something like this
next we will look at the different data
types in typescript
we have different data types like number
string
boolean array etc
so number first we'll look at the number
just like javascript typescript supports
number data type
all numbers are stored as floating point
numbers
these numbers can be a decimal
hexadecimal
for example
say let
first
number
one two three
so
let's again
the third number
is equal to this is of the type now we
will write octal
and don't forget to put colon otherwise
it will show an error
that
fourth
now will declare the number of type say
binary
so typescript supports number data types
like the numbers can be stored in
floating point numbers or decimal or
hexadecimal octal or binary
so this is basically a number
and this
is hexadecimal
[Music]
this is octal
and this is binary these are the
different number methods in typescript
the method two exponential returns the
exponential notation in string format
two fixed returns the fixed point
notation in string format
to locate string converts a number into
a local specific representation of the
number
two precision returns a string
representation in exponential or fixed
point to be specified precision
tostring returns the string
representation of the number in the
specified base and value off returns a
primitive value of the number
next we have string then the data type
which we have is string string is an
another primitive data type that is used
to store text data
string values are surrounded by single
quotation marks or double quotation mark
for example
we say declare it let employee
name
string of the type string
is equal to
johnson
so this is of the type string
the different string methods in
typescript are
kept method character at returns the
character at the given index concatenate
returns the combination of two or more
specified strings
index off returns an index of first
occurrence of this specified substring
from a string and minus 1 if not found
the method replace replaces the matched
substring with a new substring
and the method split splits the string
into substrings and returns an array
two upper case converts all the
characters of the string into upper case
two lower case converts all the
characters of the string into the lower
case the next type which we have is
boolean boolean values are supported by
both javascript and typescript and
stored as true or false
example for boolean is say let
here note that the boolean with small b
is different from the boolean capital b
so the uppercase boolean is an object
type whereas the lowercase boolean is a
primitive type
it is always recommended to use the
primitive type boolean that is a
lowercase boolean in the code because
while javascript courses an object to
its primitive type
the typescript type system does not the
typescript treats it like in the object
type
the another data type is of the type
array
an array is a special type of data type
which can store multiple values of
different data types sequentially using
a special syntax
typescript supports array similar to
javascript there are two ways to declare
an array one is using the square
brackets and the other is using a
generic array type
example
this is one type to declare with the
square brackets
and the other type is to use
the generic array type
both methods produce the same output
arrays can contain elements of any data
types numbers strings or even objects
arrays can be declared and initialized
separately
these are the different array methods in
typescript
we have pop that removes the last
element of the array and returns that
element and push adds the new elements
to the array and returns the new array
length sort sorts all the elements of
the array and similarly we have concat
index of copy within fill
shift splice
and shift
includes join
last index of
that returns the last index of the
element in an array similarly we have
slice to string and to locate string
similarly we have
tuple
union any void and never as the data
types in typescript
next we will look at the if statement in
typescript
an if statement can include one or more
expressions which return boolean if the
boolean expression evaluates to true
a set of statements is then executed and
in if-else condition
if else condition includes two blocks
if block and an else block if the if
condition evaluates to true then if
block is executed otherwise the else
block is executed
and we also have elsif so the elsif
statement can be used for if statement
next we will see loops in typescript
typescript supports for loop the for
loop is used to execute a block of code
a given number of times which is
specified by a condition
so this is the for loop
the first expression is executed before
the for loop starts and the second
expression is the condition for the loop
to execute and the third expression is
executed after the execution of every
code block here in this example i is
equal to 0 declares and initializes a
variable the second condition i is less
than 3 checks whether the value of i is
less than 3 or not
if it is less then it exits the loop the
third statement
increases the value of i by 1.
this loop will execute the block 3 times
until the value of i becomes three now
that we have seen loops we'll see the
functions in typescript
functions are the primary blocks of any
program functions are the most important
part
since it is a functional programming
language with functions we can implement
the concepts of oops like classes
objects polymorphism and abstraction
functions ensure that the program is
maintainable and reusable and organized
into readable blocks while typescript
provides a concept of classes and module
functions still are integral part of the
language for example
we have function
sum
so this is the example of function
classes in typescript now let us look at
the classes in typescript
so in object-oriented programming
classes are fundamental entities used to
create reusable components
typescript has been primarily a
functional programming language
where inheritance is prototype based
functions are used to build reusable
components
let us see an example for the classes
employee name
so we'll create a class employee
and
provide employee
id
employee name
so the typescript compiler
will convert the class to the javascript
code using the closure
and the constructor
is a special type of method which is
called when creating an object in
typescript the construction method is
always defined with the name constructor
so in this example the employee class
includes a constructor with the
parameter employee id
in the constructor members of the class
can be accessed using this keyword
example this dot employee id
it is not necessary for every class to
have a constructor
first up what is javascript
now javascript is a powerful client-side
scripting language
it is mainly used for enhancing the
interaction of a user with the web page
in other words you can make your web
page more lively and interactive with
the help of this language
javascript is also being used widely in
game development web development server
development and robotics among others
so talking about why javascript is being
used
first up is that it's open source
next as discussed earlier it has
excellent user interaction
meaning the scripts are basically
written in html pages and are executed
automatically with embedded javascript
also javascript offers a wide range of
libraries and frameworks some popular
ones are react
angular vue.js among others
and some other key features of
javascript include excellent speed
cross browser compatibility that is
javascript code runs on all browsers
like google chrome
firefox safari you name it
and lastly simple things are done simply
it offers simple semantics allowing a
seamless developer experience
then what exactly is typescript
now typescript is an object-oriented
programming language which is a superset
of javascript
it's basically javascript with other
impressive additional features
and all the code written in typescript
gets compiled to javascript ultimately
now let's look at some of the key
features of typescript that make you
want to use it
firstly it's a superset of javascript as
mentioned earlier typescript is a
superset of javascript
now it supports all javascript libraries
and apis
in fact angular which is a javascript
framework
that is used to build single page
applications is completely written in
typescript
now typescript uses object oriented
programming concepts
with the increase in code complexity
javascript had to fulfill the
requirements of object oriented
programming
hence typescript was introduced to
bridge the gap
typescript helps with quicker code
development thus improving performance
and lastly as mentioned earlier it adds
several additional features to
javascript making coding excessively
easy
now let's look at some of the advantages
of typescript over javascript
typescript always points out the
compilation errors at the time of
development
now because of this at the run time the
chances of getting errors are very less
however in case of javascript it's an
interpreted language and all errors are
shown during runtime
next typescript supports static typing
this means that all the variables that
are used in your program are basically
known during compile time
now since this feature is
used it leads to better code completion
type checking tooling and refactoring
as mentioned earlier typescript adds a
lot of features to javascript right so
typescript adds features like interfaces
generics namespaces null checking and
access modifiers
and lastly it provides excellent tooling
with intellisense which provides active
hints as the code is typed
moving ahead
i am sure you must have gathered the
differences between the two languages
however let me just brief them up for
you
firstly typescript is object-oriented
language while javascript is a
client-side scripting language
now typescript supports
strongly typed and static typing feature
while javascript does not support it
in case of typescript errors are
highlighted at the time of development
making it easier for codes to run
however
javascript makes sure that it highlights
errors at runtime
now typescript code is always converted
to javascript and then run on browsers
while javascript directly runs on
browsers
now typescript supports prototyping
while javascript does not support
prototyping
lastly as mentioned typescript supports
modules generics
namespaces access modifiers etc
while javascript does not support these
features
so lastly which one should you choose
now what are the developers around the
world using
according to google trends
growth in typescript has plateaued in
the last 12 months while javascript
still has a large user base
so with that you can gather that a lot
of developers out there
prefer javascript over typescript
but if you wonder which one suits you
better
well if you are an experienced developer
and work on smaller projects then
javascript is ideal
but if you prefer a statically typed
language and you are working on a new
library or a framework or if you're
working in a big project with multiple
developers
then typescript would be a better option
what is typescript generics
typescript generics is a tool for
creating reusable components in
typescript
rather than working with a single data
type it builds a component that can
interact with various data kinds it
enables users to consume these
components while also using their own
kinds
generics ensure that the software is
both adaptable and scalable over time
type safety is provided via generics
without sacrificing performance or
efficiency
the type variable in typescript is used
to denote types and uses generics
generic functions have the same type as
non-generic functions with type
arguments specified first as in function
declarations
why use typescript generics
consider the below code without generics
the identity function is a function that
returns whatever is sent in as a
parameter we could either provide the
identity function with a specific type
or identity function with any type
while the use of any is generic when we
use any the function accepts any kind
for the type of argument as a result
when function returns we lose
information about what the type was the
only information we have is that any
type could be produced if we pass in a
string
we need the means to capture the
argument type in such a way that we can
use it to signify what is being returned
as well we will utilize a type variable
here which is a form of variable that
deals with types rather than values
the identity function now has a type
variable called time this type allows us
to capture the type of data the user
supplies
for example a number or a string so that
we can use it later we are going to
utilize the type as a return type once
more
we can use two methods to invoke generic
identity function after writing it one
method is to pass all the parameters to
the function including the type argument
the other method is to utilize type
argument inference
now let us look at the typescript
generic types
generic functions have the same type
parameters as non-generic functions with
the type parameters listed first as in
the function declarations
we can call the generic type parameter
in the type by whatever name we like as
long as the number of type variables and
how they have utilized match
the generic type can also be written as
a call signature of an object literal
type
typescript generic classes
a generic class resembles a generic
interface in appearance
following the name of class generic
classes contain a generic type parameter
list enclosed in angular brackets
although this is relatively literal use
of the generic number class you will
notice that nothing restricts it to
using only the number type instead we
may have used string or even more
complicated objects
a class type has two sides a static side
and an instant side generic classes are
only generic on the instant side not on
the static side hence static members
can't use the class type parameters
while working with them
although this is relatively literal use
of the generic number class you will
notice that nothing restricts it to
using only the number type
instead we may have used string or even
more complicated objects
putting the type parameter on the class
itself like the interface ensures that
all of the classes property functions
with the same type
typescript generic constraints
typescript generic types allow you to
work with any data type we can however
use constraints to limit it to a
specific types
a type parameter can be declared that is
limited by another type parameter for
instance in this case we would like to
retrieve a property from an object based
on its name we'll put a constraint
between two types to ensure that we are
not obtaining a property that does not
exist on the object
now let us jump into visual studio code
and understand typescript generics more
better so here we are in visual studio
code the prerequisite is we need to
install node.js and we need to install
typescript
so let's get started
let's call the function
function identity
identity function is a function that
returns whatever is sent in as a
parameter we could either provide the
identity function with a specific type
or with any type
so this is the identity function with
specific type
so if we had to write the same
in the identity function with the
specific type so what we'll do
we'll write it with the specific type
so to write it with any type
what we have to do is we'll write any
in place of string
so while the use of n is generic when we
use any the function accepts any kind of
the type of the argument as a result
when the function returns we lose the
information about what that type was the
only information we have is that any
type could have produced if we pass in a
string
so we are passing up the type string
here and maybe we can pass this type as
number as well instead of string
so i can make this function generic by
passing the type any but this will lose
information about what type was passed
so for that we need the means to capture
the argument type in such a way that we
can use it to signify what has been
returned as well so we will utilize a
type variable here which is of the form
variable that deals with the types
rather than the values
so for that we will write the code as we
create a function
identity
so here the identity function now has a
type variable called the type
this type allows us to capture the type
of data the user supplies for example a
number or a string so that we can use it
later we are going to utilize a type as
a return type once more
so we can use one of the two methods to
invoke the generic identity function
after writing it
so i have written a few lines of code
with generic type function
so here i have written a few lines of
code in this example the type variable t
is specified with the function in the
angle brackets get array
so the type variable t also is used to
specify the type of the arguments and
then return the value this means that
the data type which will be specified at
the time of a function call will also be
the data type of the arguments and of
the return value
so we call generic function get array
and the pass numbers array the strings
array for example calling the function
as get array number and we have passed
the numbers as 16 and decimal number 2.0
and 55
this will replace t with the number and
so the type of the arguments and the
return value will be the number array
in the same way for get array string we
have passed the values as hello world
the type arguments and the return value
will be a string array so now the
compiler will show an error if you try
to add a string in number array or a
number in string array thus we get the
type checking advantage
so it is not recommended but we can also
call a generic function without
specifying the type variable the
compiler will use the inference to set
the value of t on the function based on
the data type of the argument values
now let us run this code and check
so let us go to the terminal and let us
first run the command
typescript.cmd and the file name type.ts
enter
now let us run the file
nodetype.js
and here we go
it's showing the number array as
1.5 to 36 and 400 we have pushed two new
values one for the number array it is
value 400 and for the string array hello
typescript
what is react
react is a javascript library for
creating user interfaces that is
declarative efficient and customizable
react allows to build complicated user
interfaces out of components which are
small independent pieces of code
react was first open sourced in 2013 by
facebook and has since become one of the
most popular libraries in the front-end
world
with frameworks like redux react can
simply be extended to integrate
functionality like routing and state
management patterns
features of react
react is an open source library and is
developed by facebook
react apps are fast flexible modular and
scalable
react is powerful javascript libraries
that creates interactive interfaces
popular libraries of react are redux
material design and chest
redux helps manage state in javascript
redux is the most popular of all react
libraries because it easily tracks the
state as the application size grows
react has robust developer community and
variety of libraries
react is declarative and component based
declarative views make the react code
more predictable and easier to debug
and react is component based that is
react let us build encapsulated
components that manage their own state
and compose them to make complex uis
advantages of using typescript with
react
in a react project typescript allows us
to write html code directly
typescript delivers superior
intellisense and code completion for jsx
when used with react
javascript xm is abbreviated as jsx
when using ides like visual studio
visual studio code autumn webstorm
eclipse and others typescript comes in
handy this allows better development by
improving autocomplete and snippet
generation
typescript has code that is easy to read
and understand
typescript is statically typed language
the distinction between statically and
dynamically typed programming languages
is when type checking occurs
variables in static language are type
checked
while creating react app complex type
definitions can be defined as interfaces
in typescript this is useful when you
wish to use a complex type in the
application such as an object with
multiple properties
microsoft supports typescript
an open source programming language
millions of developers all over the
world enjoy and use it this implies that
if you get stuck while learning or using
typescript you can easily obtain help
and answers on the community portal
we can integrate typescript into our
existing react projects for this we can
configure the typescript compiler
installing and configuring typescript
and react
before we install typescript we need to
install node.js
go to the node.js official website and
you can install node.js from there once
you install node.js go to the command
prompt and run this command npm install
hifunji typescript
this command is used to install
typescript globally
once you have installed typescript to
check if the typescript is installed
properly run the command tsc typescript
compiler
hyphen v to check the version of the
typescript compiler
next we need to install react
for installing react and creating a
react project
go to the command prompt and run this
command
npx create react app this command will
create a simple folder structure of the
application then install all the
necessary modules and get the project up
and running for you
first of all we need to install node.js
to install node.js go to the official
website of node
nodejs.org
go to the downloads in downloads here
you can
install the node.js if you have windows
if you have mac os
you can install it from here so i have
windows so i'll install windows since i
have already installed so i'll cancel it
so once you have installed node.js then
go to the command prompt
in command prompt we need to install the
typescript to install the typescript run
the command npm that is node package
manager
install
hyphen g
g stands for installing globally
and then typescript
what this command does is it installs
the typescript globally
run this command once you run this
command the typescript will be installed
since i have already installed
typescript i'll cancel it so after you
have installed typescript to check if
the typescript is installed properly run
the command typescript compiler tsc
space
hyphen hyphen b
and press enter
and this will show the version
and this will show the version of the
typescript installed so i have version
4.5.4 installed in my device
so after this to get started with the
project after successful installation of
node.js and typescript
let us create a new folder
to create a new folder type the command
make directory
and we'll name the folder as
typescript
hyphen
react
so enter
so we have created the new folder
next we'll change the directory to the
folder which we created so cd
to
ts react
so after this we need to initiate the
project
so to initiate the project we will run
the command npm
init
it is asking for package name
just click enter
and
click enter
then is this okay click s
after this what we need to do is create
react app
so to create react app run the command
npx
space create
react tab
and enter
so this command will create a simple
folder structure for your application
and then install all the necessary
modules and get your project up and
running for you
so this is the project folder which i
have already created
i have the vs code folder wherein i have
settings.json files in this then i have
installed all the node modules
then i have the source folder
in source folder i have app.tsx file
counter.esx
index.html declarations
index.exe file
to install webpack just run the command
npm install web pack
space webpack hyphen cli indic terminal
this will install the web pack
so i'll show you a simple hello world or
hello everyone program
so in app.dsx
we'll just type hello everyone
and we'll give the color as green and
align the text at the center input since
we have imported the counter
file so in counter file we'll just type
it subscribe to simply learn with text
align in the center and with the color
red
so we'll just run this
here we go we have the message hello
everyone and subscribe to simply
what is node.js
node.js is an open source server-side
execution platform for javascript code
node.js is a javascript runtime based on
the version 8 javascript engine from
chrome
node is an asynchronous event-driven
javascript runtime for building scalable
network applications
although node.js is excellent for
developing server side apps it lacks
several current features such as type
checking it can also be difficult to
manage a node.js code base
node is commonly used for real-time
applications like chat
news feeds and web push notifications
because it allows for a persistent
connection from the browser to the
server
the current coding method such as static
typing and type checking are supported
by typescript
it's designed to create complex and high
level applications that's why having
typescript as a primary language for
supporting node.js capabilities would be
idle
this also allows us to develop
server-side apps with rigorous type
checking avoiding run type errors and
other typescript benefits while
maximizing node.js capabilities
now let's see how to setup the
development environment for typescript
with node.js
the prerequisites are we need to have
typescript installed in our device and
node.js
to install node.js go to the official
website
go to nodejs.org and go to downloads
so here you can see
we have node.js for different browsers
for windows mac os
and source code
so go to windows if you have windows pc
and click on install
click on windows and here you can see it
is getting installed since i have
already installed in my device
i'll cancel it
so once you have installed go to the
command prompt
and just enter
node.v to check if node is installed
properly
so here you can see the node is
installed in my
system
to install typescript just run the
command npm
node package manager
install
globally
typescript
run this command and typescript will be
installed since i have already installed
typescript in my device
we cancel this so once you have
installed typescript to check if
typescript is installed or not to see if
the compiler is installed just run the
command
typescript compiler space
version
here you can see it will show the
version of typescript compiler
so now that we have installed both
typescript and
node.js let's see
our example program for typescript with
node.js
so let's jump into visual studio code
one more prerequisite is we need to have
visual studio code installed
so create a new folder and create a new
project
so we'll run an example program we'll
create a function
will write a program to add two numbers
so sum
number one
comma number two
will return number one and number two
console.log
we'll call the function sum
and we'll provide the arguments
so we'll provide the value
9 comma
5.
so let's see if and run this program
first we'll run
typescript.cmd
type.ts command
then we'll hit that
then we'll run node and the file name
here you can see
it's showing the value showing the
output as forty nine plus five the sum
of nine plus five is forty so we'll
delete this
and
write another program
to show a hello message or a welcome
message
so we'll create a function
we'll name the function as welcome
message
and will return
that user
is equal to
simply learn
console log
we'll call the function
welcome
and pass
so here we go we'll save this and check
whether we have an error
so here we go showing welcome to simply
learn
what is express.js
express.js is a node.js web application
framework that is free and open source
it is used to quickly and easily design
and create web apps web applications are
applications that can be run through a
web browser because express.js simply
requires javascript
programmers and developers may create
web applications and apis with little
effort
tj holloway chook
express which is now maintained by
node.js and several open source
contributors
to construct our applications express
provides a simple interface it gives us
the resources we need to create our app
it's adaptable because there are a lot
more modules on npm that can be directly
integrated into express
let us look at some of the features of
express.js
server side development is made easier
with express it's possible to create
single page multi-page and hybrid web
apps with express.js
express enables middlewares to respond
to http request to be configured
middleware is primarily responsible for
the orderly structure of express js
various functions
express js has a comprehensive routing
mechanism that uses urls to maintain the
state of a web page
it establishes a routing table that is
used to carry out various operations
based on the http method and url
express.js has templating engines that
enable developers to create dynamic
content for web pages by creating html
templates on the server
express js simplifies debugging by
offering a debugging mechanism that can
pinpoint a particular area of the web
application that is causing problems
advantages of express.js
express.js makes developing node.js web
applications quickly and easily
express.js is simple to set up and
personalize
it allows to define application routes
using http methods and urls
express.js includes a number of
middleware modules that can be used to
execute additional request and responses
activities
it is simple to interface with a variety
of template engines including
jade vash and ejs
it allows us to specify middleware for
handling errors
express is used to make a rest api
server and it's simple to provide your
application static files and resources
databases such as mongodb redis and
mysql are simple to connect to a
express.js
now let us look at the demo on
typescript express the prerequisites are
we need to have an editor maybe visual
studio code then we need to have node.js
installed and a package manager
installed such as npm or yarn
so we'll jump into visual studio code
here i have created a new folder
named express type script then we will
go to the terminal
next we'll run the command
npx
type script
hyphen init will initialize typescript
next to initialize the node.js
application will run the command
yarn
in it
once we have initialized the node.js
application we just need to click enter
just click enter
and we have successfully saved the
package.json file
next we need to
make a new directory
we'll make a new directory source
next we'll install the touch cli
globally
with the command npm install
touch
cli
so after installing this we'll run the
command
touch
source inside the source folder we will
create the file app.ts
so here you can see we have created the
file app.ts inside the source folder
so after this we will install typescript
to install typescript run the command
yarn
add
type script
node
dev
type script
happening
so after this we need to install express
to install express run the command
yarn
space add
express
next we need to add node modules and
express modules for that run the command
yarn
add
type slash node
type slash express
so let us now go to the app.ts file
and
run the code
and close this
so i'll copy paste a few lines of code
here
wherein i have imported express
module
the constant app creates an express
function
and we have express.json
and we have returning a message hello
world
so we'll save this and we are running it
on the local host with port number 3000
so we'll save this
and
run it
to run it we'll just
run the command e on
def
so application is listening at the
local host 3000 so we'll copy this
and open in the browser
here we got showing the message hello
world
similarly we have routing
like this example with app.get and
app.host the app object provides a
collection of functions that attach
callbacks to http request made to
defined destinations
and other http methods such as post put
patch and delete can also have callbacks
attached to them
the router object is another approach to
setup routing
you can call the get put and patch and
delete methods on a router object just
like you do on a app object
and similarly we have request and
response
so the request object holds information
about http request including headers
query strings and parameters
when when an http request is received
the response object represents the http
response that the application provides
similarly for response the send method
is the most significant one it sends the
http response to the client so that it
can be received
the function accepts a variety of data
kinds including strings objects arrays
and buffers
the send method finishes the response
process with data but you can
alternatively use the end function to
end it without any data
the request and response objects are
accessible to middleware function
it can join the request response cycle
at any point
a third argument that middleware
receives is the next function
the get callback which processes the
http get request that we wrote in this
example
is an example of middleware
it's highly unique middleware that only
works in one situation they can also
carry out more general duties
we'll first look at type assertions
type assertion is similar to typecast in
other languages but it does not do any
additional verification or restructuring
it has no effect on runtime and is only
used by the compiler typescript expects
that you the programmer have completed
the necessary and specific checks
so there are two types of assertions
one is the as syntax
and the other one is the angle bracket
syntax both versions are identical
choosing one over the other is primarily
a matter of preference
however only as style assertions are
allowed when combining typescript with
jsx
type aliases type aliases give a type a
new name
type aliases are similar to interfaces
in that they can be used to name
primitives unions tuples and any other
kind that you would have to define by
hand otherwise
aliasing doesn't truly create a new type
instead it gives the type a new name
aliasing a primitive isn't very useful
however it can be used for documentation
purposes
type aliases like interfaces can be
general all we have to do is add type
parameters and utilize them on the right
side of the alias declaration
this is the syntax for type aliases
type generics
type generics is a tool for creating
reusable components in typescript
rather than working with a single data
type it builds a component that can
interact with various data kinds it
enables users to consume these
components while also using their kinds
generics ensure that the software is
both adaptable and scalable over time
consider the below code without generics
the identity function is a function that
returns whatever is sent in as a
parameter you could either provide the
identity function with a specific type
or the identity function with any type
while the use of any is generic when you
use any the function accepts any kind
for the type of argument
as a result when the function returns
you lose the information about what the
type was
the only information you have is that
any type could be produced if you pass a
string
so for that we need the means to capture
the argument type in such a way that we
can use it to signify what is being
returned as well
we will utilize a type variable here
which is a form of variable that deals
with the types rather than values
the identity function now has a type
variable called type this type allows
you to capture the type of data the user
supplies
for example
a number or a string so that you can use
it later you are going to utilize type
as the return type once more
next we'll look at the in operator
the in operator serves as a type
narrowing expression
the true branch narrows to types that
have an optional or required property n
and the false branch narrows to the
types that have an optional or missing
property n
for a n in x expression
where n is a string literal or a string
literal type and x is the union type
below is an example code for inoperator
null and undefined are two special types
in typescript that have the values null
and undefined respectively they are not
particularly useful much like void
null and undefined are subclasses of all
other types by default that means you
can give things like number null and
undefined values
when the strict null checks flag is set
however null and undefined can also be
assigned to unknown any and the
respective types
this helps you avoid a lot of frequent
errors you can use them as union type
string null and undefined if you want to
send in either a string null or a
undefined
next we have index types
using index types we can get the
compiler to check code that utilizes
dynamic property
names by using index types a typical
javascript pattern for example is to
select a subset of an object's property
we may build and use this function in
typescript using the index type query
and index access operators
let us jump into visual studio code and
understand index types more better
so consider this code as an example for
index types
here key of t the index type query
operator
for any type t p of t is the union of
non-public property names of t
and t of k the indexed access operator
is the second operator
the type syntax reflects the expression
syntax in this case
and t of k can be like index type
queries be used in generic environment
which is where its truly potential can
be seen
all we have to do now is make sure that
the type variable k extends e of t
in get property o
t and property name k so that means of
property name the compiler will initiate
the actual type of the key after you
return t of k result therefore the
return type of get property will change
depending on which property you request
index signature
index signature interact with the key of
and the t of k
the type of an index signature argument
must be either a string or a number
if your type has a string index
signature key of t will be a string or a
number because in javascript you can
access an object property using either a
string or number
t of string is simply the index
signature type
below is the syntax for index signature
if you have a type with number index
signature e of t will just be a number
map types
taking an existing type and making each
of its property optional is a typical
undertaking because this happens
frequently enough in javascript
typescript has a new feature called map
types that allows you to define new
types based on existing ones
the new types turn each property in the
old type in the same way in a map type
for example make all the properties
optional or the read-only type
it's important to note that this syntax
refers to the type rather than a member
you can use an intersection type to add
more members
this is the simplest map type and its
parts the syntax is similar to the index
signature with a 4 in the middle
there are three sections in total
the type variable k is assigned to each
property one by one
the little union of string the names of
the properties to iterate over a stored
in case
and third one the properties type is a
result
next we have conditional types
based on the condition given as a type
relationship test
a conditional type chooses one of the
two alternative types when t can be
assigned to u the type is x and when it
can't the type is y
because the condition depends on one or
more type variable a conditional type t
extends u
so x is to y and is either resolved to x
or y or delayed
whether to resolve to x or y or to
differ when t or u contains type
variables is determined by whether the
type system has enough information to
conclude that t is always assignable to
you
in conditional types we also have
distributive conditional type
that is a conditional type in which the
check type is bait type parameter
during instantiation distributive
conditional types are automatically
distributed over union types
supporting libraries from node modules
typescript includes a series of
declaration files to guarantee that
typescript and javascript support works
well right out of the box
and typescript includes a series of
declaration files however there are two
drawbacks to using these declaration
files with typescript
one drawback is since while upgrading
typescript
we must also deal with the changes of
typescript built-in declaration files
which can be difficult when the dom apis
change so regularly
and the other
drawback is that customizing these files
to meet your needs and the demands of
project dependencies is difficult
so to overcome this a new feature like
types
was added that allow us to override a
specific built-in library
then we can update typescript and lock
the file in dependency management
ensuring that it utilizes the same
version of dom types
as a result we can update the types on
our own schedule
then with
then with typescript 4.5
we can update typescript and log file in
our dependency management
await type and promise
improvements the weighted type is the
new utility introduced in typescript
this type is intended to represent
activities such as await in async
functions and the then method on
promises
notably the way they recursively unwrap
promises
existing api such as javascript built in
like promise.all
promise.race and others can benefit from
awaited time
in fact some of promised.all inference
concerns provided as foundation for
awaited promise.all combines certain
traits with awaited to produce far
superior inference results
tail recursion elimination on
conditional types
when typescript identifies potential
infinite recursion or any type expansion
that take a long time and damage your
editor experience
it often leak fails
as a result typescript includes
heuristics to ensure that it doesn't run
off the tracks while deconstructing an
indefinitely deep type or working with
types that provide a lot of intermediate
results
let's jump into visual studio code and
look at an example
the trim left type for example removes
spaces from the beginning of string like
time when provided a string type with
space at the beginning trim left returns
the reminder of the string to the user
this type is handy but it will throw an
error if a string contains more than 50
leading spaces
this is problematic because these types
are frequently used in modeling
operations on strings
such as parsers for url routers
to make matters worse a more powerful
type useful generates more type
installations resulting in even
additional input length restrictions
trim left is written in such a way that
it is tail recursive on one branch when
it calls itself again it returns a
result instantly and does nothing with
it
because these types don't require any
intermediate outcomes they can be
constructed more rapidly and without
activating many of typescript built-in
type recursion heuristics
next we have assert signatures
the set signature features allow us to
construct functions that operate as type
cards as a side effect
instead of returning their boolean
result explicitly
consider a below example
after a search ring typescript has no
way of knowing if you have guaranteed
the type of input
to prevent this most people just make
the parameter input string which is fine
but it also moves the type checking
problem somewhere and in circumstances
where you just want to fail hard having
this option is beneficial
if this function ever returns typescript
can filter the type of input to string
exactly like it would be if it were
inside an if block with a type card
to make this safe the asset function
must either give an error or not return
at all if the asset
assession isn't true
and lastly we have recursive type
aliases
the ability to recursively reference
type aliases has been limited
the reason for which
is because each type aliases must be
capable of substituting itself for
whatever it aliases
because this isn't always possible the
compiler rejects some recursive aliases
interfaces can be recursive but their
expressiveness is limited and type
aliases cannot that involves combining
the two creating a type alias and
extracting the type's recursive
operations into interfaces
interfaces can be recursive but their
expressiveness is limited and type
aliases cannot
that involves combining the two creating
a type alias and extracting the types
recursive portions into interfaces it's
effective
by establishing an interface users may
write what was practically the same code
typescript has no trouble working with
the interfaces and other object types
because they introduce a level of
indirection
and their whole structure does not need
to be eagerly built up
however many found the workaround of
introducing the interface to be
inconvenient
and there was nothing wrong with the old
version of value or array that used
array directly in concept
this is the chat application where we
have two users
and from the user one will send the
message hello
and the user 2 will receive it and from
the user 2 will send the message hi
and the user 1 receives it so this is
basically a simple chat application how
we can create
how are you
so this is basically a simple chat
application which we can create
so in this video we will learn to make
this chat application from the scratch
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply learn watch
the video till the end so that you don't
miss out anything so without wasting any
further time let's get started first of
all we will create a new folder
so i'll go to my d drive and i'll create
a new folder
i'll name the folder as
chat tab
so after creating this new folder
so we will go to visual studio code open
a new window in new window we will open
the folder which we created
we created the folder in d drive
we will first create the user interface
to create the user interface for that we
need to create a new file called
index.html
so i've successfully created the new
file index.html
so we'll change the title
we'll name the title as io chat
next after this will open the link
before this we should know what is cdn
a cdn is a network of servers that
distributes content from an origin
server throughout the world by catching
content close to where each end user is
accessing the internet via a web enabled
device
the content they request is first stored
on the origin server and is then
replicated and stored elsewhere as
needed
so we will use bootstrap cdn and query
cdn for our project
so we'll use the link tag
the link element allows authors to link
the document to other resources
we'll click on the link
so for this to get the bootstrap cdn
we will
go to the browser and type bootstrap cdn
so we'll copy this link
for bootstrap cdn
and we'll paste it here
bootstrap is the most popular css
framework for developing responsive and
mobile first websites
bootstrap 5 is the newest version of
bootstrap
and bootstrap is free open source css
framework directed at responsive mobile
first front-end web development
it contains css and javascript based on
design templates for forms buttons
navigation and other interface
components
after this next we need jquery cdn
next we will
next we'll get the jquery cdn and write
it in the script tags
so i'll select script
the script element allows authors to
include dynamic script and data blocks
in the documents
the element does not represent content
for the user
to get the cdn for jquery
go to the browser
and just type
jquery cdn
and open the first link
click on uncompressed
and
copy this
go back to the visual studio code
and
paste it
so after this is done
jquery is fast small and feature red
javascript library it makes things like
html document transversal and
manipulation event handling animation
and ajax much simpler with an easy to
use api
that works across a multitude of browser
with the combination of versatility and
extensibility
so after this we'll take one more script
tag
and this time we will include
the
we'll take one more script tag inside
this script tag we will enter the client
site socket dot io web api that will
work inside the browser you can go to
the browser and search socket dot io you
will get all the information related to
socket socket.io
so just go and type
socket.io
here
just go to the browser and type
socket.io and on this website socket.io
you have all the documentation and all
the details to get started with
socket.io so you can go through the
socket.io here
so in the script tags
i'll write source
and just type socket
or type of slash
socket dot io dot js
so after this
we'll create a new div tag
so the div element has no special
meaning at all it represents its
children it can be used with the class
language and title attributes to markup
semantics common to a group of
consecutive elements
so inside this div will create a new
class
new class container
so class is basically a space separated
list of classes of the element classes
allow css and javascript to select and
access specific elements via the class
selector or functions like the method
document get elements by class name
so after this
we'll create another div
class
rule
inside this will create one more diff
class
this scholar medium for this class is
used when the device size is medium or
greater than 768 pixel and the maximum
width of the container is 720 pixel and
you want the width equal to 4 columns
that is when we use this function column
medium 4.
next we will create another div
class
well
so after this will provide the heading
h3
the h3 element represents a section
heading
so in this will provide the heading as
online users
you can change the headings whatever you
want to but i'll keep it as online users
so after this will create an unordered
list
in this class
list group
and id
so after this we'll create a one more
div
in this div class
we'll provide column medium of size 8.
this column medium 8 starts for large
column
then we'll create a div another div
class chat
where id
is equal to chat
then i'll create a form
this form element represents a
collection of form associated elements
some of which can represent editable
values that can be submitted into a
server or processing
perform id
is equal to
for message form
this will create a div class
form group
next we'll create the label
so label element represents a caption in
a user interface the caption can be
associated with specific form control
known as label elements labeled
controlled either using for attribute or
by putting the form control inside the
label element
itself so use the label element inside
that will write enter message
next we'll create a text area
use the label text area
so inside text area we'll create a class
form control
and
id
message
so text area element represents a
multi-line plain text edit control for
the elements raw value the contents of
the control represent the control
default value
after the text area
will
just
write
then we will create an input element
input element of
will
assign a type submit
class
button
value
send message
in double quotes
so this input basically it represents a
type data field usually with the form
control to allow the user to edit the
data
so we have finished with the user
interface we'll just save this
and run it in the browser
right click and open with live server
so here we go
we have created the html
but
we we will now create assign few css
elements
we just need the margin top
for the body so we'll assign that
so we'll create styles element
the style element allows authors to
embed style information in their
documents the style element is one of
the several inputs to the styling
processing model the element does not
represent content for the user
so in the style
we'll just write this body
and will assign margin top
30 pixel
save this and we'll go to the browser
and just refresh
so till now we have created the user
interface
we'll just go to the browser and run
this user interface
just right click and click on open with
live server
now we will create a new file called
server.js
and will go to the terminal
in terminal we will run two commands
first of all we need to install
socket.typo for that we'll run npm
and there is one prerequisite we need to
have node.js installed in our device
so then run the command node package
manager npm
install
socket.typo
is a library that enables real-time
bi-directional and even-based
communication between the browser and
the server
it consists of a node.js server and a
javascript client library for the
browser
after installing socket.io then we need
to install express
for that run the command npm install
express
express is a minimal and flexible
node.js web application framework that
provides a robust set of features for
web and mobile applications
after installing socket.typeon express
you will get these two files
packet.json file
and package
log.json
next go to the
server.js wherein i will paste few lines
of code
in the line 1 creates an express
application the express function is a
top level function exported by the
express module
then we have const listen
and then we require and socket dot io
then we we have created a variable app
express method then we have created a
variable server
so this server
that is we use the module http
so it creates a module http to use the
http server and client we must require
http the http interfaces in node.js are
designed to support many features of the
protocol which have been traditionally
difficult to use in particular large
possible chunk encoded messages the
interface is careful to never buffer
entire request or responses so the user
is able to stream data
then we have another variable io where
we require socket dot io server
and similarly we are listening in the
port 3000
so in port 3000 it starts a server
listening for connection
a net dot server can be an tcp or an ipc
server depending on what it listens to
do
then we have app.get
here the request is declared but its
value is never read we have request and
response
then we are routing it on the local host
3000
so in this line we are transferring the
file at the given path so automatically
sets the content type response header
field the callback is invoked when the
transfer is complete or when an error
occurs
be sure to check request response sent
if you wish to attempt responding as the
header and some data may be already been
transferred
here we are connecting the client to the
server and here we add plug details to
the customer array and here we are
checking the current connections
and then we disconnect from the server
using the disconnect function
next we delete the plug details and
the again we show the current
connections
here for on the socket.on we send
messages function data and then we
console.log the data then we emit the
new messages
so then we have written console.log
server is listening
so now we will run this code and check
if the server is listening
now we'll check if the server is
listening for that we'll run the command
node
server
and here we go server is listening
now we will just go and
run the local host 3000 on the browser
go to the
new tab and just run localhost 3000
and here we go
it's running
and when we come back to the code
we can see it shows one socket connected
so again if we go and open it in a new
browser
and just run the local host
and go back to the code
it will show two sockets connected
so we are almost done we just have a
small part left out we'll go to
index.html
and here
we'll just scroll down
and above body we'll just paste few
lines of code
so here basically we are just creating a
function to get data form
so we'll get message form
and we'll we are creating variables
message and we are creating variables
chat
so basically in this line we will know
form between click event handle
and
then we will prevent default from
submission
next in this line we will trap data for
text box and call server
then we'll create clear
then we will clear the form text box
then we'll console.log submitted
our program is finished
now we'll just run and check the code
so we'll save this code
go to the browser
refresh it
so i have the two browsers i have opened
it in two separate window we'll just
check if the application is working so
we'll send the message hi
and here we go we have received the
message so we can say hello
the chat application is working
successfully
we'll first look at beginner level
interview questions
what is typescript
typescript is an object oriented and
strongly typed programming language
which is a superset of javascript
typescript was designed by anders
hegelsberg at microsoft the limitations
of javascript for developing large-scale
applications at microsoft and among its
external customers led to the creation
of typescript
because of the difficulty of working
with complicated javascript code there
was a demand for custom tooling to make
developing javascript components easier
typescript code is converted to
javascript which can be executed
anywhere javascript is supported in the
browser or nodejs or any other
application
typescript is javascript with some
additional features to support a more
robust interaction with your editor
typescript adds additional syntax to
javascript
typescript is a scripting language that
understands javascript and uses type
inference to provide powerful
capabilities without additional code
explain the features of typescript
typescript supports other javascript
libraries typescript is a new microsoft
language that is highly typed superset
of javascript with support for object
oriented programming and other current
features like decorators
because browsers and nodejs comprehend
javascript typescript compiles
javascript
typescript is portable typescript is
cross browser cross device and cross
platform it can run in any environment
that supports javascript
typescript unlike its computators does
not require a dedicated virtual machine
or a specific runtime environment to run
typescript is superset of javascript it
is strongly syntactical that superset of
javascript with the addition of optional
static typing typescript is a large
scale application development language
that transcompiles to javascript
existing javascript programs are also
valid typescript programs because
typescript is a superset of javascript
typescript is static
when a client doesn't have a value for a
parameter he can personal optional
arguments are a feature of typescript
you can declare some arguments in the
function optional by utilizing optional
parameter features so that the client is
not necessary to supply a value to
optional parameters
object-oriented language when it comes
to object-oriented programming with
javascript typescript shines
because of the class keyword it makes
object-oriented programming look quite
similar to programming in other
object-oriented languages like c-sharp
or java
what are export and import keywords in
typescript
import keyword is used to export
declaration example export star from
module
and the export keyword is used to export
any variable function and type aliases
below is the example for import keyword
and export keyword
can typescript be used for the backend
typescript can be generally used for
backend applications by using node.js
and having additional safety that the
language brings
how to declare a variable in typescript
let and const are the two methods to
declare variables variable names can
contain alphabets and numeric digits
they cannot contain spaces and special
characters except the underscore and the
dollar sign variable names cannot begin
with the digital is the example code
where we have declared a variable with
let method and we have declared a
variable inside a function
list the applications of typescript
script can be used to develop javascript
applications for both client-side and
server-side execution
typescript can be deployed instead of
javascript language since it adds more
features and gives error directly with
the code typescript is used for building
large-scale applications for enterprises
how can a base constructor be called
from a child class
a base class constructor can be called
from child class using the super method
as shown in the example
what are getters and setters
getters and sectors intercept access to
a member of the object
they give us a way of having finer grain
control over how a member access each
objects a getter method starts with the
keyword get
and the setter method starts with the
keyword set
what is the purpose of
tsconfig.json file
tsconfig.json file is a json format file
in which we can specify different
options to tell the compiler how to
compile a given project this file in the
directory indicates that the directory
is the typescript project root
list the advantages of typescript
typescript highlights errors at the
compilation time during the time of
development
any browser or javascript engine can run
typescript
it has a namespace concept by defining a
module typescript supports strongly
typed or static typing typescript has
the advantages of being tightly typed or
allowing static typing
it may confirm type correctness at the
compile time because of static typing
what are rest parameters in typescript
when the number of parameters that a
function will receive is not known or
can vary we can use rest parameters
we can pass zero or more arguments to
the rest parameters the compiler will
create an array of arguments with the
rest parameter name
how to compile typescript with visual
studio code
visual studio code includes typescript
language support but does not include
the typescript compiler we need to
install the typescript compiler either
globally or in your workspace to
transpile typescript source code to
javascript the easiest way to install
typescript is through node package
manager
the node.js package manager if you have
npm installed you can install typescript
globally on your computer by using this
command npm install hyphen g type script
we can test the installed typescript by
checking the version or help for this
run the command tsc hyphen hyphen
version
list access modifier supported by
typescript typescript supports three
access modifiers
protected
private
and public in protected all class
members can access them but the instance
cannot but in private it's only
accessible by members whereas in public
it is accessible by members child
classes and instance of the class
list the disadvantages of typescript the
typescript takes a long time to compile
the code typescript does not support
abstract classes
an extra compilation step for converting
typescript into javascript typescript
has overly complicated typing system
how to debug a typescript file
to debug a typescript file a dot js
source map file is needed to debug the
file
compile the dot ts file with the source
map flag for generating source map file
use the command
type script tsc space hyphen source map
file.ts source mapping url is equal to
file.js.map
how can we convert a string to a number
with typescript in typescript conversion
from a string to a number can be done
using the following commands parse int
method
and we have parse float method
and number method
explain type aliases
type aliases give a type a new name type
aliases are similar to interfaces in
that they can be used to name primitives
unions tuples and any other kinds that
you would have to define by hand
otherwise
aliasing doesn't truly create a new type
instead it gives that type a new name
aliasing a primitive isn't very useful
however it can be used for documentation
purposes type aliases like interfaces
can be in general
all we have to do is add type parameters
and utilize them on the right side of
alias declaration below is the syntax
for type aliases
what are nullable types in typescript
null and undefined are the two special
types in typescript that have the values
null and undefined respectively they are
not particularly useful much like void
null and undefined are subclasses of all
other types by default
that means you can give things like
number null and undefined values
when the strict null checks flag is said
however null and undefined can only be
assigned to unknown
any and their respective types the one
exception being that undefined is also
assignable to want this helps to avoid a
lot of frequent errors you can use the
union type string null undefined if you
want to send in either a string null or
undefined
what is in operator in typescript
the in operator serves as a type
narrowing expression
the true branch narrows to types that
have been an optional or required
property n and the false branch narrows
to the types that have an optional or
missing properties in for a n in x
expression as shown in the example below
where n is a string literal or string
literal type
and x is a union type explain index
types in typescript
using index types we can get the
compiler to check code that utilizes the
dynamic property names a typical
javascript pattern for example is to
select a subset of an object properties
we may build and use this function in
typescript using the index type query
and indexed access operators
in this example key of t the index type
query operator for any type t key of t
is the union of known public property
names of t and t of k the indexed axis
operator is the second operator the type
syntax reflects the expression syntax in
this case t of k can be like index type
queries be used in generic environment
which is where it's truly potentially
seen all you have to do now is make sure
that the type variable k
extends to k of t
what are map types
typescript has a feature called map
types that allow you to define new types
based on the existing ones the new type
turns each property into the old type in
the same way in a map type
it's important to note that this syntax
refers to a type rather than a member
you can use an intersection type to add
more numbers as you can see in the
example it is the simplest map type and
its parts are type keys and type flags
where syntax is similar to the index
signatures
with 4 in the middle there are 3
sections in total
the type variable k is assigned to each
property one by one
and the literal union of strings the
name of properties to iterate over the
stored in case
and properties type as a result
what is meant by contextual typing
when there is a type on one side of the
equation but not on the other the
typescript compiler finds out the form
we can omit typing on the right side as
typescript can work it out automatically
this increases the amount of work needed
to type code
distinguish between typescript and
javascript typescript is an object
oriented programming language whereas
javascript is a scripting language
typescript supports static typing
javascript does not support static
typing
in typescript error can be found and
corrected during a compile time in
javascript errors can be found only
during runtime as it is an interpreted
language
there is support for
es3 es4 5 and 6 in typescript
whereas in javascript no support for
compiling
in-type script functions can have
optional parameters whereas in
javascript this is not possible
in typescript converted into javascript
code
to be understandable for browsers
javascript can be directly used in
browsers
typescript has proper build setup don't
package manager is required for static
type definitions no build setup is
required in javascript
what is jsx
jsx is an xml like syntax that can be
embed it is intended to be turned into
legitimate javascript though the
semantics of that transformation will
vary depending on the implementation
typescript allows you to embed
jsx type verify it and compile it to
javascript immediately jsx needs to be
translated into a valid typescript we
use the jsx file with the
tsx extension
define static typing
static typing refers to a compiler
having variables parameters and object
members that are recognizable at the
compilation type this helps in detecting
early errors static typing as is an
important concept
static typing is when the compiler
enforces that the values use the same
type here's an example
what is meant by type inference
when you don't specify an explicit type
for variable typescript can infer it
type inference is the term for this this
is normally done during the declaration
when the variables or parameters are
initialized
typescript recognizes that the variable
foo is a string even if we don't mention
string as a type
here is an example
how to create objects in typescript
objects are collection of keys and
values that resemble a dictionary
the keys must be one of a kind three
symbol rs and are sometimes referred to
as associate arrays
an object type in typescript refers to
any value with properties it can be
defined simply by specifying the
properties and the kinds of these
properties
as an example
explain different data types in
typescript
number both integer and floating point
numbers are represented by the data type
number
boolean has true and false values
string it is used to denote a string of
characters
void is usually applied to function
return types
null it's used when an object isn't
worth anything
undefined indicates the value assigned
to an uninitialized variable
any any type of value can be assigned to
a variable if declared with any data
type
what are the benefits of using
typescript
compilation javascript is an interpreted
language thus there is no need to
compile it as a result it must be run to
ensure authenticity if there is an error
you write all the code only to find no
output as a result you will have to
spend hours looking for faults in the
code
error checking is provided via the
typescript transpiler if typescript
detects any syntax mistakes it will
compile the code and generate
compilation error
this aids in detecting errors before the
execution of the script
the next benefit is it provides an
optional type system for javascript code
when a client doesn't have a value for a
parameter he can pass null
optional arguments are a feature of
typescript
you can declare some optional arguments
in the function by utilizing optional
parameter features so the decline does
not need to supply a value to optional
parameters
strong static typing
javascript does not have a powerful
static typing system
through the tls typescript comes with an
optional static typing and type
inference system the tls can deduce the
type of variable defined with node type
based on its value
typescript supports object-oriented
programming typescript support classes
interfaces inheritance and other
object-oriented programming principles
typescript supports type definition
existing javascript libraries can use
typescript type definitions
external javascript libraries are
defined in typescript definition files
as a result it can include these
libraries in typescript code
how to install typescript
typescript is a javascript programming
language for use in application
typescript extends javascript with
optional types that support tools for
large scale javascript application in
any browser or any host on any other
operating system to install typescript
globally with node package manager which
means you can run the typescript command
from anywhere in your terminal to
install the latest stable version of
typescript you just need to run the
command npm install hyphen g space type
script this will install the latest
version of typescript
what are decorators
a decorator is a type of declaration
that can be used to decorate the class
declaration method accessor property or
argument
decorators take the form
expression where expression must
evaluate to a function
that will be called with information
about the decorated declaration when it
is called at runtime
what are mixins
combining simpler particle classes is a
popular approach of constructing classes
from reusable components
for languages like scala you may be
familiar with the concept of mixins or
characteristics
to extend a base class the design relies
on generics and class inheritance
the finest mix in support
in typescript is provided through the
class expression pattern
explain classes in typescript
classes are not supported in javascript
es5 or earlier this feature that
typescript inherits from es6
a class is a collection of items with
similar characteristics fields methods
constructor blocks
nested classes and interfaces are all
included in the classes
below is the syntax to declare a class
in terms of oops a class is a template
for producing objects
what is a namespace and how to declare
it
the namespace is used to group
functionalities logically to enable a
single or group of link functionalities
the namespace can include interfaces
classes functions and variables
the namespace keyword followed by the
namespace name can be used to construct
a namespace curly brackets can be used
to define all interfaces classes and
other objects
below is the syntax for namespace
explain the components of typescript
internally the typescript language is
separated into three layers each of this
layer is further subdivided into
language compiler
and language services
language it is written in typescript and
includes typescript language components
it includes syntax keywords and type
annotations
compiler the typescript compiler
converts typescript programs into
javascript code it also converts our
typescript code to javascript code
parsing and type checking it
it provides information that allows
editors and other tools to deliver
greater assistance capabilities like
automated refactoring and intelligence
it adds a layer of abstraction to the
core compiler pipeline
what are the recent advancements in
typescript
typescript 4.2 has been released and it
includes more flexible type annotations
tougher checks and additional
configuration choices and a few breaking
changes
rest arguments can now be placed
anywhere in triple type in type error
messages type aliases are no longer
enlarged resulting in a better developer
experience
typescript 4.2 brings the language one
step closer to its aim of accurately
typing javascript at any size anywhere
javascript is used
describe as syntax in typescript
the as is an additional syntax in
typescript for type assertion it was
introduced as the original syntax
conflicted with jsx
while using jsx with typescript only as
style assertions can be used
define lambda function
typescript provides shorthand syntax for
defining function expressions a lambda
function is an anonymous function
without a name
below is an example for lambda function
what are conditional types in typescript
based on a condition given as a type
relationship test a conditional type
chooses one of the two alternative types
when t can be assigned to you the type
is x and when t can't the type is y
because the condition depends on one or
more type variables a conditional type t
extends to u
x is to y and is either resolved to x or
y or delayed whether to resolve to x or
y or to differ when t or u contains type
variables is determined by whether the
type systems has enough information to
conclude that t is always assignable to
you
what is an interface with reference to
typescript
the interface defines the syntax for
classes to follow a class implementing
an interface implements all its members
it can be reference but not instantiated
typescript compiler uses an interface
for type checking
what is a declare keyword in typescript
as javascript does not have typescript
declaration to use it in the typescript
file without any compilation error
declare keyword is used
the keyword is used for ambient methods
and declarations to define a variable
that exists elsewhere
now we will look at advanced level
interview questions
what are object oriented principles
supported by typescript
all object oriented principles
encapsulation inheritance polymorphism
and obstruction are supported by
typescript
encapsulation is a major component of
object oriented programming language and
its method of structuring code so that
each block of code has its own set of
access points for external code
polymorphism occurs when many class
inherit from the same parent and
overwrite the same functionality
each of those kit classes is now
responsible for implementing a property
or method but they may do so it on their
own unique way
inheritance
typescript makes creating an object
model and inheritance chain a breeze to
construct classes
simply use the standard class keyword
abstraction is a method of modeling
objects in a system that separates the
responsibilities of the classes or type
from the code that inherits it
explain index signatures in typescript
index signatures interact with the key
of and t of k the type of an index
signature argument must be either a
string or a number
if your type has a string index
signature key of t will be a string
or a number because in javascript we can
access an object property using either
string or numbers and t of string is
simply the index signatures type
the index signature consists of the
index name and its type in square
bracket
followed by colon and the value type
what are assert signatures
the asset signature features allows us
to construct functions that operate as
type guards as a side effect
instead of returning their boolean
result explicitly
after a search string typescript has no
way of knowing if you have guaranteed
the type of input to prevent this most
people just make the parameter input
string which is fine
but it also moves the type of checking
problem somewhere and in circumstances
where you just want to fail hard having
the option is beneficial
what is type assertion explain its types
a type assertion is similar to a type
cast in other languages but it does not
do any additional data verification or
restructuring it has no effect on
runtime and is only used by the compiler
there are two types of assertions
one is the as syntax other is the angle
bracket syntax
below is the example for as syntax and
angle bracket syntax
explain how typescript files can be
supported from node modules
typescript includes a series of
declaration files however there are two
drawbacks to using this declaration
files with typescript
one is while upgrading typescript we
must deal with changes to typescript's
built-in declaration files
and the other is customizing these files
to meet the needs and the demands of
project dependencies is difficult
a new feature like at the rate types was
added that allows to override the
specific built in library then we can
update typescript and the log file
independency management ensuring that it
utilizes the same version of the dom
types as a result we can update the
types on our own schedule
explain the typescript generics
typescript generics is a tool for
creating reusable components in
typescript it builds a component that
can interact with various data kinds it
enables users to consume these
components while also using their own
kinds
the identity function now has a type
variable called type
this type allows us to capture the type
of data the user supplies for example a
number or a string so that we can use it
later we are going to utilize type as
the return type once more below is the
syntax for typescript generics
what is recursive type aliases
the ability to recursively reference
type aliases has always been eliminated
the reason for this is because each type
aliases must be capable of substituting
itself for whatever it aliases
interfaces can be recursive
but their expressiveness is limited and
type aliases cannot
that involves combining the two creating
a type aliases and extracting the types
recursive portions into interfaces it's
effective
typescript has no trouble working with
the interfaces and the other object
types because they introduce a level of
indirection and their whole structure
does not need to be eagerly built up
explain tale recursion elimination on
conditional types
when typescript identifies infinite
recursion or any type expansions that
take a long time and damage your editor
experience
as a result typescript includes
heuristics to ensure that it doesn't run
off the tracks while working with types
that provide a lot of intermediate
results
the trim left type removes spaces from
the beginning of string like type when
provided a string type with the space at
the beginning trim left returns a
reminder of the string to the user
advance typescript removes tail
recursion from conditional types it can
prevent
intermediary instantiations as one
branch of conditional type is merely
another conditional type
explain the awaited type and promise
improvements this type is intended to
represent activities such as await in
async functions and the dot then method
on promises notably the way they
recursively unwrap promises
existing apis such as javascript
built-ins like promise.all promise.trace
and others can benefit from the awaited
type in fact some of promise dot all's
inference concerns provided as
foundation for awaited
promise.all combine certain traits with
the awaited to produce far superior
inference results
and with that we have come to the end of
this full course tutorial if you enjoyed
watching the video do give it a thumbs
up comment your doubts below and our
experts will answer them for you
thank you so much for being here watch
out for more videos from us until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you